in this course you are going to learn
about augmented reality from both a
theoretical and practical perspective
this course is for absolute beginners
and you will learn the fundamentals
along with ar development with unity
c-sharp and other tools
hello everyone and welcome to this
course of augmented reality this course
teaches you the theoretical and
practical prospects of augmented reality
from the very basics to a level where
one can develop any augmented reality
application they want
after this course you'll be able to
develop your own augmented reality
applications and filters so this is
about the course now let's know a little
bit about me
so i am priyanshi bhattacharjee i have
worked with multiple startups as an exar
developer and have taught over 200
students about extended reality at
different colleges and universities
i also run a youtube channel called
coded reality where i make content on
augmented reality virtual reality and
mixed reality so now let's you know
discuss about the syllabus of the our
augmented reality course
so we will start by understanding the
fundamental concepts of augmented
reality virtual reality and mixed
reality and at the end of our first
module we're getting an idea about the
market size and growth of extended
reality over the years
in module 2 we will start to learn about
a game engine called unity3d which we'll
be using to design and develop our
augmented reality applications
then in module 3 we'll be starting with
a programming language
c
that will be using to code our augmented
reality applications in which we'll be
learning about the basics of programming
with c-sharp and many other fundamental
concepts
then in module 4 we will start with
developing our ar applications we learn
about market-based ar in depth including
its architecture and how marker-based ar
really works then we'll be learning
about the sdks and start developing
applications with an ar sdk called view
fourier engine
after the completion of this module we
will be moving forward with module 5 in
which we'll be developing three ar
application which includes ar card
customizer air business card and ar
encyclopedia after we learned to develop
ar applications we'll move on to
module 6 which is a bonus section
where we will be learning to develop our
own ar filters for instagram and
facebook and then in module 7 which is
also a bonus module we will end this
course by creating our
very own 3d ar filter
here i present to you some of the ar
applications and filters we will be
building throughout the course so this
is
an ar filter which will be building
and this is an ar application which we
will be building all right this is an ar
encyclopedia
app
but these are not only the one which
we will be building during the course
we'll be developing two more
applications
like ar car customizer and another one
is ar business card
so who can
uh follow this
course this course is made for beginners
so you don't need any working knowledge
of augmented reality to follow this
course i'll be teaching you everything
from the very basics so if you don't
know about augmented reality don't worry
you will be learning to develop
augmented reality applications from
scratch
you can get more detailed information
about the course from the website
www.ar course.netlife.app
thank you
hello folks welcome to this lecture this
is the first lecture of our course uh
augmented reality for everyone in this
course we are going to get an idea of uh
what exactly is
extended reality what comes under the
hood of extended reality that is we are
going to learn about augmented reality
virtual reality mixed reality we are
going to learn about the mixed reality
continuum all right then uh we will end
this part of the lecture by uh
understanding the growth of you know the
growth of extended reality over the
years and what we are projecting by the
year 2025
all right so without any further ado
let's uh
understand all right see
uh extended reality now try to
understand extended reality in this way
it is the extension all right it is the
extension of our current reality all
right you can say that it is the a
virtual all right it is a virtual
extension of our current reality all
right you can understand extended
reality uh like this all right there
isn't any specific all right there isn't
any specific definition that would you
know uh
do justice to this uh whole domain all
right
but how i like to explain extended
reality is it is the extension of our
current reality or like that and it is
the virtual extension of it is the
virtual extension of our current
clearance
you can say extended reality is the hood
all right means it is the roof and that
roof has three children all right
those three children are named as
augmented reality virtual reality and
mixed reality all right so extended
reality is the main hood and it contains
three other domains augmented reality
virtual reality and mixed reality
all right extended reality is the parent
domain
all right now as we have understood what
exactly uh is extended reality right
what are the subdomains of extended
reality let's you know let's understand
what is augmented reality all right you
see you might have already you might
have
experienced augmented reality in your
life but you it might happen that you
didn't knew that it was augmented
reality like you know when you used to
play uh pokemon go when i i guess it
released in 2016 at that point of time
i i was very excited to play that game
all right just because i could uh you
know the spawn the pokemon all right i
could bring the pokemon into the real
world all right it had a ar feature that
could you know by pressing the ar camera
we could bring the pokemon into our real
world on it i was very excited about
that feature all uh the reason why i
didn't uh was i wasn't able to play the
game because you know uh i wasn't able
to roam around for free like it had gps
enabled right so i the only reason why i
played the game was because of its ar
feature and at that point of time i
didn't know what exactly augmented
reality was i didn't even know how this
thing works all right
at that point of time i just started
with programming all right so
uh we have we all have used augmented
reality at some point in our life and
didn't know exactly what it was
right so
one example you already got all right
the one with pokemon go now people used
to think uh that pokemon go is one of
the biggest big breakthrough in
augmented reality but it is not the
truth is this because see if i if you
look in after this course alright after
this course if you look into that now
the creating the mechanism all right
that is the pokeball throwing mechanism
to the uh pokemon it uh that mechanism
is very simple to make all right that
mechanism is very simple to develop it's
just we are throwing it through a
projectile so uh understand it like this
okay
basically augmented reality is nothing
augmented reality is nothing but you
know uh bringing all right that is uh
augmenting or you know putting the
digital objects all right in in our case
the digital objects like uh in pokemon
go pikachu is a digital object right so
we are taking the digital object all
right and placing it into our real world
that is what augmented reality is how we
are placing it we are placing it through
our device all right and uh don't worry
we are going to understand all right how
all this thing works all right how
augmented reality actually works right
how what is the architecture in our
future videos but for now understand it
like this way that we augmented reality
is basically the augmentation or you can
say the placement of digital object in
real world like for example take your
favorite cartoon all right for uh a long
time back uh my favorite cartoon cartoon
was doremon
all right i used to watch it like
all day i love that cartoon when i was
like in class
third or fourth so at that time uh if i
knew about augmented reality i would
have surely tried that he uh i would
have tried augmenting dorem on into into
my room alright i would have tried that
so just think of it this way you are
actually bringing your favorite digital
uh character all right
into your real world so that is what
augmented reality is that is basically
what augmented reality is all right it
is basically the placement of data
object into the real world like all
right and now as i have told you as i
have told you now you you might know all
right you you right now you are aware of
what exact uh how you know
pokemon go uses augmented reality right
now what i want you to do is after
finishing this lecture install that game
and try it out try it out by yourself
see how exactly the ar feature is
working all right it would be really fun
believe me
now
there are
uh mainly there are many majorly two
types of augmented reality marker based
augmented reality marker less augmented
reality all right in markerless there
are four other types of augmented
reality that is superimposition location
based projection and outlining all right
don't worry i'm going to uh make you
understand what exactly are these all
right so let's start with marker based
see
the meaning of this already the meaning
of marker based is in its name only
marker based ar means the augment that
or the augmented reality feature works
only if
there is a marker all right
only if it there is a marker to help
augment the object all right that is
what augment marker based augmented
reality is basically now this type of
ar basically works on the concept of
tracking and recognition all right it
first tracks the
marker means it first recognizes the
marker and then tracks it tracks it all
the way long all right so that is how
this marker based ar work all right
basically in this type of ar now you
would be you will be needing all right
you will be needing a marker to augment
you would be needing a marker
uh to help augment uh
the digital object in the into the world
all right like like in here all right
like in this you can see that this uh
lego batman all right or you can save
this minecraft blocked batman all right
it's being augmented this
uh this particular minecraft
shaped
batman is being uh
me
what can i say is being augmented on top
of uh a marker all right here you can
see it is being augmented on top of a
marker so this is what marker-based
augmented reality is to augment this
kind of uh to augment digital object we
would be needing a marker all right so
that is what marker-based augmented
reality is all right and in this course
we will be developing marker-based ar
all right so if you're not clear with
the concept right now that's totally
fine all right
uh you you would be when you will be
developing uh the marker-based app by
yourself you'll be very clear that how
exactly that those things work all right
but for now in simple words
uh
market-based ar is something all right
that would be needing all right in which
we will be will be needing it is
mandatory to have a marker all right it
is mandatory to have a marker to
augment the digital object on top of it
or or else you won't be able to you know
or else you won't be able to augment it
all right so that is what marker based
augmented reality is all right now uh
pokemon go is not an example of marker
based augmented reality all right i
would tell you uh
what example is it for all right
now
let's understand
what is
uh markle sayer all right now as you
have understood about marker based er
martin luther is the total opposite
alright the difference between them is
all right the difference between them is
marker based ar needs marker all right
that is it needs some you know point or
you can say some something to all right
it needs something to augment all right
it needs and that thing is a marker
so market based augmented reality needs
a marker to augment but markless ar
doesn't
now there are some algorithms all right
like simultaneous localization and
mapping is an algorithm that ah is used
all right that is used to map the whole
you know the whole environment around us
and then place
the objects in there all right
so markerless ar doesn't needs all right
markless ar doesn't need any sort of
marker what it does it will scan the uh
let's say if i'm trying to augment uh
some object in my room what will it do
it will scan the surface it will scan
the walls all right it would uh create
you can say it it creates a virtual you
know visualization of itself and then
you know
it will place all right it will place
the object right in there all right so
it will first scan the room alright it
will first scan the root
after scanning
it will place the object all right now
how it will scan there is an algorithm
it's a it's a very widely used algorithm
it is also used in robotics but it is
also used in virtual reality augmented
reality and mutuality so it is known as
slam that is simultaneous localization
and mapping
all right so that's how we um you know
build marketless ar features all right
so markless air is
is very simple it will this ar will you
know simply detect your room or means
the plane
the vertical and horizontal surfaces of
your room all right that is the planes
and perform the augmented augmentation
on those particular planes of those
objects all right
means it will augment the digital
objects on on top of those planes that
your ar have has detected right now for
example in this you can see this ikea
place app all right this is the demo of
ikea place basically this is a very
famous you know uh furniture app that
you know
makes use of marketless augmented
reality to help you decorate your room
all right like if i let's say if i want
to buy a sofa all right like you can see
it in here what i'm doing is i'm
installing the ikea place app i'm
searching for some sofa in there i like
that sofa very much but i don't know
will uh that sofa will you know fit my
home or not fit my in the sense it will
look good in my room or not something
like that all right
now what i can do is i can make use of a
marketless augmented reality scan my
room and then place the object in there
all right and then uh through my mobile
i can see that if uh the sofa is
adjusting at my place or not all right
and based on that i can buy the sofa
so that is how mark that is what markle
is saying all right
now there are multiple use cases of
markle is here all right
and uh decoration all right it means
this putting furnitures and all this is
one all right is one industry focused
all right uh it is uh of in interior
design is another industry all right in
where mixed reality all right and where
mixed reality and augmented reality are
are widely used all right like for
decorate decorating the homes and all
those things all right so hi i hope
market based and marketless
ar is clear so basically marker based ar
is nothing marker based uh ar needs a
marker to perform the augmentation of
for digital objects into on top of the
marker whereas markless air doesn't
doesn't need any marker all right what
it will do it will scan the surface and
then augment the digital objects on top
of the surface all right so that is what
that is the basic difference and that is
what they do
all right now let's get into the concept
of superimposition based ar
all right
see superimposition based augmented
reality all right is basically a
technique
that you know uses object recognition
now in this diagram all right in this
diagram you can see
the there is a person's hand all right
there is a person's hand and on top of
that hand
we what we are what this app is doing is
you know displaying
displaying a skeleton of the hand on top
of the person's hand alright so that is
what superimposition based ar is
it superimposes all right it's super
imposes
that means it put all right it puts
and digital object on top of a real
object all right and that works with the
help of object recognition
all right so that is what uh
superimposition based ar is it's very
simple all right it's it's very simple
now all right
see
what is happening in here
basically with this photo all right you
can see that we are able to you know
augment a skeleton skeleton of hand
on top of another person's hand alright
so what is happening uh the algorithm
all right that is the ar app is
recognizing the hand then putting all
right or you can say then uh
superimposing all right superimposing
the
skeleton on top of that hand all right
that is what it is doing that is what
superimposition based ar is all right
very simple all right
now
these type of ayana is very helpful all
right in medical industry all right like
you can say you can uh superimpose an
x-ray all right on a patient's body and
look into it real time in 3d so how cool
that would be and how efficient that
would be right that would make the
doctor's job more easier right so that
is
how we use superimposition based ar all
right and superimposition based ar are
used in you know in many different ways
so you can do your research on that all
right and even if you if you like you
can uh try developing something
with superimposition ar also all right
so
you can totally do that that would be
real fun all right so that is what
superimposition based ar is so i hope
you are clear with the very fundamental
concepts right now
after this
we are going to get into this location
based area all right
see loca uh location based area now
uh let me tell you
uh you you uh i'm sure you know about uh
gps right you know about uh
or what can i say google maps
right so you can say this is google maps
in augmented reality all right like in
google maps when you search for a place
what it does it it gives you the address
of that place or that means it marks the
uh road it will you know highlight the
road through which you can go go how
much time will it take all right it will
label the places or that will come
while you are going in there right it
will label those places
you but what you are doing in there you
are uh seeing all those in a 2d screen
all right
what location based ar does is it's also
you know does the things almost same
but in augmented reality it would give
you the live feed all right in 3d
it will give you the live feed in 3d
like you will if you are going somewhere
you uh if you turn around you would be
seeing a name plate all right hovering
over a building all right that would uh
give you an idea yeah this is the
building what i'm looking for all right
then you can go in there so
this type of ar experience makes it more
easier all right to you know use
us like locate places all right so that
is what location based ar is location
based ar basically you know ties digital
content and the experience it creates to
a specific place all right the objects
are mapped out so that when a user's
location matches the predetermined spot
it is displayed on the screen all right
so that's what i told you just just now
right this is the this definition i gave
you the very simple explanation of the
same definition
written in here all right so location
based ar is just like google maps but in
ar all right and more efficient more
better
all right in a more better way of course
now you guys might be thinking why we
are going to you know uh held our phone
in uh held our phone in hand and start
looking for places all right it's going
to be very hectic i totally understand
that all right and that's not how we are
going to you know use
location based ar
currently there are multiple ar glasses
that are being released all right like
geo glass is releasing their own ar
headset then qualcomm right qualcomm is
releasing their own ar headset all right
so many people many industries all right
are working on their own ar and mr
headset then a magic leap is there so
when those glasses will release now
after a few years alright or maybe in
this year only you will be seeing
location based ar all right
it would be gps but in ar so how cool
that experience would be
right so that is how these things will
work
so i hope this uh the concept of
location based ar is clear
all right now here comes projection
based area now let me make it simpler
for you all right projection based ar is
another name of holograms all right i
know you guys might uh have an idea
about what exactly a hologram is right
it basically project solid it is
projecting with you know a projector
role
uh into uh
means
into the means uh what let me let me
explain it in a simple way
what it is doing it is like
with a normal augmented reality all
right that is being used by a fort the
difference between projection based ar
and normal ar is
we are in normal here we are using our
phone to augment all right we are using
our phone to augment
but in projection based art we are using
some other device to project all right
to project
the digital object into the real world
all right that gives a more immersive
experience in that case you are not you
are not going to need and phone all
right you are just having some project
and it is projecting all right it is
projecting the 3d object in the real
world
people are working on this kind of uh
technology all right although right now
uh it hasn't been that successful all
right but people are working on that and
i'm sure this is something that we are
going to get in future all right and
people are really working like
working hard
on this kind of ar alright it would be
like really cool like you will be the
tony stark
all right of real world
so
yeah augmented reality virtual reality
mixed reality has the potential to bring
all the things that you see in the iron
man movie of course not the arc reactor
but all the digital things like the
jarvis all right
artificial intelligence is also having
those potential so if we combine these
technologies now we can have something
like java so
understand it this way all right
augmented reality virtual reality and
mixed reality is the future of our world
all right maybe within five to ten years
you won't be even using your phone you
will be have having slim glasses all
right you will be having slim glasses
through which you will be able to
augment the digital objects alright and
that is going to be true because we have
those glasses now all right yes they are
they are bulky like if i talk take an
example
there's a
microsoft hololens all right
if you if you have used that uh before
you you would get the same experience
like uh
tony stark right similarly then uh the
uh
other ar glasses is being released like
geoglass is releasing their own then uh
qualcomm is releasing their own so
within five to ten years all right you
won't be using your phone to communicate
or you know do things you will be using
your ar glasses to do all the things all
right there's snapchats lens all right
so a lot of things are there that you
can do
all right so now as you have as we have
understood uh the very basic concepts
you know the concepts of extended
reality or we have understood the basics
of augmented reality we have understood
marker based ar markerless air
superimposition location based and
projection based and the last one we
have and you know the topic of
augmented reality is outlining ar
all right now what exactly is it all
right
outlining ayana is uh
are mostly used in cars all right you
might not be seeing them more often all
right
although uh i guess even tesla is
working on implementing ar in their
uh cars all right so basically outlining
it will outline the direction all right
it will outline the it will map the
world and then outline the direction all
right with these uh trails here you can
see right here you can see
so they will outline those trails and
help you you know
go
through all the paths all right it would
recognize the boundaries all right it
would uh recognize the lines it would
help in many situations all that when
human aware human i can't all right so
augment augmented reality is the future
all right augmented reality which in
virtual reality is the future so this is
how outlining ar is used all right even
if tesla is working on implementing
augmented reality alright then why can't
we right we are developers we can do
that of course we can do that so
you can see people are working on
implementing ar in their cars right how
cool is that
right so that is what outlining ar is
all right now as we've understood the
fundamental concepts of augmented
reality
let's uh get into the virtual reality
all right virtual reality is the total
opposite of augmented reality in
augmented reality what what did we do in
augmented reality we were augmenting all
right or you could say putting the
digital objects in the real world but in
virtual reality we are taking all right
we are taking the person itself to the
virtual world all right or you can say
we are teleporting the person to the
virtual world
right so that is what uh virtual reality
is and
it gives a very good sense of
immersiveness all right for example all
right
see even i don't have a vr headset all
let the truth be told alright i don't
have a vr headset i don't
but i do have the understanding how it
feels all right because i
s at somewhere all right at somewhere i
have used at some point of my life i
have used a virtual reality headset yeah
of course not
at my home but when i you know used to
go to some game parlor all right they
had a virtual reality experience alright
i
i am i have used i know how that feels
all right and i'm glad that i can
explain it to you that
uh try to understand it like this all
right let's say you you are playing a
game alright
take any of your favorite game all right
one of my favorite game is you know gta
right although i don't play games much
nowadays but
if i if i had to say one of my favorite
games is gta 5 and gps and andreas all
right so what i'm going to do is i'm i'm
going to close my eyes and you know
think of or think of
think of a character in there all right
think of a character in there and try to
you know close my eyes and try to
experience all right all that thing by
myself all right and
the level of uh immersiveness you will
get there now after like while thinking
or while imagining you are
in uh in there in real time in the game
and playing all the things doing all the
things that the game's character can do
will give you uh you know a sense of
immersiveness
and using virtual reality that sense of
increases by 100 all right because at
that point of time you are actually in
there you are actually controlling the
person
available inside the game right you are
actually able to control the
you know you are actually able to
control the
character available inside the game so
virtual reality is nothing but you know
it is a technology that
teleports uh
you to
a virtual world all right
so that is what exactly it is now
there are you know multiple games and uh
educational applications available right
for example um anatomy all right it
teaches you about the human anatomy all
right so
that that is an educational app all
right then there there is beats about
one of the very famous game like uh in
the in the first image you can see this
is the gameplay of a beat saver already
the second image this is the gameplay of
half-life alex all right in the third
image this is the battle royale game
yeah there is also a battle royale game
in virtual reality so you can see the
level of immersiveness the
level of realism you will be getting
this is called uh what can i say
stand out vr battle royale all right so
the vr can be used in multiple sectors
it can be used in healthcare it can be
used in a military training already it
can be used in flight training it can be
used in manufacturing all right
you it can be used in education it can
be used in gaming so
the you know what can i say the
level all right or you can say the
limitation of vr is you know unreachable
right yeah there is some limitation
alright like the cost is there all right
but
cost you know cost is decreasing like uh
previously in india already i'm talking
about in india in india previously uh
oculus quest already the vr headset it
used to cost around 80 to 90 000 i guess
all right and now calculus quiz 2 costs
you around 30 to 40 000 all right so you
can see how
drastically has the the price has you
know the price has decreased by half
all right so the price of vr headsets
are decreasing all right and also the
quality and the technology is
improving and increasing all right so
just a few more more years and you'll be
getting uh
vr headsets maybe in 10 000 or 20 000 so
things are you know things are happening
real quick and uh mixed reality
is actually mixed reality is going to
help us a lot if i talk about in the
manufacturing industry all right if i
talk about uh the military training
industry all right and as we have
understood about the virtual reality
augmented reality it's our high time to
go to mixed reality all right now
let me tell you all right also one thing
i forgot to tell you that if you are
using virtual rear uh vr now you'd be
needing an headset that headset is
called head mounted display all right so
you make sure you know that this term
all right or you can say it's uh in
abbreviated form it is also called hmd
all right or head mounted display now
see
mixed reality all right
mixed reality you can mix reality now is
the you can say it is the brother all
right
this is the brother or the twin brother
you can say or you can say just just the
brother of augmented reality all right
why because see it is
let me let me simplify this term to you
mixed reality is just like
augmented reality but yeah there's a but
but
it is more advanced all right it has
more capabilities than normal augmented
reality why all right see
there's something called already mixed
reality continuum or you can say mixed
reality spectrum what does that mean
it means that the you know the merge all
right
the merge
of
augmented reality and virtual reality or
you can say the real world and virtual
world or digital world all right we
combine them you can you know
go virtual
and real at the same time all right with
with mixed reality so mixed reality has
a larger potential if we talk about the
uh
like
training industry all right like in
manufacturing industry mixed reality can
help you know to recognize those
items all right it can help you through
the manufacturing process in healthcare
all right it can help you you know
operate a patient alright it can guide
you through all the things you don't
even need to you know distract yourself
uh to any other computers or uh you know
digital objects available
in the
uh in the icu all right you can say or
in the patient squad all right where uh
basically the operation is happening all
right you don't even have to move from
the patient you can
stay in there uh monitor all the things
all right in your mr headset all right
monitor all the you know how let's say
heart rate or
blood pressure or any any data through
your mr headset only
all right so this is how it can help in
uh
you know medical industry then uh
military training recently i guess i
just read somewhere
a bite in 2018 all right in 2018 uh
military all right i guess the u.s
military uh
reached microsoft and offered around you
know 400 to 500 billion dollars
to build mixed reality headsets for them
all right for training military all
right for training the military so you
can you can you can you know you can
just think how
powerful these headsets are all right it
can help in training so mixed reality
can help you uh anyway like for example
in india there's a startup called ajna
lens all right what they are doing they
are uh
creating headsets for government which
are being you know used to uh train
military all right indian military so
uh it is being used to train navy seals
they are it is used being used to you
know train
numerous people out here in india so you
can see how mixed reality is exactly
helping right
so mixed reality uh i would say mixed
reality is future all right
extended reality is the future of our
world
all right it is the future of our world
so mixed reality is nothing but you know
it is the advanced form of augmented
reality all right it contains both it
means it can go both virtual
and
are real all right so that's what makes
reality is all right and you have
already understood the mixture
about the mixed reality spectrum that is
the combination all right that is the
combination of physical and digital
world
all right
so that is what mixed reality is all
right and also this image is taken from
microsoft's website so yeah
now
as we've understood all right about
all the things already about mixed
reality augmented reality virtual
reality
let's you know let's
get our heads into x the growth of xr
all right or you can see the growth of
market of extended reality all right see
the extended reality market size all
right
uh is going to reach all right around
you know
393 billion dollars by in 2025 at uh at
a growth rate of 69.4 percent cagr all
right it is a report by market research
future
all right now you can see that by in
uh the growth was
the growth was so less all right means
there wasn't any awareness of
augmented and virtual reality but you
can see by 2025 what will be the growth
all right you can read this chart by
yourself all right so
you can see how
how it is impacting now i want to tell
you that
this chart already this chart is
you know this chart is not stable all
right uh
right now in 20 in 2022 only
uh the market has reached
more than 200 billion dollars all right
so you can see you can see how how the
growth is actually but it can even
happen by 2020 uh three already by 2023
it can even reach 393 billion dollars
that is estimated by 2025 so
all right so make sure you know you go
through all these notes all right all
the notes will be available in the
website so make sure you go through that
so yeah that's it for this lecture thank
you
hey folks um
welcome to our module 2 and in this
module i'm going to tell you how to
install unity
and after that uh i'm going to
uh
show you or tell you how to use unity
all right what are its interfaces and
all those things all right so
sit tight on your uh
seat and watch the video all right if
you want you can uh
grab some popcorns also
so
yeah
first of all
what is unity before downloading we must
know what is unity if we don't know
about that then
how could we work out with that so we
need to know what is unity see unity is
a
engine all right it's sort of a tool
it's a as not sort of a tool it's a tool
it's a definitely a tool
it's a tool for developing games
for developing simulations for
developing ar vr applications
all right uh you can even make your own
simulations like you can develop your
own um robot inside of unity you can
develop your own
let's say
self-driving car you can implement your
own self-driving car inside of unity
yeah that's possible
that is 3d simulation so
uh and one of the most like most one of
the best things about uh unity is
it is multi it can it works on me unit
uh linux it works on mac os or works on
um
windows all right and also you can build
uh actually you can actually build
applications all right uh you can build
your games your apps for multiple
platform windows mac os linux then
android ios playstation then i guess it
also has a feature for xbox or also i'm
not sure about that i haven't researched
about it then
there's also
lumen luminous then uh
there's uh
webgl so yeah multiple things are
available all right so yeah that's what
unity infinity is a very good tool for
developing these things
now
what you need to do
you have to go to this page all right
i'll be providing the link down below
right and uh
click on this all right just just click
on this download unity hub all right
after you have downloaded install it all
like this these processors are very
simple i need not to show you i'm pretty
sure about that
now
what do we do after you've installed on
it open your unity hub it will
it might not look something like this
all right because this is a beta version
on it uh it's in currently in beta
testing all right it does have some bug
like recently if a
phased one that it wasn't grabbing my
license but i had to restart it and it
like worked really well so
yeah
so basically
uh it might seem a bit white alright the
interface might be white but
components are same so when you first
open your unity already
log in log in to your account alright
activate your license uh it will only
show you like it will by default uh show
you how to activate your license all
right you just need and if it doesn't uh
go to this click on this like
preferences option all right
uh go to this licenses all right i have
a professional license i got it through
student plan and click on add and
choose any license you want all right
now
let me show you one thing right
this is the basic interface of our whole
unity hub all right through this we have
to run our unity
this is the project section alright in
this project section multiple projects
of yours will be like
put it in here like will be listed down
here uh
as you will be installing unity for the
first time
it won't show any of the projects it
will be totally empty these are my
projects all right
then there are other tabs also i'm sure
you would explore this learn and
community tab but for now let's go to
this install tab so to install our own
unity version all right now
this is my unity versions alright these
are my unit version that i am having
that is 20 20 20 90 and 2018 all right
uh these are my unity versions
i've installed those i
work with these uh
mostly these two version more often all
right
now
this this panel would be empty alright
this panel would uh would uh be empty if
you haven't installed any
um
if you haven't installed any of your uh
unity versions till now so to install
one just click on install uh editor all
right
after that it will prompt upper menu
alright there are multiple uh versions
uh
in here all right there multiple
versions in here i'd recommend go for
2020 all right even unity recommends
this as of now and also always download
the lts version why lts is limited time
support and it's it's the most stable
version all right it's the most stable
version that we would have
so
would always download a
stable version and we'd also if doing
our development in unity 2020 only so i
would recommend download it right so
then click on install
now you can either install this all
right any actually any id or code editor
would work but maybe you won't get that
a code completion on that autocomplete
but i would suggest downloading it all
right
so download this to all right
if you want linux you might not get this
option then you have to use any other
code later only
but another thing i would want you to do
this is click on this android build
support under sdk and indicators and
open jdk all right and remove this check
mark from the documentation we don't we
can access it from web
all right and there are other like build
versions too you can also
like take a look at these and download
them
then click on continue all right click
on this i have agree and all those terms
and things click on this alright
and then click on install all right and
it would start installing
your editor
right and after it gets installed all
right just click on this download
and it will show if any of you
if any of your data is installing or not
and now if we want to create our own
project click on this new project option
alright sorry it's taking a bit of time
i it's it's uh it's a bit buggy
so yeah
i'm really sorry about this thing yeah
so as you can see here are multiple
templates available right multiple
templates available there is microgram
2d mobile karting micro game lego 3d
mobile auto showroom all right but for
now
we have to work with these two only not
even the 2d one we have to work with the
3d only all right
so
what we have to do see there are
multiple options like another is this 3d
uh sample scene hdrp and urp so
basically uh
what this does is this basically gives
you a more better graphics more
optimized graphics alright urp
better best works for
uh
best works for
us like computer systems
and uh
the urp best works for mobile phones all
right so yeah
and then uh you need to name your
project alright name your project in
here i want to name my project let's say
learn
to
develop
all right
i'm sorry for the spelling
mistake all right and then you can
simply create project and your project
will start creating all right
so yeah that's it this is the base
procedure and i have also shown you how
to install unity so
yeah
thank you
so hey folks welcome to this uh video
and in today's uh this is the second uh
part of module two alright in the first
part of the module i gave you an
introduction to unity and also uh told
you how to install unity and create uh
your first project with it all right
but now in today's video we'll be
covering rest of the topics or the rest
of the imported topics that are left all
right so without any further delay let's
get started so our first topic to cover
is navigating through interface all
right so we've been navigating through
our interface learning about what how
like what are the different components
of our interfaces all right so first we
have to start with our project window
all right so the part here you are
seeing all right like the folders here
are this panel is particularly known as
the project panel all right
this panel uh in this panel we can
create multiple all right we can kill
multi as many as folders we can we can
add our own 3d models and all those
right so
just
to create your own folder in here in the
patch project panel just
right click in the panel uh go to this
create option and click on a folder all
right so i want to create a folder named
materials all right where i would be
storing
my materials
right
so
this is my my material folder
right
now
in the project panel i can even add
numerous amount of assets right like if
i if i show you um just just wait i'll
be adding an audio file in it all right
so this is a burden beach file all right
i'm going to add this audio file in it
just wait for a few seconds and uh
the file will be imported it does take
some time all right because currently
i'm also recording so it took some
amount of time but it's usually fast so
here i have uh just what i did i just
dragged and dropped that particular
audio in here all right if you click in
here you can even play that audio but i
don't want to play it
right now so
yeah so we learned about our project
window now while we develop all right
while we develop our own games our own
application
we face multiple bugs we face multiple
errors right
don't we we do
so where do
where can we see those errors where can
we look for those errors
right
so
uh unity has provided us something known
as the console window all right it's
just right here all right us uh like
only after the
uh project if you don't have this
console panel or console window just uh
go in this top section name window click
on this click on panels and
just
select that panel that is not available
in this in your workspace right
so currently it's and empty right
currently it's empty i will show you how
an error will look like but
yeah in here you will get all the errors
and warnings and particular debug text
in here right so this is our
console window
now here comes our another window or
panel that is the hierarchy panel
so what is the hierarchy panel all right
see
there are multiple objects in this the
scene all right don't worry i will make
you make sure that you understand what
this scene is but
currently
uh currently
there are
like two objects that is a one light
object another is a main camera object
right so hierarchy panel what it does is
it lists down all right with the help of
hierarchy panel we can just right click
and create our another object right i
will show you how to create one but
hierarchy is basically uh the
structuring of
like
the objects it is a panel where you
would be able to see what objects are
available uh inside of the scene all
right and through the hierarchy panel
you can create your objects you can
modify them and all those things all
right
modifying is done by another panel
actually i would show you
right name after the hierarchy all right
so
this is what our hierarchy panel does
right so we understood what our
hierarchy panel does now here comes our
inspector panel all right so what is
this inspector panel man
what is so
this inspector panel is basically used
for
what can i say it is basically used for
modifying the components all right it
displays the
properties of the object all right like
if i click on the main camera right so
here you can see here multiple multiple
uh components here there multiple
options are there we can manipulate
those of these options and
uh
like we can manipulate this and
make the camera component look our own
way all right we can
uh edit these components right
so inspector panel gives you an
inspection of that object right it gives
uh it helps you to edit those options
inside the object all right now
as with
so tell us what uh which panels have we
looked
we have looked into the project
panel the console panel the inspector
panel and the hierarchy panel now it's
our time to look into the scene panel
all right see seen the scene panel is
nothing but uh a whole different like
um it's a it's a workspace all right
it's it's a workspace where we can
actually
uh put our models in right like our 3d
objects in there we can put our 3d
object into
like main camera main camera is inside
the scene main camera is inside this
uh whole scene right it's in this 3d
workspace so scene is the 3d workspace
right now after that there is another
panel that is this game panel
right
now what is this game panel
see
uh this scene is for navigating through
all right we can manipulate these
objects like like this all right we can
i will show you what are these but we
can manipulate these we can put our 3d
objects in there but game
game is the rendering part all right
like after our uh like let's say i have
made a 2d game for now all right but i
uh now i want to test it out i want to
play so what i would do is i would play
that uh particular game and or in this
screen all right in this particular
screen or in this particular panel
the game will start showing
right
so
yeah
now here comes oh another thing
uh here you can see three buttons all
right
uh these are three buttons
this one is the play button this one is
the pause button this one is the step
button right
so uh what this play button does is just
plays the scene all right that is starts
the rendering this is like the pause
button it will pause while you are like
like rendering it and the step now the
statements it will like after you have
paused you can click on this step button
it will
uh like move one by one
all right
i'll show you those all right i will
show you these
now here comes another panel this is the
asset store panel all right
now one thing to note is uh here you can
see it has told that they have moved uh
like the asset store
to uh the web all right and uh
i don't know why they did so but
actually i prefer that more uh because
in my system the
unity asset store uh used to lag all
right uh instead of unity so i think
that was a good idea but uh the main
difference already that you would notice
as a beginner
uh in unity 2019 and 2020 is that uh in
2019 the asset store is already
integrated
in your like
whole
uh unity and in 2020
uh the asset store is
uh on the web browser all right
so you can access it on uh from the web
browser all right so we don't need this
panel as of now so i will just right
click on it and close that
all right
one more thing i would like to show you
is there are multiple layouts available
in unity all right just like go to the
right of your screen and click on this
layout alright there are multiple
layouts
all right you can try one of these and
one of my very favorite all right just
just wait for it oh yeah one of my very
favorite uh layout is this one
why uh because this gives a like
more broader view all right this gives a
more uh broader view of this
scene all right it gives some it gives
more free space to work on so i like
this one
the most
uh but for now let's go to the default
all right we'll be working on the in the
default only as of now
so
yeah
so uh let me save this yeah
so we have understood that
the very basic interface now let's go
and
look at the tools all right
the tools that we have so first of all
we need but before that before looking
into the tools we have to understand our
game objects all right
so
see we have uh
got into another section that is game
objects and what are game objects
so see game objects are digital objects
all right game objects are those digital
objects that we can use digitally
all right
game objects can be anything alright i
mean anything it can be 3d game object
or to the game object
all right so what our game object
basically game objects are virtual
objects nothing else right so like uh
like an example this main camera it's a
game object all right
it's it's it's a gaming a game object
now this directional light all right
this is a game object
right
so
yeah similarly we can create our own
game objects like just just
uh go to this hierarchy right click in
here
uh click on this 3d object all right
click on this
cube
right
so we have created our own cube
right so now
here you can see there are multiple
anchors right there multiple anchors i
will tell you what are these
in the top here you can see here is a
tool bar
right here is a toolbar so what does
this toolbar does first first of all
first and foremost there is a tool named
hand tool this is uh used
to
like uh grab the screen and navigate
through it grab the scene and navigate
just just for that now after that after
that we have move tool
this move tool gives you some certain
anchors all right uh where you can hook
on
all right you can hook uh
with those anchors you can move your
game object throughout the screen
right
so
that's what it does
after that we have a rotate tool like if
you want to rotate your object i can i
can do that it gives rotational accesses
through which i can do that right
isn't it like really fun
now after that rotate tool there's
another tool that is a scale tool it
helps us to scale the object
scale the object all right like we can i
can scale it in any any uh axis
scaling it at any axis right
after that we have a rectangle tool or
wreck tool all right what is this it it
just like helps you to resize the object
in a rectangular manner nothing else
now then we have a universal tool
uh i guess this is called uh oh this
doesn't have a name actually but i will
call it universal tool all right
so
it is a combination of all the tools we
discussed previously all right
except the hand tool and if you would
see uh i'm able to use the hand tool uh
even when i'm like not uh selecting it
already like externally selecting it
it's automatically getting selected so
the basic shortcut for that is
sorry to click the uh middle mouse
button
right so
i'm really sorry about that so yeah
uh we have created our own cube we
learned about game object right
we learned about game objects
now
our uh just just wait i want to like
reset all the things
now i want uh to play with it right i
want to manipulate it
i want to manipulate this game object
how to do that
first of all i can use these uh these
several tools these fancy tools
available or i can uh go to my like
simple methods like
uh as i previously told that in the
inspector menu inspector menu gives us
the properties of the game object so
we with the inspector menu we can edit
those properties too right we can
so how do we do that first of all let's
say i want to edit the transforms all
right so what are the transforms man
what are transforms
like see i am moving this right i'm
moving this like this i'm i'm able to
rotate it also so what is that
the
things are like moving at a particular
direction we can also do the same thing
through this like inspector menu like
here you can see there are three
parameters like first of all see the
transform
here first of all see the transform
here comes the position
so that what does what does it does
it changes the position like i want to
be it at
10 of x axis right so it has got to tend
and
uh
yeah you can simply manipulate your
position from this but for now i want it
to be in zero
right
now
rotational values all right let's say i
i i want uh my cube to be rotated 45
degrees at uh x 90 degrees at uh y
and uh let's 45 degrees at z
so i rotated my cube right i i did
rotated it
now one one thing you'd be seeing like
let's say you messed up with all these
uh
parameters now you want to reset it how
would you do that just click on this
three little dots
click on reset
as simple as that nothing much all right
you can also scale it all right now this
is your homework you have to try this
scale portion by yourself all right you
have to try the scale portion by
yourself
now here are some other all other
parameters too all right
now this is a cube mesh filter all right
then there's a mesh renderer i want to
show you something if i
remove this mesh renderer
you won't see any sort of mesh all right
what are these green lines
this green lines are the box collider if
i remove it
you you would see the very light green
right very light green now these other
light greens are this this of cube mesh
filters
but this box collider lines are also
getting attached to it
now
here is the mixed random mission day is
basically the mesh of the queue nothing
else all right
so
till now we have learnt manipulating our
cube
we have learnt uh
uh
navigate our interfaces all that we have
learnt about game objects right
so
yeah we have learned this much by now
now
let's talk about materials what are
materials see
of course you want uh your uh
like game objects to be colorful right
you want your game objects to be like
texturified like they they should have
some sort of skin
right even humans does have skin why
won't a game object that's like
that's really bad
right so our
game objects also wants
uh
materials
like just uh humans we want our skin
similarly the game objects also want
their skin
so
the skin is known as materials in
this terminology in technical
terminology all right
so just just uh
as you can see i previously
created a folder right
go to that folder
right click
click on create
find the material i found it in here
click on it and let's
name it i want to name it red right i
want my material to be red
now what
now i want to change the color all right
see simply click on this material and
here you can see that you uh the
properties of those one that material is
available in the inspector now after
that click on this white box all right
this is this uh
at the right of albedo
click on this all right and select a
color let's say let's say i want it uh
to be
um
red
yeah so that's sort of a bit pink also
but well that would work for me so now
uh
man i have like
i have edited the color i have put uh
put something color in it but why isn't
it reflecting in the cube why is it
showing on the cube is the cube angry
that with the color is the cube angry no
it is not of course not so
we we have to apply this material in the
cube right we have to apply it so how
would you do that
two simple ways click on this cube
one way i'm showing you one way that is
click on this cube
drag and drop this material inside its
inspector
voila you got the material now our cube
is happy just like us humans
the cube has also got
its skin another way is just drag drag
this and put drop it in the scene view
without also using the inspector this
can also be done
right so our cube is now really happy
because we have provided him a skill
right
voila
so now we learned about materials now
one more thing if you want to add
textures it is really easy click on this
like albedo here you are seeing a blank
box and after that there's a zero sort
of click on this all right
now
let's say what what sort of material i
want i want all right let's see
um
oh no no
not not this not this of course not this
uh let's say this
yeah this this looks something like
a bit good right so yeah we give our
cube a texture also
see now our cube is more than happy
so
we successfully
made our cube happy and also learnt
about materials and texturing find those
all right
now
how to create a scene all right see what
are scenes
scenes are nothing but different
environments
right
they are different environment like this
is a sample scene i want to name it
let's say i want to name it where where
is the name yeah i want to name it
a main scene all right mean scene
this is the scene i want to name
right this is my main scene
so this is the scene all right and where
did the material go
that's weird
first i guess this is the bug of unity
but this is really weird
or i guess it happened because i didn't
saved it i'm not sure but yeah but we
managed to get it back
now scene is a
separate environment so that we can
create another scene
all right i would also like uh
while uh getting into euphoria i will be
i will also be showing how to navigate
through different scenes all right so
don't worry about anything how to
navigate and all those things so i just
want i just have to click right then
create
then here's always the scene man oh yeah
got this scene now and
create a new scene that is test scene
see i got another scene with uh
main camera and directional light by
default all right but currently i want
to be in the main scene right
so
we successfully created our cube and
also managed to make it happy by giving
it a skin
now let's learn a bit a bit about
project structure
right
what is the project structure
what is it
a project structure is a way of
structuring your project all right
nothing else see why uh see this is not
something like
many people teaches you all right this
this or this thing you gain but you gain
by experience but today i'll be teaching
you
all right see maintaining your project
on it maintaining a project is really
important like when i was a beginner
even uh i remember when i was a beginner
i
used to like
make my whole project very much
cluttered right
i used to make everything cluttered out
and that actually caused a real problem
for me like later on
all right because managing those were
really like hectic
so with
after like after working with unity i
learned that uh it is really important
to manage your project so how do i
manage i create separate folders all
right for separate
type of file or like for materials like
for skins i created this particular uh
folder named materials all right to add
some sort of assets all right some sort
of assets
i would name another folder name assets
where i'll be storing my assets like 3d
model like
3d images right like to store audio i'd
be creating another folder that is audio
folder all right so i create separate
types of
folders all right for separate types of
files
right so similarly
throughout this video would be saying
how am i creating folder for each type
of file right so
i recommend to stay
along with the video till the end right
so till now we have learned
uh about navigating through our
interface about game objects about
manipulating those all right
uh about uh materials all right like the
skins then we have learned about the
scenes what are scenes
right
uh then we have learned about our
project structure
isn't it cool like
within a half an hour we have done so
much
so
yeah so we learned about structuring our
project
all right
now
some more parts are left like creating
our own c sharp script all right then we
will be learning to modify our own
components then prefabs
uh then
physics and collision then we'll be
learning about audio and then at last
we'll wrap up this
module after
designing our interfaces
all right
so
yeah let's let's do it let's get the
energy back and let's do it so
to to keep the scripts all right to keep
the scripts uh what i want to do i want
to create another folder
name scripts folder or that it would be
containing all the scripts in here
just then right click click click shisha
all right i want to name it a test
script
all right
now as you can see in here there's a
like buffering going on this buffering
is basically the
is getting compiled
right so just wait for a few seconds and
it would
be done
actually my system like my system has
got really slow and because of that it's
taking a lot of time but
i guess we can manage with that right so
yeah voila our test script is created
now
i'll be using my own text editor all
right i'm dragging and dropping it into
the one
um just wait
just just uh just wait
uh so
yeah
now let me drag and drop it in here all
right now see don't look into these
windows all right um i have set up my
sublime text for competitive programming
so don't look into this but let's
understand what are these all right see
if uh don't worry i'll be explaining all
these things all right what is like
public class what is
like what is void then uh what is using
so i'd be under make you understand all
these things all right if you don't
understand something in here don't worry
i am there for you all right i'm your
instructor i'm always there for you if
you have any doubt join our community
all right join our community ask your
doubts in there you would i promise you
would get instant doubt support in there
all right
so yeah
as you can see in here all right
just wait let me uh make the font a bit
bigger yeah so
first of all
we are including all these system
packages like unity packages all right
these are packages we are including
now we have created a class of
transcript all that that is inheriting
another class all right that is
monobehaviour class
all right
there's the monobehaviour class
now inside that mono behavior class c
remember this monobehaviour class
consists of these functions
all right so it is important to inherit
this monobehaviour class
now if you don't understand what
inheritance is don't worry i am there
now this is uh
[Music]
with the void uh start function there's
the update function
what happens in start is
so the first time all right the first
time i'm playing my
unity
like playing uh the particular scene all
right
it will show at first like in the first
frame it will
do some function that i will define all
right and what the update does is
what it does it basically updates
uh every frame like it will do that
function it will do that particular
function in each and every frame all
right and it will be called once like if
if the frame is one
the update function will be called once
the frame is two
again one so
yeah so it
in every frame this update function is
called once
now let's let's try it out right try it
out
so
to uh print something i'll try to print
something that is
to print something in like
unity or like in the console we do
debug.log and let's name it
start function
right and also remember to put the
semicolon i all i
sometimes forget and this gives us
all right so it's compiling the script
alright just just wait for it all right
it will
it will compile the script and then we
are good to go i will also show you how
to execute a script
all right
um
just just do it ah yeah
we are good to go
right
so
yeah now let's play all right how to
play click on this play button
all right just wait this would take some
time all right
all right it is telling us to hold on
and we will hold on like
here it is really good it notifies us
everything
so yeah
as you can see we have got into our
games and started playing it let's go to
the console
oh my god
why isn't it printing have i have i done
something wrong like have i coded
something wrong let's check the script
again
no
nothing is wrong in here
i guess everything is okay yeah it looks
good to me but why didn't
it actually work
let me show you
so i got out of my play screen all right
go to the scene yeah
see the script is in here all right it
is in here in the project but we haven't
executed it right we haven't executed it
so how to execute pick an object all
right i want this cube object then just
drag and drop the script all right
drag and drop in it there's another
option alright that is click on add
component
all right
and type the script name all right like
test script so here you got the test
script right
so similarly there are two ways to add
on you can also drag and drop in here
also all right that's another option now
another got added here but i don't want
it so i will remove it
all right
so let's play it now let's let's try
playing it now
just wait hold on
our unity is telling us to hold on
it is entering the play mode
so
now let's see what has happened
in our console
cool
now you can see in the console there's
something written
it is written start function
that's what we
wrote in the debug.log right that's what
we wrote
so
what happens
the start function walk
works in
first frame
right
now this is the update function all
right now we want to check the update
function right
just wait
try it
so yeah
so i have saved it it will take some
time to compile it let it do its
compilation we won't bother him all
right unit is good
he does everything for us all right
so
let's uh let's hold on let's
just do it it will take some time
oh
cool
so it got
like
compiled and let's play it let's see
what happens
just wait
uh now let's are you ready to see the
console window are you guys ready
let's see it
oh my god
what's it doing it's continuously like
putting giving the function update
function like each frame it is doing
this
on each frame
see it continuously updates the function
in each frame
so
actually i think you got a very basic
idea of what this this function is doing
right
i guess you got that very basic idea so
for now
uh this is the like you learned how to
uh
basically learn unity sorry
i'm not the only teaching unity
basically you learned how to
create your own script all right and
understood the functions in there all
right now
there's another section known as
modifying components we already learned
how to modify components all right so
yeah
now here comes prefabs what are prefabs
prefabs you can say these are the
collections all right these are
collection let me create another folder
i would also show you how to create a
prefab
so
what is the prefab man
a prefab basically helps us to create a
collection
right like it is sort of a storage
particular thing right see uh
let's say right now let's let's take a
scenario all right let's take a scenario
you are developing a game all right so
that's a a first person shooter game
all right you have implemented it uh on
one scene all right now you have created
your own first level now you want to go
to a second level and you want that same
particular fps player alright same
particular fps player in this in another
scene that you are going to create that
is in another level what you would do
you have uh
one way
all right one way is to
like
create like assemble all the components
that you made previously again all right
and that would consume your time all
right and of course that isn't a good
thing
another way is to create a prefab
so prefab creates an another like
a package of that particular object
right it's it's a package of that
particular object
it helps to create uh like a package
like okay if i our cube has certain
properties all right i need the same
cube one that's
next scene
right i need the same cue on the next
scene
then one way is to recreate it another
way is to create a prefab and just use
that
now how to create a prefab
click on this wallet click on this cube
drag it and bring it in this project
section
put it in there and voila your prefab is
created now here you can see the cube
has turned like this this thing is
turned blue this is the indication that
it is a prefab now let's create another
scene and let's see does it does uh oh i
i have already one
does this work on this on this another
scene i want to save it right i
definitely want to save it
uh
so yeah
let's go to this uh
where is it prefab all right now let's
drag and drop it in here
wow i got it in here just to reset the
transform yeah
i got it in here let's let's try playing
it let's say the functionality works or
not
just wait
for a few seconds
to run
um
it is doing its job
uh so yeah now let's look at in the
console wow
the same thing that was
working on the previous scene is the
same thing is working in here so yeah
one more thing i forgot to tell you i
just okay it just came up in my mind
just
let me like
go back to my main scene
uh wait let me lower down the desktop
volume yeah
so
now so now what all right so what now
it's uh
what we have to do uh
see
now i would be telling you something
really important all right i forgot to
tell you
that previously
and
object all right an object can have its
child object all right like you can
branch the objects like if i if i want
to want the cube to be a child of main
camera i would just click on the cube
drag and drop it in here and see
my cube is now the child of the main
camera
right and main camera is the parent
similarly i can also create empty
empty objects that is click on create
and create empty all right i won't
change its name i will just reset its
transform and put this cube underneath
of that
game object all right now i can make
multiple childs of this cube all right i
just control d all right to duplicate
control d
ah
so yeah again ctrl d
again ctrl d
so similarly like this i i i am able to
like
oh wait uh yeah i'm able to create
multiple child objects inside another
empty game object
right so you can do those things
similarly
nothing much different
right
so
till now we have learnt a lot of things
all right we have learned
also modifying our own components we
have learnt about prefabs now three more
important sections are left
that is physics and collision
all right physics and collision
another
one is audio how to work with audio
files all right audio is really simple
all right
then we have
the last but not the least
designing our interfaces
all right and at last of that i would
also be showing you another thing
all right ah so
yeah
let's move on with physics and collision
what is a collision man what is it
see collision is nothing all right
collision is nothing but
the
hit or like the hit of an object
for on another object all right it is
flexi these two objects are colliding
with each other all right these two
objects are colliding collision is
basically the
like
interfering of two object
with one another
right
so
that's what collision is all right now
if i if i had to say you all right
game like this this whole unity engine
is a replica of our real world physics
are we showing you how all right just
just wait all right first of all i will
be deleting all those other game objects
just wait uh first i need to uh set up
my environment to show you how
right
uh
oh no no why let me let the y be 0.4
right and the vb for
one b four right
so
this is how it is
all right now
let's take another
3d object that is a spear
we would call it a ball right
it is a ball
for uh for us it is a ball
right
just wait
so
so yeah
this is a ball right now i want to
implement a real world physics
so as of now all right let me let me
first de-attach the script right now or
else it would be
working continuously i don't want the
script to be interfere to interfere
alright
just wait
oh
and let me apply to a brief habit
so our 3d uh our script has been removed
all right like here one thing you can
see of it here's the shadow that's
because of the lightning all right you
can play with the light lighting later
all right so let's play it now so
in real world what happens
in real world if we have a plane and if
we throw a ball from the from the top
it will fall down right it will fall
down and bounce
let's check that it happens in here or
not
just wait keep patience
all right keep patience
oh my god why isn't it falling it should
fall right it should
because i i recently told that unit
engine is a replica of our real world
physics
but
you have to implement those physics
right you have to implement those how
how would we implement those
unity is really really caring about us
and what unity developers did they
already created those physics objects
for us those physics components that
will help us replicate the real world
situations
all right now how do we do that
so see we are first of all we are in the
game scene all right we are in the game
scene i'd be editing this whole thing
while being in the game scene all right
so just put it aside in here all right
because we need the view only nothing
else
one more thing i would like to say that
after
i get out of the this game view object
will get resetted because though won't
be saved uh during the game view
remember that all right
so now
i want this ball to fall due to gravity
all right
i want this ball to fall
how do i do that so far there click on
this add component all right there's
something known as a rigid body
all right
click on this rigid body and see the
effect
cool isn't it like after i added this
rigid body it's the ball started falling
now it isn't bouncing right see to make
it bounce there's another sort of
physics all right we need to create a
physics material all those things
but we won't be doing that in here but
as of now you understood that
uh we were able to add
the gravity like we would be able to add
make the ball uh physical like we are we
are able to add physics to the ball
right
now
in the rigid body component
you can uh play with the values in here
all right like
the mass value the drag the angular drag
you can like
click on this huge gravity let me let me
show you one thing
if i click on this
uh see it isn't falling because it is
not using gravity
so
see cool isn't it
great now here's another
option collision detection all right
uh before explaining this collision
detection thing right i would be telling
you
how this collision is happening
how is it
is there any sort of magic
before that i need to replicate this
object already because i don't want the
ball to fall
all right i literally don't want it to
fall
so
here you can see here some options box
collider all right
this box colliders are basically
provides the collision platforms
all right it provides a platform
like uh like in the ground we are moving
all right we aren't falling like we are
fall we aren't falling through that
uh whole road right went
like penetrating that road and
going to the bottom of that road are
like does that does that thing happened
doesn't right
similarly
in terms of games we could say there are
some platforms right those platform has
some colliders
all right those are book box collider so
here if i click on this box color you
can see all right you you just saw that
the ball got it through that because
there aren't any collision
like there aren't any collision
happening to stop that ball right in
there because we have disabled the uh
box collider right so box collider
actually helps us
to uh like this colliders there are
multiple types of colliders actually box
color is one of which type like this
pier collider all right
so
box collider is basically helps us
to pro uh to provide collision to that
particular platform
right
just just wait
uh
so yeah
so uh this is how everything is
happening right cool isn't it
so
we have understood about colliders one
more thing there like there are many
multiple you can have multiple uneven
shapes right like like a terrain
all right like a road there like a road
is uneven all right a desert it is
uneven it doesn't have a flat surface it
is totally uneven there are
highs and lows right
so for that type of like if you want uh
want to provide collider to that
platform
we can't use box collider in there right
because then it will be totally plain
we want we don't we won't be able to use
it
so there's another collider named mesh
collider all right
it is in the component only alright i
want you to try that collider out all
right by yourself just close to have
component click on mesh collider and you
can use it now the problem with mesh
collider is
uh it is a
a bit more cpu intensive all right then
this box collider or
spear collider or any other collider the
reason being there is it uh does
more calculations
than box and spear collider because uh
the mesh collider what it does it it
gets the accurate shape based on that
particular terrain or the particular
model right isn't it so
so what uh
they gave that particular
shape so it does more calculation
now in the rigid body i was going to
show you something known as collision
detection what is that the multiple
option all right we'll be looking into
two main of these discrete and
continuous
now there's a huge difference between
those all right
see
what is the difference discrete is
performant all right discrete uh gives a
lot of performance it is like in
performance wise
it is better than continuous
all right but the prob the problem
there is
it
does like it doesn't do accurate
calculations
it doesn't like
it can if you if you throw it from a
really high like at a really high
position it will penetrate
through this whole um collider all right
through this whole platform
but
continuous continuous is
is better than discrete already because
uh with the use of continuous there are
very less chances that it will penetrate
through because it does more calculation
than discrete but the problem is
continuous is cpu intensive so that's
the difference major differences all
right
so we also learned about the very basic
physics
right we learned about the very basic
physics of
unity
now
it's our time
it's our time to learn
uh
this audio
right
so
for that
first of all to play that audio all
right first of all to play that audio oh
my god i did i deleted everything uh so
yeah
all right i would be getting those
objects back because
i did that with
our
whole environment now i want to create
an audio object how do i do that
go to this uh
click on this
go to this thing all right
click on audio source
all right so we created a simple audio
source right we created it
now there are some particular options in
there all right
click on this
select the audio
and uh
let's let's play it
all right
just wait this is a uh this audio is the
birds and beach audio all right like
bird chirping are in the big uh beach
all that or do you think
are you able to listen it i am sure that
you are able to listen
so the audio is playing right
so uh
the audio is playing in here right the
audio is playing
that's cool isn't it so we implemented
our own audio source
all right now uh soon in our pre uh in
our future lectures all right we'll also
be learning how to control our audio
sources through scripts alright but for
now if we look into these like uh
properties there's a
uh option for mute now i won't be
actually explaining all the things in
here you have to explore it by yourself
like
uh you can explore this bypass effects
bypass listener effects bypass reverb
zones all right now these this loop is
basically uh will loop the audio all
right because without loop
initiated all right without click
checked on loop
uh what will happen your audio will only
play once but with loop it will play all
the time all right now here's another
option that is play on awake all right
uh play play on awake what it does is it
like when you
just play your game all right it will
start the audio at that time only if i
if i uh
like remove it and then start playing it
just wait
so uh it has started playing but you uh
won't be seeing anything like you won't
be hearing anything because
player awake is disabled now to play
that audio i need to add some trigger or
some sort of script to play that audio
all right so play when on away
what it does
it basically
uh
plays the audio whenever you start now
here's another thing that is volume all
right
now this is the volume it uh varies from
zero to one all right now there are
multiple other
uh audio editing uh feature you can
check them out by yourself all right you
can
do some research on them
all right
so till now we have als we have
completed most of our topics all right
we have completed most of our topics
now
the last
but not the least
creating our own user interfaces
how do we do that
all right see i'd be creating a very
simple user interface all right nothing
too complicated already nothing to like
nothing of
very complicated user interface a very
simple one just to show you all that how
to create one all right but we'll be
creating uh beautiful interfaces during
uh like
during the making of our
uh course
like the uh projects
all right
so just let me delete this particular
thing because i don't need it now
all right
so let's save it
now how to design our own interfaces
all right
let me dock this game view in here
and uh
for that first of all i
want to go to my wide view right
because it helps me a lot
all right
so first of all click on this 2d option
here you can see alright this will give
you a 2d view alright this would give
you a 2d view so i got the 2d view
all right i would like to click on here
this this y thing the reason because
this will give you a grid and it's
really helpful
now
uh
first of all
we have to uh right click
and click on the ui option then create a
canvas all right
what is this canvas
right
what is this canvas basically this
canvas is basically
the like uh
the basic framework all right the basic
wireframe of the or you could say the
frame for handling the user interfaces
right
so
click on this canvas alright here are
some options what i would like you to do
is
uh first of all uh click on random mode
all right keep its screen space overlay
as of now there are multiple options and
definitely will be looking forward to uh
these in our future lectures
all right and this world space is going
to be really useful during the like
during our
making of those projects
right
now here are some options all right
now go to this canvas scaler
thing all right now ui scale mode
constant pixel size
do to scale with screen size all right
and give it a default resolution for me
as of now uh this
800 by 600 is okay
and leave all those parameters
same all right
for now this is what i need
now
our canvas is ready right our canvas is
ready now i want to like get the display
of my laptop in here like the resolution
of my laptop in here
okay uh
very well
sorry my mouse is like sometimes
creating the problem of navigation like
the mouse button
middle mouse button so as we've created
our canvas all right now we need to uh
create a background image for it so how
do we do that so click on canvas click
on ui
then there's something known as panel
all right click on this panel
right
see you got a sort of background all
right now i need to color the background
right uh first of all i name it uh
background image right although i
haven't imported any image so i will
take
coloring it all right
first of all how to do that
uh click on this panel
all right uh click on this image section
right here from here you can select the
image you want all right
so already one is selected i don't want
to change it click on this color option
and here we see that this this thing is
transparent how to make it opaque
see here's an option known as a also
known as alpha
so just just click it in here and
like make it 255 like make it to full
i want a yellowish orange color
so this is the color i wanted and i got
right
so
now this is my background i'll be
scaring the background a bit
how do i do so uh choose the scale tool
click on the middle uh option and just
scale it
right
now as we are have created our own
background now what we want we want is
to create a heading text for it how do
we do that
how do we so click on ui
then i there are two option text and
text mesh pro all right i haven't
imported text mesh pro although
text mesh pro is the better option to go
for
all right because it pro
the quality of the text and text mesh
pro is really good alright so i'll be
clicking on it
all right uh just wait uh so yeah
uh i'll be uh importing the uh text
message essentials all right it would
take some amount of time all right don't
worry
all right
let it uh
take the time it want
all right all right because that is
importing all those assets so it's
important for it
to be important clearly
just wait
[Music]
yeah it is getting imported uh just it
would take some amount of time
actually i guess i should have like
imported it previously only
but uh if i did so you wouldn't have
like caught how to do that so here we
got our text in here right we got our
text in here all right now we want or to
edit the text and let's let's let's name
something all right
let's name it
uh
our new ui all right i know this is like
a very bad name
now i want the textile to be like
something like h1 right but it's giving
a color no no
let's leave it let's let's keep it
normal only
and click on bold right we can even
resize it how
uh like zoom it in here and you will
find these anchors all right do this do
this right
another thing we want is to
center our text so we did that
all right
so
you can uh we also have some other fonts
all right
uh
okay we don't have one
oh i sorry i forgot to import that
a extra package came with uh
text method but no worries
uh we don't need that as of now now here
you can see here is that a wreck
transform option
click on alt alright click on alt click
on uh so as you can see if you just open
it all right and click or not there are
multiple options here
i want you to click on this top one
see
our
text automatically got and then i want
to
reposition it and voila
we got our text or just wait
yeah we got our text to where we want
and this is our
ui all right our new ui or let's say
uh let's name it to
learning
unity
right
so this is our new ui
isn't it now we want to add uh some
buttons right we want to add some
buttons how would we do that
click on canvas
click on ui
here is an option known as button and
button text mesh pro i would i want you
to go for button text mesh pro it's
better
believe me it's a lot better all right
now
we can even add some functionalities
alright first of all i want to like
put a transform to it i wanted to want
it to be in center only let's name it as
a play button
all right
let's name it a play button
and let's name it play
see in future or we today we are
learning just how to
implement our own ui all right in future
in future lectures we will be learning
uh like
how to navigate through uh uh
uh our scenes how to like add
functionalities to our button right so
for now this is what i want
so we created our play button all right
even
i can change the color all right there
are some
many things all right like if i if i
click on this placed color i want to
make it green when it gets pressed
right now if i play this if i play this
just wait
it would take some amount of time
because unity takes time
all right so
uh just just wait
it's entering the play mode
cool now if i click on this see
when i'm clicking or clicking on it it
is
getting green now if i if i select the
highlight color and
like make it a blue
let's see what happens
oh well nothing happened
uh let's let's check out the
selected color
let's make it sort of like yellow wow
now oh highlight collect worked finally
i i don't know what why it didn't work
so
when i'm hovering on it it is
highlighting the color as
blue when i'm pressing it that is
the pressed color it is green
after it is selected
it got
pink
right so
isn't it really cool all right similarly
we can add some functionalities alright
like there's an option on click all
right if i want i can like add some
particular function like for now uh
let's say i want to disable the text all
right so whatever do i would uh drag and
drop this text first of all let me show
you from a again
there is an on click parameter click on
this add
then
take the text in here all right now in
here there is written no function click
in here
go to game object
uh click on set active all right and
just don't check that button out all
right we have we can create another
button something like this
name it uh active first of all i would
name it active
sorry deactive deactivate
d
activate
and
this one is
wait
all right i just want to
like
wait
this is going to like
activate
like
activate the whole thing
all right
just to wait
let me drag and drop drag it down in
here all right
uh
cool isn't it now let's let's try this
out what happens let's see
just wait it would take some amount of
time but it will uh it will get done
all right so just wait
cool
now if i want to like deactivate on it i
don't want this learning unity i want to
hide it click on the activate see it got
deactivated but i but i want it back
see it came back
see
i'm making my button do some activities
so
we also learned
how to uh
design our own interfaces if you want to
add some sort of image you can just
click in here ui then
raw image all right i
i don't know i have any image for this
all this
oh i do uh let's say i want uh i want
this emoji one right i want this
one
to be in there and i can also resize it
um sorry
it got resized wrongly
i'm in a wrong manner so yeah see
isn't this ui looking good
actually it isn't looking good but yeah
for now it's it's okay it's fine
right
so
we
also learned how we learned today we
learned
a lot of things in unity
right so
see you in the next lecture
thank you
so hey folks uh welcome to our first
lecture of module three in this module
i'm going to introduce you to uh c sharp
so
without any further ado let's get
started so what is c sharp right see c
sharp uh first of all one of the most
important thing i'm going to tell you
right now is
pronounce c sharp as c sharp only not c
hash like
i have seen many people they like uh
they don't know that how it is
pronounced or they even sarcastically
tell that it is c hash
guys it's not c it's c sharp right uh so
yeah
so see c sharp is an object-oriented
general purpose programming language all
right it was developed by microsoft uh
in the early 2000s right uh the
development team was led by uh anders
hillsborough and it is a part of the dot
net framework
it can be used to develop different
types of uh software's like uh console
applications windows applications uh
then
web applications mobile applications and
games and uh so yeah and it is also you
being used in arvr development so yeah
so c sharp is a multi multi uh like the
general purpose program language it can
do anything
right
so
yeah this is a very basic introduction
to c this is what c sharp is
now let's get into the coding part all
right
so
this is a very basic code structure all
right so using system name space hello
world
then class program
then
static void main then
console.writeline then
console.read right
so don't worry uh
the
if you are not able to understand what
are these don't worry i am there
right now i'll be coding this all right
and after that i'll be making you
understand what is this all right so
here is my c sharp compiler
right this is my c compiler so
i'm going to write using
system
name space
hello world
right
class
uh let's say
program
public
static
void mean
string
args
then console
dot
right line
hello
viewers
sorry
then console
dot read
let's run this program
let's see what happens
wait it's compiling the program
cool now if i click enter
the program will be finished
so what did just happened man it printed
something right it printed something in
the console can you see it in here it's
it's printing something right it's
printing definitely it's printing
so
let's understand
how is this working what are these
gibberish
right
let's understand so by the way
congratulations you uh coded your first
uh
program
so let's get back to the notes
so yeah first of all let's let's know
what a directive is right what is a
directive
see a directive basically tells our
program all right
so not the program uh directive
basically tells of a compiler what is
the compiler compiler compiles the
program all right we haven't set up any
sort of local compiler because we are
using our own online
ide for coding all right so
directives basically directs our
compiler all right it tells our compiler
that our program is using this name
spaces our program is using this certain
name spaces all right so what is the
directive
right see this using system
this this using system is a directive
this
using system is a directive all right
similarly there are others also like
system.collections and all those things
all right
uh like you uh watched in the
that uh unity video right in in that
unity tutorial that there was uh using
unity engine right so yeah there are
multiple name spaces sorry multiple
directives
so yeah
this
directives basically this using system
directive
tells us all right this using system
directive tells us that our program is
using
this system name space all right it is
telling that to our compiler it is
telling to our compiler that
hey compiler i am your c program this
person created me
so i'm using this uh system name space
are you okay with that and that compiler
replied yes i'm totally okay with that
because this uh using system is already
pre-defined in my
compiler code base right so i am totally
okay with that we can run the program so
yeah compiler happy our code happy that
you are the code are happy right so yeah
now
as i told you about namespaces right
see name spaces now they are basically a
collection
all right they are collection
collection of whom
namespaces are collection of whom i just
told that namespaces are a collection
but collection of whom see name spaces
are basically a collection of other code
properties you can say or other code
structures right or other code elements
all right
so
these code elements can include classes
like see recurrently we only created our
own namespace this is our hello world
namespace it is containing a class right
it is containing a class it is
containing a program class
so we
certainly created our own name space
right we certainly created our own
namespace
so
yeah
now
we understood what are namespaces all
right what a namespace says
is
see and uh if i have to repeat
namespaces are a collection of code
elements all right it is basically a
collection of code elements it contains
other classes other interfaces other
enums other structure a structs all
right so
name spaces are a collection of those
things
all right see c sharp our c sharp is a
programming language right
c sharp has a large amount of code all
right c sharp has a large amount of
pre-written code that like the team who
developed c they already wrote
codes for us all right useful codes for
us that we are using
all right that we are using but can you
can you tell that if
the programmers if the programmers took
all those programs and just put uh put
it in only one file
or wouldn't it be cluttered up like
there are multiple hundreds like
hundreds thousands code files wouldn't
it be clutter up and now if i had to
find one file then wouldn't it be
cluttered up so what they did
they
divided those pre-written code into
different namespaces all right see using
system is not on is
not the only namespace available all
right there are many other
all right so
yeah
so our code the like the c sharp the
developers who wrote c sharp they they
actually
divided all those code all right so
divided all those code into different uh
name spaces
all right uh the system namespace all
right the system namespace that is
available it actually uh contains the
code all right codes for methods
that allows us to do certain functions
all right like if we want to print we
can do that
so
uh i already told that we can actually
declare our own namespace we even did we
even did uh declared our own namespace
all right we can copy this and create
our another namespace all right i would
show you how to do that
and you know
uh what are the advantages of
using namespaces right see
first of all one more thing if you are
creating two or three your n numbers of
name spaces it is really important for
you to name it differently all right the
namings should not be same so then if
the
first name is hello world or you may i
mean your first name space name is hello
world the second name space name should
be hello priyanshu or any other name
right or your name so
remember that
and
one of the major things of like helpful
things of uh name spaces are
name spaces are two different
environment you could say all right
in namespace one
see
namespaces basically help us to prevent
the conflicts name conflicts like see if
we if we if i show you here all right if
i if i create if i
let's say if i created a same type of
variable i know that you won't
understand this as of now all right
you won't understand this all right
i'm pretty sure about that but don't
worry all right don't worry i'm going to
cover about variables comments and all
those things now let's play it let's
just play see see it is giving us error
you know why it is giving us error
it is giving us error the reason is
that we are using
at the same name
the same name all right so in uh in c we
can't use the same name
all right we can't use
so it's really important to give
different names but but but
if i had to show you all right
we can declare we can give the same
names in second namespace all that like
this is one of our namespace right so
namespace
hello priyanshu all right this is
uh another
this is another instance i'm creating so
class
program can you see i am giving the same
name in here right the same name in here
now now let's let's try running it man
let's try running it
see it didn't returned us any sort of
error it didn't
why because
namespaces you can think of namespaces
are different environments actually
they have the uh
in there if namespace one has program
and namespace2 has program
the same names then it won't conflict it
won't create any problem
so yeah
i hope you understand right i hope you
understood this thing
now
uh
we looked into the example right we
looked into the example
oh yeah one more thing i forgot to tell
you that is that this this main method
all right see this main method the main
method you could see
this is the starting point all right
this is the starting point of our
program
the main method is basically the
starting point of a program it's where
our program starts all right if i if i
give the same thing all right let me
copy this and put it in here if i give
the same thing in here
where it didn't got printed
or why is it happening
wait
copy
paste
all right it isn't pasting i don't know
oh oh oh i got to know i didn't ended
the program right sorry i'm really sorry
about that
i was like oh god
now let's let's try running this and i'm
sure you would get error see it is
giving as error see it is writing
program a dot out has more than one
entry point defined
do you know what it means
it means that there are two entry points
and main method is the entry point so
in a program in a particular file there
should be only one
method alright there should be only one
main method
because it is the starting point of our
program right because if we have if we
give two
main methods in diff two separate uh
name spaces then our compiler will be
like hey man
which which main method should i go for
i'm confused
and because of that
and because of that you you are very
rude to me you gave me
two main method i am really angry about
that so i will what i will give you i
will give you error and you won't be
able to run your program
so our compiler will tell this
so to make our compiler happy to make
our compiler
work fine means to make our program work
fine we need to uh provide only one main
method in our
but in our any in any of our namespace
all right
now no no no
yeah oh okay okay i also forgot to tell
you about these this too right
my bad my bad so what
see you have already seen that what this
console.writeline does this
console.writeline basically prints all
right this console.writeline prints a
statement but what what this
console.read read does all right i have
written it in here see the console.read
all right it basically waits for a key
press from the user before code seeing
the console execution like if i execute
it all right if i if i let's say execute
i will show you all right i will show
you now if i let's say i try doing
something like editing this program can
you see you can't edit the source for
when programming is running
you can you can't edit the source code
when program is running means our
program is running it hasn't ended
if i press enter see our program ended
now if i if i had to comment this
download i know you don't know about
comments don't worry or let's say i
remove this i'll remove this particular
code line all right
if i remove this
see i didn't even need to press enter it
just uh exited so that's what our
console.read does all right so let's
let's get uh get an idea about our main
method all right so what is it so see
the main method in here the main method
is basically the starting point or at
the starting point of any of any of our
uh c sharp program all right
yeah so our the main method the main
method in here the main method here
is our entry point or the starting point
of our c program
right
uh whenever whenever we run a program
all right why did why did when we saw
the example where we uh like added
another added another public static void
mean in in our second namespace why
didn't it ran
it didn't ran because there should be
only one entry point of the program i
already told you what would the compiler
will feel if you give
two entry points right the compiler will
be angry
it will be an insult for him
i guess so
so yeah
there should only be one entry point all
right
one
main method
and also one thing that
these entry points are called first all
right than any other methods like if you
define any other methods they won't be
called first
the first thing that will be called is
this main method
all right i hope you understand
so yeah there's another parameter this
string args all right if you don't know
what a string is
man don't worry i am there now i am
there for you i am there for you to make
you understand it is i i will make you
understand this uh why what is this
string args all right what is this
string guy this is an array all right
this is a collection it can take a
collection of strings all right it can
takes a collection of string if if
you're not able to understand what is
this don't worry next lecture is there
all right next lecture is there for you
after that lecture you will understand
what it is what it does all right and i
will recapitulate or recapture this
particular portion in that
don't worry
so basically it can take this the string
method can take sorry the string
argument can take
multiple multiple amounts of
string data right and i already told you
what this console.writeline is
and what this console.read is all right
so
for the for today list for this lecture
our our uh first first lecture is
completed all right so our module three
first lecture is done all right
see ya bye bye see you in the next
lecture thank you
so hey folks uh this is model 3.2 and in
this module we are going to learn about
comments variables data types and type
casting
all right and in our previous module
that is 3.1 we learned about uh c sharp
we learned the basic structure of c
sharp or all the very basics of means
what is that using a system what is uh
like we learned a lot of things all
right what is console.writeline right so
in this module we are going to learn
about uh
comments
then we are going to move on to
variables then
data types and last but not the least
and one of the important concept that is
typecasting all right so without any
further ado let's get started
so what are comments alright see
comments are basically uh some sort of
statement or you could say some sort of
keywords or something like that all
right it has some sort of specific lines
that is ignored all right that is
ignored by the compiler all right you
already know what a compiler is a
compiler is uh is a tool that converts
the code to a binary form right that
that is or you can say machine
understandable code
right
why it does that it does that because uh
machines cannot understand english all
right it can't understand our words
machines can only understand binaries
that is zero and one all right so
yeah uh so
what comments does is comment uh the
comments basically all right these
comments are basically ignored by the
compiler they they won't run that
particular line all right they they will
just ignore that that
yeah it is a comment all right why
should we run that it's a you
it's a useless thing all right for a
compiler for a compiler it is a useless
thing they won't run it because uh
nothing will come out of that right so a
comment
is basically uh a comment is basically
uh some some sort of lines all right
some sort of specific lines that are
ignored by the compiler all right and uh
how comments are useful all right how
comments are useful see comments are
useful in a in a way right it is uh
useful
see uh as a programmer all right we have
to uh make our code understandable all
right
uh because let's say i'm working on some
project right now all right i'm working
on some project and in that project all
right uh the code is of thousand lines
or two thousand lines or let's say even
uh hundred two hundred lines all right
now uh the code is being passed to
another developer he has to work on it
all right without any proper
documentation or
comments all right or we can't uh the
the coder all right the new developer
can't understand what that program is
doing all right we have to like
put a lot of time to understand the
whole code
but we can make that thing easier right
we can make that thing very simpler we
can comment all right we can comment the
lines
we can comment the lines right we can
means we can uh sort of create small all
right small documents or you could say
small
small lines or small paragraphs spot for
that particular code like let's say uh
currently we are developing uh uh
ar app and in there we have to rotate
all right we have to rotate that 3d
model right we have to rotate that 3d
model so i have written some code for
that
and in the top of that all right in the
top of that code
what i did i wrote a comment all right i
wrote a comment that this particular
code right this particular code
is rotating the 3d game object all right
it is it is rotating the object
all right so if i'm passing the code to
another developer then he won't have any
problem understanding the code all right
he won't have any problem
so that's why comments are useful
all right now let's let's try this out
and also uh there are actually two types
of comments all right single line
comment and multi-line comment
so what is a single line all right
single line comments works for only
single lines all right like it if the
line is one then it will be within line
one only or it will uh if you
are not understanding that don't worry
you are going to do the practical all
right so single line comments are
basically
uh they stay in one line already all
right if you if you go to the next line
that comment won't work all right that
comment won't extend actually but this
is not the case of with multi-line
comment all right multi-line comment can
help us in documenting also
so multi-line comments uh starts from a
particular point or let's say we are
starting that multi-line comment from
line number three all right and we are
writing some multi lines all right we
are writing some
text within that comment all right in
separate separate lines like you can see
right in here all right right like you
can see right in here
we have taken three lines to write some
content and
in the in the fifth line all right we
are ending it
in the fifth line we are ending it so
that's how we start a single uh
multi-line comment all right so to start
a single line comment we have to give uh
double forward slash all right
and to
write a multi-line comment all right
there are two things a starting point
and an ending point all right the
starting point is like forward slash
star
it is the start of the comment
and to end that comment what we have to
do is start backward slash
all right i hope you understand
right so let's try this thing out right
before going to variables let's try this
thing out
all right
so uh
this is our code all right
so
first of all let's write some sort of
code alright let's write console dot
right
line
uh comments
all right so this is our code right now
let's try to run it
let's run uh run this program see it is
printing comments right let's
let's uh
try to give the single line comment
notation all right
see uh
after i have given to forward slasher
you can see the whole line has gone
brown
what does this indicate this indicates
that this is a commented line all right
this is a commenting commented line
although the color will uh
will be different in your editor if you
are using some other kind of editor all
right because this is the theme of it
but don't worry about the color but it
is highlighted all right when it is
highlighted you are you will understand
that your code is committed commented
so let's run run it all right let's run
it
see it is not printing anything because
it is not reading the line
the compiler is just ignoring this
particular line all right now let's try
out something uh
another thing can we add another line of
code in the same same single line
comment can we so let's try it out why
not write it try it out right
let's try it out and see
so uh line two
all right
so let's try it out let's see that
the single line comment is also ignoring
the next one or not
oh no it is not ignoring the next line
okay do you know what what is the reason
the reason it it works for only one line
all right if if we give another
set of uh forward slashes
uh in line to comment means in the
console.writeline line two then again it
would perform its function all right but
it is also like it's it is the task is
also tedious to uh give every time uh
the double slashes right double forward
slashes so there's another thing all
right let's say we want to give
uh let's say we want to uh
write multi-line comment all right or
you could say we want to
write multi-line things right so first
of all let's give console.writeline
comments
all right
console
dot
right line
line
two
all right uh line two
again uh console
dot
right line
line
3 all right so
let's try it out all right let's try it
out
let's run it
see uh the code is running but we don't
want the code to run we want to comment
it all right we want the compiler to
ignore it so how would we do that all
right so simply give forward slash and
star all right
see uh as you can see here
just as i have gave as soon as i uh
gave this comment uh
comment notation multiline comment uh
starting point all right you can see it
has highlighted all right or made the
colors brown
from where it started all right
uh now we have to end it how would we do
that so it's it's again as simple as
that just start backward slash all right
and you can see the
commented portion is only brown
right let's run it
see
the compiler is ignoring the codes it is
as simple as that
so i hope you understood what are
comments all right comments are
basically uh some set of lines all right
that are ignored by the
compiler
that's it all right so now as we have
understood about comments let's uh let's
go for variables
all right
see
variables are you can uh see variables
are used to store some value all right
variables in a programming language are
used to store some value right so to see
i won't be using any technical terms to
uh make you understand about variables
all right
uh i would be using layman's term all
right or you can say the simple term
to uh make you understand about
variables all right so first of all
first of all think the variable as some
sort of a container all right a
container that can store something all
right let's say uh uh let's take a
common container all right let's say
let's say a water bottle all right take
a take and water bottle all right take a
water bottle it is a variable all right
for now think your variable as a water
bottle
all right and you are storing all right
something in it all right what thing
what is that thing that you are storing
in that water bottle
it is all right it is a liquid all right
in a water bottle you will store some
some kind of liquid doesn't matter what
kind of liquid it is
all right uh it can be a
orange juice or a chocolate milkshake or
a simple water right
or it is a liquid
all right doesn't matter what
what liquid it is but it is a liquid
right in the water bottle you are
storing some kind of liquid
all right
and
what liquid are you storing all right
what is the liquid
means is it water is it an orange juice
or is it a chocolate milkshake
so i want to store a chocolate milkshake
in the water bottle right or even a
simple water
i can store water in the water bottle
so
you can you can imagine all right you
can you can interpret this uh in
technical terms how see the water bottle
is acting like a variable or you can say
a container because variables are
containers variables are meant to store
some value
right
variables are meant to store some value
all right
so variables are container and in our
example
a variable is our water bottle okay
water bottle is our variable
all right and the
and
we are storing a liquid right
all right we are storing some sort of
liquid
in here the liquid is the type all that
liquid is the type of the data we are
storing
all right see water comes in the type of
liquid right we all know that chocolate
milkshake also comes under the type
liquid because it is liquid of course
then orange juice also comes under the
type of liquid right
so
we are storing some kind of liquid so
that is a type or you can also say data
type right we can also say data type
right it is the data type right so water
bottle is our variable
uh liquid is our data type and
and the type of liquid you are storing
all right the type of liquid you are
storing that is
uh water or let's say chocolate
milkshake
that is the data all right that is the
data we are storing
in our variable all right or you can say
in our water bottle so
we are taking our water bottle all right
we are taking some sort of liquid all
right
some sort of liquid is
the uh chocolate milkshake i am storing
my chocolate milkshake in the water
bottle all right and the type of the
chocolate milkshake
is
liquid
all right so i hope you understand so
variables are basically acts like as
containers they are containers but in
computer programming all right they are
containers in computer programming
right so let's uh to make you unmake
make it more understandable let me show
you all right see this won't execute of
course this will give you error but let
me tell you all right so this is
the type all right liquid is the type
water bottle
water bottle right water bottle
is our
container all right water bottle is our
container
and the data we are storing in it all
right the data we are storing in is
is
chocolate
milkshake
right
so yeah here you can see this liquid is
the data type all right this liquid is
the type this water bottle is the
container
and this
choco milkshake all right is our data
this choco milkshake is our
data all right and this is how right
this is how we
initialize all right or create a
variable in
our
c programming all right this is how we
create variable in many other
programming languages too like java c
plus plus so let's uh write a comment
for it all right that is data type data
type
then we have to give the variable name
right variable name
then we have to initialize
the data to it so this is how it works
right or you can say if i remove this
data only let's say type variable equals
data as simple as that nothing too
complicated
all right
so we are storing
chocolate milkshake
in our water bottle all right and what
type of
chocolate milkshake it is it is a liquid
right it is a liquid so that's it
right this is what variable is variable
is a container nothing else
so
i i already show you how to de like what
is the way of declaring a container
right now let's try it out all right
let's
let's try uh actually initializing a
variable right
let's try out initializing a variable in
in computing terms alright not and
layman's term
so it's simple first we have to give the
type or you can say data type
then we have to write the name of the
variable all right let's say i want to
store a number
all right then we have to
use the equals operator also known as
assignment operator all right and we
have to
assign all right we have to put some
sort of data
in our case in this case the data will
be number so i am trying going to put 12
in here all right and let's say it works
or not so i'm going what i'm going to do
is
i'm going to
print it out right
i am simply going to
print this thing out
let's see what happens yeah so it has
printed our
number that we stored in a variable
right so
we created a variable that is storing
the value
right so that's great it's a good start
actually so
we learned what is a variable all right
we learned what is a variable how to
create a variable one more thing i would
like to say is
now you you many of you might have a
question that we are creating a variable
right like uh where do we store our
water bottle all right we can we store
our water bottle in our backpack all
right or in in some place at our house
right
that's right right
so
where do we store this variable all
right where this variable gets stored
see
uh in our systems we have random access
memory all right that is ram all right
and uh
this some sort of all right when we
create a variable some sort of
memory is allocated alright what memory
like how much memory is allocated in the
ram we will see in the latest sections
we'll learn about data type all right
but it
it allocates all right or you can say
makes some space for the variables to
store in in the ram so our variables and
values are stored in the ram
all right
so i hope you understand
i hope you understand the concept of
variable all right if you are confused
in some point you can comment it down
all right
so uh now
it is there's a dialogue that
with great power comes great
responsibility right similarly
with variables there also comes rules
all right and we have to maintain those
rules
the very first rule all right the very
first rule is that a variable name in
shisha can only contain
numbers
uh letters numbers or underscores all
right what that means is all right we
can't create a variable all right uh let
me let me show you actually
in
dollar
num
equals 12 or
right
let's uh try to print it out and you
will
see what happens
all right
see
it is giving us an error that is
unexpected character
because
the reason is
c sharp doesn't allows a variable to
have dollar in in its variable naming
all right these are called naming
conventions
but we can have underscores all right we
already have letters right we already
have letter
we can have underscore all right we can
have underscore two
all right
so
yeah of course we can also have numbers
now here comes another rule regarding it
all right here comes another rule
regarding it
all right
so variable name all right variable name
can't start with a number
see here it is written that we cannot
start
a variable name with a number that is it
we cannot write a variable name as
three
abc or
two
name
like that all right let's try it out and
see all right let's try it out and
see if that works or not
right
so two num
let's try it out
see it is uh
giving us an error that is unexpected
symbol
but
but we can have
uh numbers in between all right we can
have numbers in between of variable
names all right like
n to um
i know it's it's weird but we can have
like this we can have numbers like this
all right similarly we can also add
numbers to the end of the variable all
right we can also
put numbers to the end of the variable
see it is working perfectly fine right
so we learned about two rules that uh
we can
only add letters numbers and under
underscores during any
uh naming convention already during the
naming of any variable
and also a variable can't start with a
number all right although it can have
all right it can have number in between
the name of the variable or at the end
of the variable
right
uh
so the next rule all right the next rule
we have is that we cannot use a reserved
keyword
we cannot use a reserved keyword as a
variable name
because
they already have their own meanings and
purposes to fulfill right now what does
this mean
see there are multiple keywords all
right or you can say reserved keywords
in uh
in our c program just like we saw
previously like using all right using
system
they are reserved keywords all right
using is a deserved keyword class is a
reserved keyword all right int alright
in is a reserved keyword if is a
reserved keyword
all right console it is a reserved
keyword
so
we cannot use any sort of reserved
keyword
during a variable naming convention
right
so let's try it out all right let's uh
let's give it
a variable name as
if
all right and just let's try it out what
happens let's see what happens
wow it has given some errors right it is
giving unexpected symbol equals then um
unexpected symbol f it would it will
give because this is not the syntax of f
right that's why it is giving the error
uh unexpected symbol equals
all right so yeah so you uh you learned
that we cannot use any sort of uh
reserved keywords as variable names all
right
similarly uh another thing is variable
names are case sensitive all right what
does this mean see
uh it means that if you write a variable
like this all right
let's say
uh if you
write a variable like this
name equals priyanshu alright see uh
this is a string data type all right i
would uh tell you what is this but don't
worry for now i'm just showing an
example
and uh let's try to print it out all
right
so let's try to print it out
and let's see what happens right
so you can see that it has printed my
name right
but let's say if i write the name in
capital letters all in caps all right
all in caps can you can you uh can can
you tell that will it uh execute the
program execute in the sense of course
it will execute but will it give any
sort of error or just print priyanshu as
it is written right now
all right so will it just take your time
alright just take a few seconds and
think about it all right think about it
will it alright pause the video and
think about it so let's let's run it now
all right
see it is giving us an error
it is giving us us an error why because
there is no variable defined as in a me
that is capital letters n a m e
there's a variable defined as
n a m e as small letters all right this
variable is in small letters and we
wrote it in
capital letters so both of them are
totally different
all right both of them are totally
different
so
uh always remember that
the variable names that is uh
the type or you could say not exactly
the type uh just check that if the
variable name is in caps
or in small letters already because
these are uh
case sensitives all right these
variables are case sensitives all right
so we can't have
like if we write a name in small letters
and we are trying to print that name in
capital letters means
in capital letters is
means that we are uh trying to write
that name variable in the
console.writeline in capital letters it
won't execute because it would uh then
it would search for another set of
variable alright it would search for
another variable whose whose
text is in a capital letter and is
written name all right so i hope you
understand
that we can't have
uh like variables means we can have
variables but uh they are case sensitive
all right like
uh because
the see in this example this first name
all right this first name you can see
that the first is written in a small
little the n is written in cap capital
letters and ame is written in small
letters but in in another is
in another
uh text it is uh the f is caps but but
the other
letters are in a
small letter all right are in small so
this
this name and this name are not same all
right both are totally different
all right
now as we have learnt about variable its
rules all right now it's our time
to get into the data types all right
see it is a very important concept all
right data types is a very important
concept so
uh try to understand it all right if you
are not able to understand something all
right you can comment it down and also i
would suggest re-watching this
particular portion all right re-watching
the particular portion you i have not
understood then also you have you
haven't understood you can comment it
down and i would uh
surely uh like to help you all right
so
yeah
data types right
see
uh i already told you about an example
right previously the water bottle
example that the liquid is the data type
or you can see the type of uh the value
right similarly data types are also the
same thing they they specify the type of
a variable already specify the type of
the variable
all right the type of value it can store
right
so
the very first data type we have is in
all right so basically the int
is basically a short for integer all
right
uh and it has a range all right it has a
range of minus 2 1 4 7 4 8 3 6 4 8
2. two one four seven four eight three
six four seven all right
what this means that
it has a range of
this to this all right it has a range of
this
to this
if we exceed that value all right let's
say if i write 2 1 4 7
4 8 3 6 4 7 then it would return a error
all right let's try it out all right
let's copy this value first all right um
let's copy this value first and uh let's
try that in our
code editor all right
so
um
yeah
int
val
equals
all right
so
now let's try to print it out
console.writeline
val
all right let's run
run the program and see it is printing
right it is printing the exact value
but but for now let's change it to two
one four
seven four eight three six four eight
can you tell me will it print or will it
like
give us some error
pause the video and think about it all
right think about it and
just
uh
tell me that will it print the value
all right just pause the video and think
about it so let's run the program
and let's see
my god it is giving us some sort of
error why it is giving that error
because the range is exceeded all right
means we have exceeded the range of
integer like here you have seen that the
max
means the negative range is
2147 483 648 right
and the positive range is up to
2147 483 647 but in there we wrote
2 1 4 7 4 8 3 6 4 8 so it is having
a plus one value all right it is
exceeding the range that's why it is
giving error
so ranges basically tells us that
how much value all right how much value
the a particular data type can store all
right and we also learned how to
uh
use integer as that is end as an
variable
right
so another is
long all right it is you can say it is a
big brother of int alright uh it also
store integer value all right that is
means non-decimal values you could say
or you can also say integer values all
right
so
it has a more higher range all right
this long all right that's long has a
more higher range
than in all right so when you need more
values to store all right when you need
more values to store that is
higher range of values to store then you
should go for long all right like let's
try out the same example right we like
here we see that we put some uh
using int
it exceeded it uh its
range right because
the range was up to two one four seven
four eight three six four eight right
but let's try the same thing out with
long will it exceed
let's see
no it won't it won't exceed
do you know the reason
the basic reason behind it is because
the range of long is much much bigger
than off
integer all right
it is really
the range is very much bigger than
integer
right
uh another thing all right
as you can see in air basically uh we
can also add a suffix all right we can
also add a suffix l
all right we can also add a suffix l in
here and it is not mandatory all right
it is not mandatory but it is
recommended to add the suffix l all
right it is recommended to add the
suffix
l
all right
so
uh
yeah
now as we have understood about uh long
all right as we have understood about
long
it is
now a time all right it is now time to
understand about
bite
so we are going to learn about uh byte
right so
another thing uh before going to buy it
all right another thing i would like to
suggest is whenever you are writing all
right it means this suffix l all right
in the long whenever you're writing this
always remember that to use capital all
right capital l
there's a very uh specific reason for
that because many people what many
people does is they gets confused with a
small letter l and one
it's sometimes uh confusing and even c
sharp uh
recommends to use a capital letter l
all right to use capital letter l in
spite of small literal or all right
although it will give a warning if you
if you use small letter l but uh there
won't be much uh issues with that but it
is recommended to use capital letter l
in spite of
small letter l in the suffix of long all
right long data type
so uh let's get into the byte all right
by data type see
byte is also uh
so uh sort of integer only all right it
also stores uh
integers but
the byte all right bytes range is really
low all right byte has a really low
range
all right
byte has a really
low range
so uh the range of it is from 0 to 255
all right it is it is the range of
byte so if we try it out all right if we
try this example out alright if we try
this example out
so basically if we try this example out
that is byte
all right
byte
val alright now if we give value uh
exceeding already if we give value
exceeding
255 that is let's say 300
all right and then try to print console
dot uh
right
line
all right
val
so let's see what it does all right
let's see what it basically
does
let's see all right so
it is giving us some sort of error why
it is giving error all right why it is
giving it it is giving us error because
we exceeded the limit all right now if
we give something
under the limit all right that is
between the uh
0 to 255 all right let's say we give 255
only
all right if we give this
see
it is working perfectly fine
so yeah that's what byte is it has a low
range but it is an integer data type
all right similarly we also have other
data types all right now we are going
getting into the floating the point data
types or you can say decimal data types
alright that
these are the data types that has
decimal decimal places
all right these data types has decimal
places so the very first data type we we
will be learning in uh in decimal places
uh
all right uh that is floating point
numbers or you can say
float all right so float is a data type
all right which can have a decimal means
which have decimals places in numbers
alright if you want to store
the uh some value in points we can't
store that in integer of course right so
we have to use some sort of data types
meant for it so similarly there are
three data types all right
meant for uh storing
uh decimal placed uh values that is
float double and decimal all right so
the very first thing we are learning is
float
all right so
floating point basically float refers
all right to floating point numbers all
right and they have decimal places in
the numbers all right just like 1.34
then 5.64
all right these numbers have decimals
decimal places and them
and uh if we talk about the range all
right
the the float has a range of plus minus
1.5 into 10 to the power minus 45 all
right
plus minus 3.4 into 10 to the power
38 all right so this is the range of
float
all right and also float uh
uses eight bytes of storage all right
and it has a precision of about
seven digits all right
so basically
um
it has a precision of seven digits all
right what that means is it mean that if
you are storing a number like one point
two three four five six seven eight nine
all right if you are storing a numbers
like this
so it will be rounded off all right it
would be rounded
off to
1.2345
all right so it would be rounded off to
this
all right so let's uh learn how to
initialize this float variable
right
let's learn to do so
so
float
all right
value
equals
all right float value equals
let's give some sort of uh
decimal value that is 12.5
and also add a suffix
f all right
then what this suffix uh
f does is it tells that it is a floating
point value now by default all right by
default
the val the decimal value is all right
the decimal values are in double all
right are in the format of double so it
is always recommended to
give f in the uh back off
float uh float numbers all right
floating point numbers
so val
let's try and print it out all right
see it is printing 12.5 now let's try it
try it out without the f suffix
all right
let's see what happens it is giving us
error the uh
the reason is because the
the means
these decimal values all right by
default these decimal values by default
are in
uh double all right are in the type of
double so it is always
recommended
to
uh you uh add
f suffix
at the last of
float variables right
so that's what
it is
all right
so as simple as that
so
yeah
let's uh let's see all right
let's see other data types too that is
double all right let's see
double
so
as we have learned about float all right
it is uh a really great data type to be
used all right another is a double all
right it has a higher range all right
this double has a higher range and
a good precision all right a good
precision
so
double all right what is a double all
right see double is also our data type
and uh it is a 64 bit all right
it is a 64 double precision floating
point type all right
and uh it has a precision of 14 to 15
digit all right it has a good precision
of around 14 to 15 digit
and
also all right also to initialize a
double variable we have to use
the suffix
small d or capital d
all right similarly in float also we can
use capital f but i use
small f all right
okay uh so here in the example i guess i
did a mistake uh i would fix this issue
all right here you can see in the
example i give
float num equals 12f but don't worry in
the in the final note that would be that
you would be getting all right i wish
i'd be fixing this issue all right but
for now uh i will show you the actual
example all right i will show you the
example i'm really sorry about this
mistake
but uh in the actual uh note this issue
will be fixed all right uh so the range
all right so double has a range of uh
plus my uh plus minus 5.0 into 10 to the
power minus
324 2
plus minus 1.7 into 10 to the power
308 all right so let's try it out let's
try this double
all right let's try this double out
so
in
let's get to the
editor of course all right and let's
write
double
all right
num
equals
12.5
all right
d
okay
and then console
dot log
oh sorry not console.log i'm always
writing this thing because in the unity
it is uh to write any sort of comment
we do debug.log so it's like
uh it it is habituated to me
so um
yeah
so let's try and print it out all right
let's see if it gives any sort of errors
or runs seamlessly so we can see that it
has rams ran
seamlessly all right
so we have learned about double data
type all right we have learnt about
float we have learnt about int we have
learnt about long we have learnt about
byte we have learnt about float we have
learnt about double now it's our time
all right it is now it is our time
to understand this decimal
all right let's understand this
decimal data type
all right see decimal is another
floating point data type alright where
you can
store decimal values all right even the
name suggests it
so
but all right but
this data this decimal all right this
decimal uh
has much greater precision all right
than
any other all right that is a float or
double all right the precision of
float and double is lower than
decimal all right so the decimal has
better precision all right it has a
greater precision that is of
approximately 28 to 29 digits all right
approximately 28 to 29 digits
so
this double uh this decimal data type
all right has an uh
greater precision of approximately 28 to
29 digits all right and
it is recommended all right it is always
recommended to use the decimal data type
all right in spite of double or
float if you want a
greater precision all right if you want
a greater precision then you should use
decimal all right but the range but the
range of decimal data type is
uh lower than
that of
double
and float all right so
it has basically a range of um
plus
plus minus 1.0 into 10 to the power
minus 28
to
uh plus minus 7.9228
into 10 to the power 28 so this is the
range all right this is
the range of decimal
data type all right similarly let's um
try it out let's try it out
in our code editor all right so um it's
very simple i already included uh
the definition right and also the
example all right nothing to uh to
complicate it in here so
decimal
num
equals
25.5
d
sorry the suffix will be m not d i'm
really sorry about that so the suffix
will be
m all right so the suffix for decimal is
m so this is how we write a
uh initialize a decimal data type all
right this is how we do it
so
now as we have learned about uh decimal
data type now it's our time to learn
about three other data types all right
that is cad bool and string
these are very important data types all
right all of the data types that i am
teaching you all right all of them are
very important for you to understand
all right
so
care all right cad data type what does
care all right what is care actually
care is a care basically stands for
character all right or you can see
letter all right a particular letter all
right it's like like uh like a is a
particular letter or a character like b
like c like d
all right
so these are characters all right these
are characters
similarly if you say have to all right
if we want to define any sort of
character in
our program how do we do that all right
how would we
do that
it's
pretty simple all right it's pretty
simple
just to write
care all right
also i'm not changing the variable name
i'm going to keep it numb only right or
let's change it let's change it all
right and let's say i want to store a
character all right called a
alright
and if i
put ch all right
now i want to print it all right
so let's see it gets print or printed or
not so here it is being printed one more
thing or there are some details that you
should look out for first of all all
right
if you are a character alright a
character data type can only store
only one letter all right
it can't store a b all right abc it can
only store one letter all right
another thing you have to uh
put in your mind is that
whenever we write a character
we have to enclose that particular uh
letter
in single brackets like just like we did
in here all right so similarly let's try
another out that is b
all right
and
let's
run this program all right
see it is printing b
all right now what if all right if we
what if we try to add
multiple
all right add
multiple uh
letters in it so here you can see it is
giving us error because of course this
is a single this can only store a single
character it can only store as
uh uh like only one only one character
all right so that's we are giving it to
it that is only one character so
remember
uh if you if you want to store only a
single character then always go for
care all right
now
our next all right uh let's see what is
our next yeah our next topic is bool all
right see bool uh is stands for boolean
all right it is the short for boolean
so
bool data types uh can only contain true
or false all right
true means on all right true means it is
executable all right true means uh it
will work it true means on
and false means
off all right you can say it is off
right
right so if you take an example of a
circuit all right or you can say your
lights also all right your lights also
so you have a switch in your house all
right to turn on the light so when you
turn on the light all right
the value of that particular switch is
becoming true
all right or you can say the value of
that particular switch is becoming on
and because
the the
value is true alright because the value
is true the current is flowing all right
the current is flowing through the
circuit
and
lighting
and putting the lights on all right and
and it is putting the putting the lights
on similarly if you turn off
the switch all right similarly if you
turn off the switch then the value of
the switch will be false and no current
will pass through it all right it will
just terminate so that's what true and
false is in terms of programming
similarly how would how can we uh
basically um
how can we basically initialize it i
have also given you example also all
right and i will also show you how to do
that
all right
so
bool
is
running so am i running
no i'm sitting
right i'm i'm sitting right
so
if i print it now all right if i
print it now
let's see what happens
see it is uh printing us true that the
value is
true
right that the value is
now if i if i turn it false that is yeah
i am running
then let's say what happened
it is printing false see we uh we will
understand the use of true and false all
right this true and false in further
lectures already because we'll be using
this
often
uh especially in the if else all right
in the if else and the development so
you at that time you will understand the
use case of
bull and how important is it
all right
now
similarly we have another alright string
now previously uh
you might think that it is also similar
to care and
it is somewhat true all right see a
string all right a string is basically
collection of characters all right the
thing that we can't do
in cad data type we can do that in
string data type all right string is a
collection you can say it is a
collection of characters
all right every letter in here is a
character p is a character r is a
character all right and we are able to
contain it all right you can say ah we
are able to
unite them in a single variable
all right that we can't do in character
because it can only store a single
letter
right
so that's what a string is string can
store multiple characters in a single
variable all right because it is a
collection of
characters
all right let's try out string
name
you can write your own name all right my
name is priyanshu
all right
so oh also i forgot to give the
semicolon this happens a lot
and then
name let's try it out and see
what happens
see it is printing priyanshu it is not
giving us any sort of error just like
the candidate when we try to store abc
right so string can store multiple
characters because it is it can store a
collection of characters
all right
so another thing already that is
noticeable in here is uh whenever you
are writing a string or that whenever
you are using a string you cannot use
uh single quotes alright you you should
only use double quotes all right so
whenever initializing a string remember
to uh
enclose the
characters or you can say the let uh
means the word all right the word that
you are uh assigning in the string
string type variable all right remember
to enclose them in double quotes all
right just like we did in here
all right
so
yeah
now
it is our time alright it is our very
time to understand or you can say learn
all right it is our very time to learn
uh about strings in depth all right
because strings is one of the most
important concepts all right in in
programming
so let's understand it all right the
very first thing we are going to learn
is concatenation all right what is
concatenation all right see
concatenation is uh nothing too much
of a complicated thing all right it is a
really simple thing
all right see concatenation uh is
basically the joining all right it is
basically the joining of two strings all
right
concatenation means it is the joining of
two particular strings all right that is
what concatenation is
so
let's try it out practically right let's
try it out in our code editor
all right
so
see here we have the name right i'm not
going to edit anything in it just i'm
going to add
some another instructions to it all
right so add a plus in it all right add
a plus
and
all right and
then add
the title all right that is
rg all right this is my title right
also i would like to give a space before
bhattacharjee because then it would add
some space to it
then let's let's try to print it all
right
see we i am able to print my
full name and we have successfully
concatenated all right see uh you might
think that
hey man this ad is used for adding two
numbers right we can use this ad
to add two numbers
right we can use this ad to add two
numbers means addition operator
but if we talk about in terms of strings
alright if you talk about in terms of
strings then this uh add operator
becomes a concatenation operator right
means it is used to
uh concatenate
two strings into one all right
uh this is what this addition uh
operator does in terms of strings all
right as simple as that
all right
so yeah
now as we have understood about
concatenation concatenation is nothing
but
the joining alright the joining of two
different strings
all right now here comes some
very important uh string methods all
right
it is very important to understand
all right
so
let's see see uh
this
uh length method all right it basically
tells us what is the length of the
string
all right it basically tells us what is
the length of the string
let's try it out all right let's simply
try it out let's uh see we are going to
do it with a very simple string alright
that a string that doesn't has a lot of
characters all right so
let's take a b c all right
see this we all know that this this
particular string has three characters
right this particular thing has three
characters
so
let's try to print the length of it
and let's see what happens
wow it has given three now let's add
another all right let's add another
character in it and let's see what it or
what it does
so as you can see it in here that it has
printed four so our length means the
strings length is four of course
so
that's what the length does all right
and this is going to be really helpful
in our further sections all right even
in the development
so
always remember to go through these
notes all right after
watching a particular lecture all right
so always go through these notes to
clear your concepts again all right or
you can say revision of your concept now
here's another function all right that
is equals
all right
what this equals does see
uh this equals will just compare
one string to another all right it would
just compare one string to another
nothing uh too much in here all right it
would just compare one string to another
all right so let's try it out in here
right uh i give it uh
let's write another string alright
string name
two all right
equals uh let's say
dc
ba
right and
let's try to use this function all right
how to use this function first of all
select alright
select a variable all right that you
want or to compare to all right
so i'm going to select name as my parent
variable on it i want to compare name to
with name
with name all right so then
you have to give name dot
equals
all right and then
within the parenthesis all right within
the parentheses of equals
we have to pass the second variable that
is
name two all right and then
simply print it out
as simple as that
all right guys uh
sorry i had to change the ide
all right the code editor i was using
that is gdb compiler uh it had some
server issues all right so now i'm using
jdoodle all right and let's try to run
this program again button jd all right
and let's see uh what will be the output
so here you can see false why is it
false because of course
of course
dcba
is not equals to abcd both are different
all right now if we
try to give
abcd
again all right
let's say what will be its output
see it is giving true
why
why is it giving true it is giving us
true because abcd
is equals to abcd both are same right
so
yeah of course
now
all right we are going to see two more
methods or you can say two more
functions of strings
that is index of and element at but
before that all right we have to be
aware of the concept of indexing
all right where uh where this uh concept
comes in picture what is this uh what is
that all right so yeah see indexing is
basically tells the placement all right
it basically tells the placement or you
can say where the particular character
is present in the string all right like
it is it works sort of look uh sort of
like a location
in the particular string
all right now
in programming all right in programming
indexing always starts from zero all
right so remember the first character
alright the very first character of the
string all right the very first
character of the string
will always be
zero all right will always be zero now
if we take uh take an example of abc
all right and we want all right we want
the index of let's say b all right we
want the index of
b
so basically the index of b would be 1
how
i already told you that the starting
point all right it is the indexing
always starts from zeroth position
all right the indexing always starts
from
zeroth position
so a would be zero b would be 1 and c
would be 2
so the b
b's address is
1 the a's address is 0 and c's address
is 2. that's what indexing is it tells
us
the index or you can say the level
location
now there are two or two certain
functions all right there are two
certain functions available all right
there are two certain functions
available for
getting the index and
getting the index and the element
present at the index all right see the
in what index office does all right in
the index of function we have just um
pass all right we have to pass
a particular um
means a particular character present in
the string all right and it would return
or you could say it would give us
the index all right the index position
of the
particular character all right
let's let's try it out
let's try it out
it would be as simple as that nothing
nothing too much complicated in here
all right
so now
if i if i had to remove this weight
yeah
so
what we have to do is we have to just
write index all right index
off
and then
let's say i want the index all right i
want the index of
c
how would i do that
all right
before this
pause the video and try uh
okay it's giving us error
oh i understood why it is giving error
actually i use single quote uh
single quotes i'm really sorry about
that although ah the quiz is still on so
you have to guess all right you have to
guess
or not even guess try to
try to calculate all right try to
interpret by yourself that what will be
the output of this all right because we
are trying to get the index or that we
are trying to get the index of
c or at index value of c from that
string that is containing a b c d all
right now let's execute it all right
so it is again giving me errors i'm not
sure why wait
a definition for index of no instruction
type code string
all right wait
oh sorry yeah
as i told uh case sensitivity i
uh i actually used a small letter i
that's uh that's why i was like confused
why it is giving error it would the cap
the first letter will be in caps all
right
so
the index all right so the index of c is
2 how if we talk about a
the index of a is 0 because it is the
starting point so of course it would be
0 then index of b
is uh
1 alright index of b is 1 and the index
of c is
2 all right similarly after this all
right similarly after this there's
another unlike that is element of all
right let's
see let's see sorry element at i'm
really sorry about that so uh
it got a rhyming
so uh yeah
so the uh this is the element that
function what it basically does is see
we have to pass all that we have to pass
some sort of index value alright we have
to pass an index value in it and
and after we pass the index value let's
say i pass uh from the a from abcd i
pass 2 all right then it would return c
because the at index 2
c is present right let's try it out
let's try it out and
you will uh you will also notice
something all right now i will tell you
what
element
at all right
and we have to put the
index value that is let's say i want
the value present at index 3 all right
let's see
see it is giving it is giving some sort
of error what error why is it giving
that error
see the reason
that is giving the error
basically in in the system
in the system name space there is no dot
element at function available right
now to uh use this function we have to
uh
include another name space that is using
system
dot
link
all right and then if we run it all
right and then if we run it
see we got
the element present at index 3 that is
d all right now if i if i want element
present at let's say
1 can you guess what
in the index 1 which element is present
pause the video and think all right
pause the video and think and
tell in the comments all right
let's try it out
let's see
wow
it is correct
at
index one element b is present that is
uh at zero already at index 0 a is
present at index 1 b is present right so
it is as simple as
that
all right
now
uh i already told you about sys uh
link all right so
we used a system.link all right it is it
is another namespace alright link is
basically a part of system name space
only all right and it contains the
element at method
nothing too complicated all right
so till now we have learnt a lot all
right we have learnt a lot about data
types we have learnt a lot about
comments we have learnt a lot about
variables
right and the lecture has almost crossed
one hour point all right so now this is
our last all right this is our last
topic of today alright last but not the
least because there are many other
topics available that is operators loops
conditionals and etc so
now this concept all right now i also
have a homework for you that you guys
have to do all right i won't
show you how to do it all right i won't
show you how to do it but you have to do
it by yourself already because
after this type casting i'm pretty sure
that you would be able to solve some
like
a problem uh
only one problem means i would only give
you one problem and i think you will be
i think you will be able to solve it
already
so
see sometimes alright sometimes it is
really necessary for us all right to
change the value already before
assigning means to change not the value
but the type of the value before
assigning all right
let's say if you if we want to assign
already if we want to assign
a floating point value to our integer of
course of course it will give
us an error right of course it will give
us an error because of course we can't
store a floating point value alright we
can't store a floating point
value
in all right we can't store a floating
point value
in our integer right in our
integer
right so we we have to convert it all
right we have to cast it we have to
convert that uh type that typed value
right that float type value so let's try
it out all right so typecasting is
basically changing the type of the value
before assigning as simple as that all
right so let's take another thing that
is int
val alright end val equals
23.2 all right
if
uh uh of course we have to uh add f
suffix if we are going to add floating
float
float type value all right and let's try
to print it out all right let's see it
uh
it works or not
so
val all right
let's see it works or not
oh my god it has it has given us some
some error right constant value cannot
be converted to a end right because of
course it can't be converted because
because uh a compiler cannot convert it
by itself we have to give some sort of
instruction to convert it right so how
would we do that
as simple as that
we have to convert it to end right so
before uh assigning the value all right
like you have assigned this value before
that
give a parenthesis all right and give
the data type you want to convert the
value to so it currently uh this value
is in float all right this value is in
float we want to convert it to end to
store in the
in data and variable right
see
it has stored basically what is
happening is it is removing that
uh value from the point all right from
the decimal it is removing that value
all right and it is storing the exact
value
all right so this is what type casting
is
now all right now another thing i would
like to show you is we can also do this
with the variable also all right let's
let's um create
a variable all right that is float fl i
have given any name i i could have
imagined it all right so let's give 23
point or let's say
24.5 f all right
so let's give that all right and
whatever i do is i will remove that
value and instead of that value i'm
going to put the variable all right i'm
going to put the variable
and
let's let's remove this end also first
try without converting and then let's
see what will be the output right i'm
trying to assign a float value in the
integer see
it is giving all right cannot implicitly
convert
type float to int all right
and xp and explicit conversion
exists are you missing a cast see the
compiler is so kind that it is also
telling us
what
what can help us fixing it all right so
what thing can help us fixing it right
so let's do it
so open the brackets all right open the
brackets and we are going to typecast it
that is
end all right we are going to type cast
it to int all right and let's say it
works or not let's see
wow
congratulations it has worked it has
worked right we
we have successfully make
uh the
floating point worked right we have
successfully typecasted now
now here's a task for you all right
here's a task for you you have to
convert
an integer to float
all right you have to convert an integer
to float this is your task
all right after after watching the video
you can surely complete it all right it
is as simple as that it is not that
complicated task right
so
for today all right for today's lecture
for a module 3.2 we have come
successfully completed this lecture
all right and in the next lecture we are
going to learn about operators all right
uh it is really important to learn about
the operators so next lecture is on
operators
hey guys welcome to this lecture and in
today's lecture we are going to learn
about operators in shisha all right
this particular topic is very important
for us because whenever we'll be uh
coding any solution or let's say we'll
be solving any sort of problems all
right or maybe coding our own uh
mechanisms in augmented and virtual
reality
we'll be needing operators on a highly
basis because this is the very
fundamental concept all right all the
operations that we perform within a
program
happens only because of operators
all right
because
for example whenever we are assigning
some value to a variable right when we
whenever we are assigning some value to
a variable
the assignment that is the equal all
right the equals to option uh or the
equals to sign is called assignment
operator yeah that is also operator or
let's say for another example
we let's say we are multiplying all
right we are multiplying
a particular speed
all right to time dot delta time all
right
i'm just taking it as an example we will
be covering time dot delta time in
future videos whenever when we will be
uh learning
to code in unity and uh
we'll be developing our ar applications
all right but for uh time being just
understand this uh there's some function
that is time the delta time and we are
multiplying
uh the speed variable all right the
speed variable with the time dot delta
time all right and the you know the s
means the multiplication sign
all right that will be putting in there
that is also an operator
all right so
operators are everywhere in program so
it is very important for us to
understand the concepts of operators all
right so basically what are operators
see an operator is basically used to
perform some certain functions or
calculations within the program all
right for an example assigning some
values to a variable all right uh
just like an equals to operator or as i
said the multiplication operator is
there to multiply right
so similarly we use operators for
multiple tasks all right and in today's
lecture we are going to see that
now
the there are multiple types of
operators all right there are multiple
types of operators there are majorly
five that is uh arithmetic operators
relational operators
logical operators assignment operators
and bitwise operators in this lecture
all right
uh we are going to learn about four the
four of these operators all right that
is arithmetic relational logical and
assignment all right we won't be needing
bitwise operators as of now so that's
why i am not teaching it
but uh if you want i can bring a whole
lecture video on bitwise operators all
right because uh
to understand bitwise operators you need
to understand binary operations all
right how how we perform binary
calculations because bitwise operator
shifts those binaries right so that's
why i'm not including this uh bitwise
operator concept uh in
you know
in this lecture
so in this lecture we are going to learn
about only four of these and uh
all right so let's start with our very
first operator arithmetic all right so
see the use all right the use of this
operator's
operator is only available in its name
arithmetic
means we use these operators to perform
some sort of calculation all right
we use this operators to
perform some sort of calculation
the calculation can be anything it can
be division it can be multiplication it
can be addition it can be subtraction
all right and we are going to look into
that
so here are all the operators listed in
you know in a table that is the plus
operator it is used for addition of
values you can do it like this a plus b
equals 10. similarly there is
subtraction then there is multiplication
right then there is a division all right
you might
this might seem a bit unfamiliar all
right means of course there's a
percentage sign all right but
in terms of programming we don't call it
a percentage
all right in terms of programming we
don't call it a percentage we call
it a modulo operator all right we call
it a modulo operator all right a modulus
what this operator does is
this operator
gives you the remainder all right it
gives you the remainder of any division
right like for an example divide seven
by two all right
there will always be a remainder of 1
all right so
that's how it gives us the remainder of
you know
a particular calculation
right and
here uh in the last two these are unary
operators the what these basically does
now this plus plus sign increments value
all right increments value with one
let me uh make you understand
this plus plus sign all right we'll be
incrementing the value as 1
and this
negative means negative negative that is
double negative this will decrement the
value
all right this will decrement the value
that's it
now
to you know understand it more all right
understand it more wisely more carefully
let's do one thing let's uh do a
practical on it right so i'm going to
open uh just uh give me a second all
right okay here is the editor
so i'm just going to open it all right
and uh what i uh first the very first
thing all right what i wanted to do is
declare two variables all right
that is the uh first variable i would
like to be you know um let's say eight
and uh you know the second variable
let's uh be it four
all right now
i'm going to perform the calculations
you can see there are two ways to
perform the calculation you can create
another variable that's in c equals a
plus b all right another way around is
um
you just directly print it all right
just directly print it that is a
console.writeline a plus b alright both
will do the same task but the difference
between them is
in here you are just printing you aren't
means in this particular line you are
just printing all right you are just
printing the adding
additive value but when you are
assigning a variable and then uh doing
addition in it just like uh like just
like this all right
what you are doing is you are storing
the
addition of a plus b that is addition of
a and b
in another variable c all right you can
surely do that let me uh let's do it
that way all right that would be better
so here you can see
all right here you can see
that we are performing the addition now
let's see it's uh
is it even working let's start up
yeah it's it's perfectly working what is
the addition of eight plus four it is 12
and we got it right now now uh let's try
out uh you know subtraction so to do the
subtraction it's very simple remove the
addition operator and put that minus
operator all right or you can say uh
in your keyboard there would be a dash
put that all right
it is called a minus operator and you
can see 8 minus 4 is 4
right now
let's do another thing all right let's
multiply it
all right let's see
see eight forza is 32 so multiplication
is also working now let's let's try out
uh division okay uh before uh
doing the division operator i want you
to pause the video and do the
calculation by yourself without using
any program uh let's see if you get that
get it correctly or not
see yeah four to the eight so uh
that uh outcome is two right
so
that's how it works alright so till now
we have seen four operators
or which one is uh means
which are those addition subtraction
multiplication and division now let's
see all right
let's see the remainder operator all
right
can you guess what would be the
remainder of
like what would be the output of this
particular calculation
just give it a thought all right
do it manually all right and then again
continue with the video
it's zero because uh
when we divide eight with four all right
it's completely
being divided all right the division is
being completed so remainder is zero now
let's say if i give uh let's say for now
i remove eight and gave nine let's see
the output is one
because there's a remainder remaining
all right the division is not being
completed
so that's how this remainder operation
works
all right it's fairly simple
so
we saw about uh you know addition
subtraction multiplication division and
remainder now there remains two more
operator all right and those are called
unary operator uh what that does is they
increment or decrement the value
all right
see
there are two ways
all right there are two ways
of using increment and decrement
variables all right means a increment
and decrement
unary operators all right
so understand it like this so now the
basic see to understand unary operator
all right first of all we have to
understand what it does see unary means
these increment and decrement operators
now they
increment the number
or
decrement the number all right means it
will uh like if i let me show you by
example only all right let's remove this
particular uh particular calculation
from here all right let's uh
let's let's perform this increment
operator on let's say b all right let's
give b plus plus let's see what happens
all right let's just see what happens
so
here you can see all right let let me
show you again
here you can see the operation is not
working
means uh
i i promised you guys right that uh
this particular plus plus operator will
increment the value
right
let me tell you one thing
it is incrementing now there's a whole
round of concept behind it all right but
before that let me show you by
incrementing incrementing the value
actually so give plus plus b
right let's see if this works
yeah it works but why didn't the first
one work
see
let me uh
let me wrap your head around it first of
all
the plus plus sign alright let me uh
make a comment right in here all right
see first of all understand all right
this plus plus operator is always used
for incrementing
all right and this minus minus operator
is always used for
decrementing right increment means
increasing the number by one all right
means this operator will always
increment a number by one
and decrement means
this operator will always decrement the
number
by one all right that is subtract one
from the previous value let me show you
something like this
see our value was 4 right our value was
and now it as it has decremented by 1 it
is 3
right
so
that's how increment and decrement works
all right now the there's a underlying
concept already there's an underlying
concept behind increment and decrement
operator all right that is post
increment pre-increment
all right
and
post decrement and pre-decrement
all right now what are those first of
all let's uh let's wrap up our head uh
around pre-incur increment all right
that is the uh
pre and post increment so first write it
pre increment all right so what this
does all right pre means
first
all right means that it it will perform
the tax task first then anything else
all right understand this way
pre-increment is that is it will be
performing all right it will be
performing
the operation first
means
in our case the operation is
incrementing so it will
uh perform the incrementation
first all right and how do we write it
fairly simple plus plus first of all we
would be giving this uh symbol plus plus
and then write the variable name all
right
so that's how pre-increment work
all right and post increment is
after
all right after performing the
operation
all right now i know this might get a
bit confusing and we write it like this
all right that is b plus plus post
increment
now
see
let me clear this message
pre-increment
pre-increment what is doing first it is
all right first
it is incrementing the value then
assigning
and post incrementing or post increment
what is it doing is first it is
uh you know
assigning then incrementing all right in
case of this variable that's why that's
why previously the b plus plus didn't
work
that's the reason because it or it has
already first it has already assigned
the value of b
to the variable c
after assigning it then it is
incrementing
all right
that's the difference between pre and
post
that's the difference all right
nothing else or else in both the cases
value is being incremented just the
difference is one is doing doing it
first then assigning it and the another
one uh what the other one is doing it is
first assigning it then and incrementing
it that's that's the difference all
right
so that's how this thing works all right
now let's try it again let's let's uh
try pre-decrement all right that is plus
plus b all right now
just guess the output alright let's
let's not uh get b let's uh let's get a
all right
guess the output what will be the output
it would be nine
right because why because first of all
it is incrementing then assigning the
value increment uh increase incrementing
by how much it is incrementing by one
all right now let's again uh
try out a plus plus let's see how that
works
see
uh it is
it is not showing that uh it has
incremented but
but
our particular all right
this particular value has been
incremented right
now
i know you might not be believing me all
right you might think what what is the
proof all right and your question is
right it's totally right all right so
let me first you know uh
let's comment out this line let me show
you if
this this particular function is even
incrementing it or not
let's see
all right let's see so give a uh go to
console.writeline and
write a plus plus let's see
so here you can also see that
it is not showing all right that it is
incremented
right
i know it might be confusing now let me
show you another way around
here is the variable i wrote this
variable in here all right and again do
a plus plus in here all right don't
assign it to any variable just do a plus
plus
and let's see yeah it worked
how how see it is not assigning any
variable we aren't printing any variable
we are printing a variable but we have
we haven't assigned this increment all
right we haven't assigned this increment
to any other variable all right just
like we did in the
variable c we didn't do that all right
did we we didn't
so it just incremented the value it
didn't assign itself so it it has not
stored
now it as it has incremented the value
that's why we are getting nine so here
you can see that this particular thing
is working right it's totally working
fine
so the major decrement uh sorry
the major uh
you know difference between uh
pre-increment and post increment is
that one works first and the other one
works
last something like that all right of uh
means uh this that is the pre one all
right the pre-increment will increment
the value first then assign it and the
post increment post increment will uh
first of first of all assign and then
increment that's the difference all
right so same all right same concept
goes around
the decrement all right that is pre
decrement
that would be
you know
minus minus b and post
decrement
would be b minus minus
right so let's let's try this one two
right first of all let's try uh minus
minus b all right so our current value
for b is
you know c and let's print the c right
see
we are getting 3 because
first it is being decremented then
assigned now let's again try all right
let's again try b minus minus in here
and let's see if that works or not
no it's not working because
the value is already assigned and we are
printing that assigned value
now to check whether
uh
act in real all right in real if it is
being decremented or not
okay i guess i ran it by mistake so um
let's go and give
b minus minus alright and let's remove
the c and let's put b in here let's see
if uh
works yeah it worked it did work
so you can see that this post decrement
also works so
that is what
p pre and post agreement is all right
very simple all right nothing too
complicated so i'm going to erase this
program all right i'm going to use this
program and go towards our next
set of operators all right so
we are clear with this concept of
operators all right
addition operator is for addition
subtraction operator is for subtraction
this asterisk is for you know uh
multiplication this slash is for
division this mod uh module or you can
say percentage operator is for remainder
all right this
plus plus operator is for incrementing
and this
minus minus operator is for decrementing
all right
so i hope you understand
how arithmetic operative works right now
here comes our relational operator all
right see
again
the meaning of this operator is already
told in uh is already listed in its name
it relation it tries to
uh you know tell us that if there is any
relation between the two values right
now in this operator there are
you know uh how many types are there six
total six types is there that is equals
equals not equals greater than less than
greater than equals less than equals
uh if you are you know uh i know most uh
everyone uh if you uh means every one of
you uh have experience with uh maths
right i know everyone every single
person of you and you already know what
uh greater than equals does less than
equals does right
so
let me make this thing clear to you see
if
all right if the condition is correct
then it will return true if the
condition is correct then it will return
to if the condition is false then sorry
if the if if the condition is not
correct all right or the condition is
wrong
all right or let's say the condition is
not matching then it will return false
all right
and uh these operators alright these
operators are
wide very widely used all right these
operators are very widely used in
if else operations all right if else for
loop operations so we'll be learning
those two
so don't worry all right
the main focus currently for us is to
understand all right is to understand
how these operators works so for that
let me open my uh you know let me open
this particular
you know
this uh
editor and let's
see our relational operator so let's
give it a comment all right relational
operators
see there are total six operators you
know who are those and let me
show you what do they do all right
let me show you so
take two very uh variable that is in
a let's uh
it 12 and let's take another variable
that is
no into b and let's assign it
right
now
all right
do one thing write console.writeline
rightline all right
and the very first operator is equals
equals operators now let's see
what it will return
let's see
it's returning false why why see
understand the concept behind equals
equals this is a this
operator all right this operator
compares two values all right and if
both the values are same all right if
both the values are same then it will
return true and if both the values are
not same
then it will return false all right so
these equal equal to operator is used
for comprising now as i have changed the
value of v to 12 and also the value of a
is 12. now let's see what it returns see
it is returning true because the
condition is true
the condition means uh
a and b
is means a and b are equal all right a a
is also 12 b is also 12. so that's what
uh you know
equals equals operators does now the
second one for us was not equals all
right it's the total opposite
it will check
if the value is equals to or not equals
now let me show you all right
a naught equals to b now can you guess
what will be the output
all right pause the video and think for
a few seconds and
uh you know try to answer it by yourself
what will be the output
so let's see
it is returning us false why because the
it is the the conditional
is also is only telling us not equals to
we don't want it to be equal all right
it means if it if both the values are
not equal to each other then only i will
return true and if they are equal i will
not i will return false now let's try to
change the value to you know change the
value of b to 10. now let's see
it is returning true
now
we understood about equals equals
operator we understood you know we
understood about uh not equals operator
what's next
next is
greater than all right next is greater
than and less than operator now let me
show you all right
let's see a all right a greater than b
of course you all know it will you know
return false because uh sorry it will
return true because of course a is
greater than b a is 12 10 ah b is 10 now
let's see
yeah it is returning to now now you know
let's uh let's uh
let's
give it 13 all right let's change the
value of b to 13 let's see
it is returning false
right it is returning false
because of course bro uh a is not bigger
than 30 it means 12 is of course not
bigger than 13 right that's where it is
returning false so now let's let's back
it up to 10 and let's try it again yeah
it is returning true because
10 is less than 12 and 12 is greater
than all right 12 is greater than 10
so same again let's try out a less than
b
all right
of course the the condition has to be
true all right means uh means this
condition is telling us the truth a
is
not less than b
a is not less than b that is false that
that's why the output is false how can
12 be
less than 10
it cannot be right so that's why it's
returning false now let's say if i
change the value of a to let's say five
okay uh sorry yeah let's change it to 5
and let's see the output
now it's returning true
because
it is returning to because
the value of a is of course less than b
because the value of a is 5 the value of
b is 10 and 5 is less than 10
so
that's how this you know this thing
works now let's say all right let's
give both the values you know equality
that is let's make a to 10 b to 10 right
now let's see it's returning us false
it is returning us false because
there isn't any option right because uh
see that that means for these type of no
for these type of values now
uh
less than equals and greater than equals
comes in
all right
so we are going to
see those uh operators now
so till now what we did till now we
learnt about
uh you know arithmetic operators all
right now we are going through
relational operators and in relational
operators we learned about equals equals
not equals greater than or less than now
uh here comes two more operators all
right here comes two more operators
less than equals greater than equals all
right now let's see first of all you
know let's again uh reset its value
let's ab12 and bb10 right now in here
it's very simple you just have to give a
greater than equals b now let's uh
try and run it here you can see
here you can see it is returning us true
there's no difference right you you
might be thinking oh god what am i
showing what am i showing it's just like
the you know
the previous one just like the previous
uh greater than equal sign sorry greater
than sign
no there's a difference you just have to
wait so here you can see it's returning
true yes of course it will return to
because 12 is greater than 10 now
let's let's make it to
10 all right let's make it up to 10
let's see
oh my god it's again returning false why
that's because he has an equals to sign
it the condition is telling all right
if
the number
is greater than
equals to some other number then only
return true
and if the condition means if that
condition is not matching then return
false now let's let's try giving 9
now let's see
say it is giving us false
right now let's again let's try less
than equals
it's returning as true because you know
9 is less than 10
now again let's give you know
10 to a let's see
again it is returning as 2 because 10 is
equals to 10 right now let's give 12 to
a
let's see
it is a returning false alright because
then the condition is not matching now
condition is not matching it is 12 is
nor less than nor equals to you know
what
nor less than nor equals to
so that's how this whole relational
operators works
i hope the concept behind the relational
operators is clear
all right
now
as we are very clear around
relational operators let's understand
the concept of logical
all right
see
logical operators uh you know they are
very simple to understand
all right very simple
some people like exaggerate it i've seen
like some people uh exaggerated uh
exaggerated it but currently in the
beginning stage and operator and you
know these or operators are very simple
very simple to understand
now
logical operators
what are they all right
these type of operators now all right
is used to you know
um what can i say i'm not getting the
right word
these two operations have put put some
condition between
uh like you know another two condition
all right
i know it might get a bit confusing i
will show you how to you know uh how
this works right but for now understand
all right it performs logical
calculations all right
understand it like this it performs
logical calculation
now you can see
two ands all right that is two ampersand
signs
all right what this means we call it as
an and operator
what this means is
in this example here you can see there
are two condition that is a equals
equals two
and another condition is
b equals equals four
all right if both the conditions
are returning true all right if both
that is a equals equals
2 is true and b equals equals 4 is true
then only it will return true let's say
any of the condition
in here let's say let's for example
let's say b equals equals force is false
but a equals equals 2 is true all right
for example then it will return false
that's how the and operators works all
right so as we have understood the and
operator let's you know let's uh
try to code it
right let's see
how this thing works
so first of all i wanted to remove this
whole
code all right
now again right in here
logical operator
all right cool
now here assign two values represent
equals you know
10 and
b sorry
enter
b equals again you know
let's say 12
all right and now you know go to uh
console.writeline
and in here
in here what you have to do is
first of all
first write one condition that is
a
equals equals
10 all right we are comparing the value
of a
to another value 10 all right now here
comes the and operator now let's again
do the same thing for b that is b equals
equals to s
now let's try
and run it
it is returning us true because
both in here both
the conditions are true now let's let's
change one value that is let's change
the value of b to 11 let's see
so it is returning false so here the
concept of for you know and operator is
very clear that two or two
means to get the and operator return
true we have to make sure that both the
conditions
all right both the conditions which are
uh you know using the and operator
should be true
all right so that's what the purpose of
and operator is
now another operator is
or operator
all right it's like if this doesn't
works then we will work with these
all right
so basically what it means is
let's say there are two values a equals
equals to b equals equals to all right
that is uh in our case alright in here b
equals 4 right
that means in here
b all right for b it is false the
condition b is false because of course b
is not equals to 4 all right
means b is 4 of course sorry
i just you know
uh confused you i i think so
let's understand it this way see b is b
right in here is 4
and we are comparing b with another
value 2 right and of course 2 is not
equal to 4 all right it is not so for
this particular condition it will be
false now for this all right that is a
equals equals 2
in here the value of a is 2 and 2 equals
equals to that is
this but for this condition it will
return true so as one condition is true
it is going to return us true
all right
so
let me show you
so here you can see i already have it
assigned that as a equals equals 10 that
is 10 equals equals 10 it will be 2 and
b equals b equals equals 11 but in our
case b is 12 and
in we are comparing it with 11 let's see
it is returning us true all right now
let's do this the other way around let's
change it to 10 and let's um
you know
let's change the b to 12. again it is
returning us true because you know one
of the condition is continuously
matching now let's say change you know
change uh both the
let's make both the condition and false
and let's see
here you can see
it is getting us it is giving us false
right so that's how this thing works
that's how odd operator works
now this not operator now it's totally
different
all right now
let me show you not operator knight will
uh it will you know reverse or you can
say inverse alright invert the result
all right it will invert the results now
for example
let's give a equals equals you know or
10 all right
the output for this will be
true
right the output for this will be true
now if we all right
patch this particular uh condition
means wrap this condition with the
you know round brackets
and put you know and put
what is this called exclamation mark or
you know not all right
not operator in front of that uh
condition and then run it
here you can see that it is
although the condition is true it is uh
returning us false why because this this
particular not operator now it is uh
inverting the result now if if it is you
know if it is resulting to you know
false
it will return us true
all right so that's
how this not operator works all right so
till now we have uh we have learnt about
uh
arithmetic operator relational operator
and logical operator now here comes the
last one that we are going to learn all
right
this one is
assignment operator all right
see assignment operators are you know
going to be very useful to us
all right they are really going to be
very useful to us and
you got to be like you know very
uh like you need to understand how these
things work all right uh understand it
carefully because sometimes not because
of these operations that might like
especially in this case this uh
these uh three for uh for case of these
three it uh gets a bit confusing all
right so don't worry i'm going to you
know
understand uh make you understand this
concept brick by brick all right
so
let's remove this all right let's remove
this again comment it
and uh
let's give it a name that is assignment
all right assignment
operator
all right very cool very great now
create a variable
and a equals you know let's uh let's
give it five all right
now here we used our very first operator
which one
equals operator all right
how see equals is an assignment operator
it's in its team only see equals is
assigning a value to a all right equals
is assigning a value to a
that's how it is working
right
so equals is an assignment operator we
learned about our very first operator
right it's not very first but
learnt about our first operator in
assignment operator category
all right
now
next operator is plus equals all right
see
i hope you remember we learned about uh
increment and decrement operator
uh plus plus equals operators also does
the same thing all right but it you know
it is more modifiable
all right it is more modifiable it also
increments the value all right it also
increments the value but
we can determine how much value to
increment all right like in the previous
one we are giving you know uh a plus
plus and it was only incrementing the
value all right it was only incrementing
the value by one we weren't able to you
know change it
means if we wan
how to do like if we use this we won't
be able to increment the value with
two all right it will only be
incremented with one all right but with
the plus equals operator
what we can do is a a plus equals two
all right and now let's
let's print it
a
let's see
it is 7 because 5 plus 2 equals
right now
you know there's a more abbreviated it's
not abbreviated there's a more expanded
version of it all right let me show you
a plus equals 1 all right a plus equals
one okay so plus equals two all right it
also has a
uh you know big version that is
a equals a plus two
all right so basically this this would
help you to understand how exactly it is
working alright how this operator is
working so pay attention carefully
what is happening
first of all it is performing the
addition of a that is
5 plus 2 then it is assigning the
addition to a
to the variable a all right it is
performing the addition on e then it is
assigning
that addition
to the variable a
that's how it is working
all right
so that's how
this
plus equals operator works
all right now
the next in our you know the
so first uh first let's understand what
we learned we learned about uh
assignment that's equals operator now uh
we learnt about plus equals operator all
right now here comes minus equals
operator this is the decrementing
operator but
is modifiable all right that is
a minus equals 2
let's try it out
see 5 minus 2
3 all right now you know let's uh let's
expand it that is a equals a minus 2
again it's the do it's doing the same
thing right just it is more expanded
version what is doing it is first
performing the calculation that is it is
first
you know decrement means decrementing
the value by 2 then it is assigning it
all right so that's how it is working
now
uh we learned about
the three operators that is
assignment
plus equals
all right that is equals plus equals and
minus equals now here comes
multiply equals now
with the first chapter operators uh your
i guess your concept might be clear but
let's say if it isn't clear i will
show it to you all right
the syntax is something like this a
asterisk equals 2
all right so what will happen it will
multiply 5 by 2 5 with 2 sorry
let's try it out
see it is multiplying it now if we if we
look into the underlying all right
means uh the underlying logic it will be
like this a equals a into 2 all right
and you know 5 into 2 is 10
and then it is assigning it so that's
the underlying logic behind it
all right
now
as we understood
this also there's another one that is
divide equals a divide equals
2 so basically it will divide 5
with 2 now of course i don't want to
divide 5 by 2 so i'm going to change the
value to 4 all right let's see for the
simplicity here you can see 2 4 divided
by 2 is 2 all right now let's you know
let's simplify it a equals a divided by
2.
it's doing the same thing right
first it is
dividing then it is assigning
as simple as that
all right that's how this thing works
now again
the last one remains that is modulo
equals
let's see
it it is returning 0 because of course
there's no you know it's a complete
division if you divide 4 by 2 right now
let let's try it out with 5 now let's
see
is returning also because one because it
is it is not performing a complete
division right so
that's how this you know this whole
thing works
all right
so uh let me show you the abbreviated
version of it also a equals a modulo 2
all right now you know let's uh let's
remove this particular line and let's
see if
our you know our
idea works or not see it is working
right now let's change this value of a
to 4 now let's see
so here you can clearly see
all right here you can clearly see
we are
able to do all the
actions all right in the assignment
operator and i hope it is clear how
everything under you know under the hood
is working
right
so
let's get to our next topic
all right
and that is bitwise operators i'm just
going to tell you the over like overall
idea behind
so you know let's see see
bitwise operator works on uh bits and
perform bit by bit operation all right
now in here bit is binary all right so
uh before rc
the thing is you have to understand
binary operations all right you have to
understand binary hexadecimal uh octal
operations before getting into bitwise
operators all right because bitwise
operators works on binary level all
right and that's why bit by bit wise
operators are fast
alright so
remember that
remember this thing and uh i would like
see i would like you guys all right
after you are completed with the c topic
i would really like you guys to do your
research and learn about all right do
your research
and
learn about bitwise operators more
because it is one
hell of an interesting topic
all right so do that now here comes
another topic operator precedence
all right see operator precedence is you
know a very interesting topic
it's like the bodmas rule in maths
all right
it's like the body mass rule it maps
what bodmas rule tells us all right
first of all it is in bodmal's rule the
associativity or you know the importance
all right
the importance
is
from
left to right all right the importance
of operators like in in the body mass
rule the importance of all those
operators start from left to right all
right bracket of you know division
subtraction multiplication uh
sorry bracket you know bracket of
division multiplication addition
subtraction
right so that's how it is means bracket
has the very high importance and
subtraction has very low importance all
right and
you know as bracket all right as bracket
has
very high importance
uh the you know the calculations inside
a bracket is performed
first
then other calculations are performed so
these all right
you know
these all right these
this is the whole concept of
operator precedence so i would like you
to go through this chart all right it's
very important to have an understanding
of this chart
it's just that it is telling us
all right about the precedence of
operator all right that is how important
an operator is
and uh
how much important is it from
its next operator so it is telling us
that all right and i want you guys to
you know have an understanding of this
all right so that's it for this lecture
and i hope
uh you guys are liking this whole series
so
make sure to press the subscribe button
and
more lectures are coming all right
thank you
in this lecture we are going to uh learn
about conditional statements all right
conditional statements in shisha
uh the reason why we are learning is we
we need to know how we you know uh drive
our program all right means we how we
drive our program to a certain direction
all right and how do we uh drive a
program to a certain direction it's by
applying conditions
all right it's uh you know it's just
like that like when you know uh i guess
you guys remember when
parents uh used us to know uh
tell us that uh we will buy you a thing
if you bring 90 percent uh
90 marks in uh your exams like it's like
that it used to know uh drive us to
study harder to get that thing so that's
how conditional works all right we give
some condition all right and uh it works
upon that condition
that's what conditional are all right
basically conditional uh statements now
they help us to execute all right it
helps us to execute some sort of
programs all right some programs uh with
respect to the conditions assigned to it
all right now if the condition is true
all right if the condition is true
then
you know uh
a particular statement will get executed
and if the condition is false it won't
get executed all right so that's what
conditional is all right so
now
uh first of all uh just let me rename
this editor to you know uh conditionals
um conditionals
all right
so
yeah
see
there are uh you know there are three or
you can say four uh conditional
statements out there now let me list
them down all right
the very first one is
if
else all right or you can see if and
else
the next one is if
else if
and else
all right
the third one
is
inline
if we are going to learn about that
don't worry
uh and the fourth one
is switch statements
alright or you can say uh
switch
case
all right
statements
so
ah there these are the four types of
conditionals we have all right so now as
we are clear with the like what
conditionals are
right
we should you know get going with our
very first
you know our uh
very first statement uh that is if and
else statements all right
see
these if statements now it helps us you
know it helps us to execute some
condition already to use
it helps us to uh execute some statement
under some condition all right it's like
that it's it's like you know uh let's
say for an example um it's raining
outside all right for an example uh it's
raining outside or uh
let's say uh how can i you know
represent it um
yeah let's say it is it is raining
outside all right and uh
you you want to take an umbrella why you
want to take an um see the very first
thing you are going out all right you
see while going out you see that there
rain is falling right
and
you are very sure
as it is raining you want to take a
condition sorry you want to take an
umbrella with you right
because uh
it is raining and if you you know uh get
wet in uh
due to the rain uh it will you know uh
it will give you fever all right you
won't be well
all right so you want to prevent it all
right and because of that you are
getting an umbrella so that you don't
get wet
right
so in here can you all right can you
guess
what is the condition
in here all right in this case
the condition is
rain
all right
how let me tell you see as it is raining
you are taking the umbrella what if it
didn't rain
you won't be taking and taking an
umbrella all right because of course
dude it is not raining why would we need
an umbrella we can walk freely
right
so the condition in here
is rain and the statements that are
being executed is
will uh
is that the person will
take
uh umbrella or he will not take daila
all right so that's how it is working
now to uh you know to implement all
right
the uh let me show or tell you about the
syntax how we you know represent uh the
syntax of ethernet i would uh like i
would uh implement the example i told
you all right i will do that right now
just give give me a few seconds first
let me make you uh you know go through
with the condition the first thing is uh
we have to give a you know
first thing is we have to write if all
right and within that if
a condition goes all right a condition
will go on
and after that
all right within the f block
some sort of you know statement will be
there statement in the sense some sort
of program you have written or some sort
of you know uh command you have written
that would go on all right and let's say
if the condition alright if the
condition is you know if the condition
is not satisfying or the condition is
wrong then another set of already
another set of statement will
work on
right
so if the condition is not true then
means if this particular kind uh
statement condition is not true then
this else block will execute now to
understand it very you know uh very
carefully let's code it first of all
create a bool variable that is is
raining and you know set it to false as
of now or let's say set it to you know
true all right that would be better now
if is raining
equals equals true
what i want to do is i want to print
i want to
print
that
take your umbrella
right
let's see if it is working or not
yeah it is working as it is raining all
right as it is raining
that's why we are taking our umbrella
let's say what will uh what will be the
outcome if we you know uh say false
see it is telling us that your program
did not output anything what does it
mean
it means that this if condition
uh like you know here our condition is
only that if it is raining alright if is
raining equal is true then only execute
this particular block of code all right
or else
means we haven't specified let's if if
this is raining equals equals to
condition doesn't execute all right
let's say if it returns false then what
all right
then
another block of code will uh you know
show its you know uh what can i say show
it's magic that is else block all right
and what else block does is if any of
the condition becomes false all right
if any of the uh you know previous
condition becomes false it will go to
the else block all right
and in the else block we can write
okay just
all right in the else block we can write
don't
take your
umbrella
right so
now let's see as israel as it is not
raining that is raining full fall so
what is happening
our code is telling don't take your
umbrella all right
so that's how if an else statement works
it it helps us to drive a program to
certain directions all right so it's
like that it's it's just like the
example i give you like the reigning
example and you know the parents are uh
like you know uh
the parents uh
giving us some you know some sort of
gift like promising us to give some gift
and uh
they are telling uh they will only give
the gift uh if we bring 90 marks in our
exam so it it's something
it is totally like that all right it's
it's how we drive our code all right
it's how we actually you know drive our
code
that's how this whole thing works
all right
so that is
what it is
now
our next all right as this one is done
right this one let's mark it down
if an else is done we are clear with if
an else statement now
the next one
all right the next one for us is
if elsif
and
else statement
right
now
see it is also similar all right it is
also similar to um if an l statement
just
here comes another block that is else if
elsif is also like you know if statement
but let's say if statement doesn't
executes it will go to the else if
statement and if else if statement also
doesn't execute
then it will go to the else statement
all right
if the these kind of statements comes in
real like
comes really handy when whenever we are
writing let's say uh solving some
problem or uh let's say making our own
ar application where we have to put some
conditions right so this kind of
statement comes really handy all right
and they are used more oftenly
all right they are used oftenly
so make sure you understand it all right
the syntax is uh you know very similar
to the
uh previous one you'd uh like
just in between uh
if and else block all right you have to
uh write another block all right that is
elsif and in here
a condition goes on all right
and uh within that uh condition we have
to write and you know block and it would
contain a statement all right it's uh
it's like that now let's let's say uh
let's take an example of voter voting
age all right let's implement it let's
uh take age let's uh currently my age is
17 all right
as of now my age is 17.
now for the very first condition i'm
going to give is
all right the very first condition i'm
if
sorry if
age
no is greater than equals 18
then only all right
then only
i am eligible to vote in india right
then only i am eligible to vote
let's say
what if
all right else if
our age is less than 18
all right let's give another condition
all right
if
our age
is less than
and all right
and
age
greater than right greater than zero of
course uh a child all right who who like
who's not even born he won't be able to
you know uh vote of course that's you
know that's ridiculous right so console
dot uh
write line
and give
not
eligible
to vote
all right
so yeah and in the else block
we give console
dot
write line
if
invalid edge
all right
invalid
age
now what does this means all right let's
first give it you know let's give the
age 19 all right let's see which one
will get executed
see
the first condition is being executed
that means the if block is being
executed why because e of course
of course uh uh the age the age we
specified is greater than
all right greater than equals
18 it is greater than 18
right that's why we're eligible to vote
now let's let's try out 17
right
we are not eligible to vote
of course because you see i am not 18
in india the minimum voting age is 18
and i am not 18 so how how will i vote
if i am not 18
so
17 is
like
if you are 17 you can't vote right now
let's try out you know four let's let's
see if a four year old can
vote or not no the
four-year-old cannot uh can't vote now
let's see if a zero all right if a zero
your old
kid can vote or not
invalid age
all alright because 0 is not an age
right so
here is the thing
if else if and else that's how we use it
all right
that's how we use it and you you you are
going to use more often when you will
start coding your own ar or ar
applications or games right or even uh
like when you will uh you do go in
competitive programming or solve
problems you are going to use these
statements oftenly all right so that's
how
you you know we use these statements
all right so i hope uh you know the
concept
the concept of you know this is clear
now we are going to you know do a bit of
problem solving in here all right
so
for us uh there's a question
all right for us there's a question let
me write it down here first first of all
let me remove all this you know
uh this statement now let me
you know write this question in here
all right
write a program to take
certain
numbers
and if
the numbers
are
if the number
is divisible
just to it if the number is divisible
by 2
then we have to print
divisible
by
and if
it is divisible
by you know 3
then we have to print
divisible
by 3
all right
else all right or else if none of the
condition matches right then we have to
print
not
divisible
by two or three all right so this is a
very simple program all right you
learned about operators all right
you know how to perform you know uh
uh how to perform remainder operation
right now let's understand the logic
first all right
to check all right if the program
is fully divisible all right see to
unders understand this if a program uh
to to know if a
number if a number is fully divided
we have to make sure that the remainder
is zero if the remainder is zero then
only all right then only
we say that
that particular division is you know is
valid or it means it is fully divided
that's when we call like like for
example uh 4 divided by 2 in this case
the remainder all right in this case
the remainder is 0
right but let's say again let's take an
example five uh
let's divide five divided by two
in this case there will be one as a
remainder and we can't call it divisible
by five so divisible by two
right so make sure that uh
keep this in mind all right keep this in
mind
any pro any number that is you know that
whose remainder is coming zero off like
is coming zero after the division
it is divided that by specific number
all right so make sure you know that now
you already know which which one is the
division operator this one already this
amp or this
percentage operator or you can some
module operator all right and to perform
the division it's very simple let me
show you first of all take a value that
is end n
let's uh as of now let's give you know
let's give it 4 now if
n
percent is 2 alright that is we are
how this is working we are taking out
the remainder all right remainder by
dividing n
with 2 we are trying to take out the
remainder then we are checking all right
then we are checking if
the
resultant remainder is equals equals
0 or not if it is 0
then we are going to you know print
console.writeline
divisible
by 2. similarly
similarly
we are going to do the same thing with 3
that is n divided in modulo 3
equals equal 0
if that works that then it is divisible
divisible
by you know um
by 3 all right now if if none of the
condition works all right if none of the
condition works then i want to print out
not
divisible
by
you know by both
two and three
all right so now let's check this out
all right let's check this out and how
these things works see as 4 is div as
the remainder all right as the remainder
of 4 divided by 2 is 0 and it is
matching the condition
that's why it is returning divisible by
2. now let's try try out
all right
it is returning us divisible by 3 the
reason is 9 is divisible by 3 when we
divide 9 by 3 the remainder comes 0 and
as
the remainder remainder of the resultant
division is 0 and it is
equals equal 0
that's why it is returning divisible by
3 all right it's as simple as that now
you know now uh
let's uh let's give one
it is not divisible by 2 not divisible
by 3 all right
so that's why in this block it is
returning us not divisible by both 2 and
3. so i hope you understand how we
exactly use if and else you know if else
if an else statement
all right and i hope it is uh you know
uh clear
so
yeah let's uh you know uh we can
conclude all right we can conclude that
if else if an else statement is also
done
all right now here comes two other
statements all right very important all
right
means actually uh
see
you are going to use inline if if
you want to assign you know it doesn't
have
extra conditions in there like only one
single condition
means only one if
actually let's let's you know write the
program first all right let's understand
the program first then you will
understand what i am trying to say
all right
so
see
you can uh
you saw the you know the syntax of if
else statement it's a bit big right it's
a bit big
now inline if not is uh
uh
is basically now inline of a basically a
shorter version of effects all right
it's the shorter version
uh
of if and else and it is you know mostly
used uh you know it is mostly used or
you can say it is more convenient to use
when you assign assign some value to a
variable depending on you know some
condition all right it's so you it's
more convenient to use in there all
right rather than using it any uh or for
taking any input or something like that
all right so it's uh it's
uh it's very convenient to use those
statements while uh you know being in
the variable
so make sure you keep this in mind right
now if i talk about the syntax the
syntax is you know pretty
simpler all right
first of all
there's the condition all right
after that there's a question mark
all right then here's a value all right
and it will be assigned all right only
if the condition is true and then here
comes the colon all right
and
this value will be assigned if the
condition is false it's just like if an
else statement
right
let's say you know let's try it out
let's try it out let's create a string
variable alright let's say string
statement
and let's uh
give a condition that is 4 greater than
2 all right
now
let's give the equation mark and let's
write 4 is
greater than 2.
all right else
else
what we can do is 2
is greater than
let's say 1
or uh just uh give me a second just give
me let's you know let's uh
change this whole statement all right
change it will uh actually confuse you a
lot let's change this whole statement
uh let's say if 4 is greater than 2 then
you can say 4 is
assigned
all right else
you can write 2 is assigned
all right
let's make this simpler
so here you can see that what i'm i'm
trying to say right now
also let's print the statement to see if
everything is working right or not
all right now let's try it out
see it is telling us 4 is assigned
because
this condition is true and if this
condition is true then only the
first one first one statement will be
assigned if the condition is false then
the second one will be assigned let's
change this a greater than sign to you
know less than sign let's see
see as this condition is false
that's why it didn't assign the first
statement it uh
rather
than assigning the first statement it
assigned the second statement so that's
how it works all right
so it's just like if an else statement
all right just in you know
abbreviated form
so i hope you are clear with inline f
all right
this uh this statement is very simple to
understand
now let's mark it as done and here comes
our last one
that is
switch case statements
all right
see switch case now it's like you know
pressing some switch if you press a
switch up certain perform will um
a certain you know certain function will
uh performed will be performed and if
you press on the switch um
another set of functions will be
performed right it's something like that
all right now
you can uh
say all right
see
let me you know make it simpler for you
the uh i can say that you know the
switch statement is uh you know very
similar to an if statement all right
just that all right just that it does
not you know work with a range of values
all right it's simple as that it it's
just that it doesn't needs any uh range
of value it doesn't works with that
all right
it's it's
a switch case statement now it requires
you know um
a case all right it requires a case all
right which which you know is based on a
single value all right it will be based
on a single value and uh depending on
the value of the variable
all right it will be it will switch you
know uh it will turn
it will switch to some statement all
right
and the program will execute the correct
block all right i know what this
definition you know uh this this
wordings might get a bit confusing all
right i totally understand already when
if i was uh in in your place i would
also have got you know confused
now to remove our confusion all right to
remove our
confusion
let's code it all right let's
code it
first of all let's understand the syntax
so it's very important to for us to
understand the syntax okay
see
the very first thing all right that
comes to us
the very first thing that comes to us
is
which one
can you guess
switch
all right
in
inside that switch you know inside that
uh
switch statement we
pass a variable all right
you pass a variable that would work as
our choice all right
and then we start you know two uh curly
braces brackets
and then we write a statement that is no
case ah wait
case all right and in that we pass some
value
and
we give a colon all right and we say
that bro do something all right
do something and now see this choice now
this choice will work as this value now
if this choice all right if the value of
this choice is similar to this value
then this switch case statement will
work all right and then we you know uh
give another statement that is a break
statement all right i would tell you
what that uh what is that all right and
what happens if you don't put that in
there now here comes another case all
right that is yeah
let's give another value to all right
and uh let's again say bro do something
all right
do something
now again break
now after that
here comes default statement alright
default is basically
this default statement will occur
if all right this default statement will
occur
if none of the you know none of the
value works all right means none of the
case
works alright so this is
the basic syntax
right this is the basic syntax of switch
case now
there's no need you know there's no need
to get confused
all right there's no need to
uh
be confused let's you know let's
create a
a simple very simple grading system
right like uh let me make you understand
the logic in here basically what it will
do now it will tell us all right
we have to tell that
uh which grade we got all right and then
based on that grade it will tell us that
the grade is good or not all right if it
is good if it is bad it will tell us
that all right so
that is what we are going to code so the
first thing i want you to create a
variable all right that is
care
ch and
assign it like let's say first for now
let's assign it some you know value
eight
right now here what you have to do is
write the switch statement and here pass
the ch variable it will be work as our
choice variable that i uh told you about
right and in here
right case alright and in that case give
a single uh you know single colons and
write a all right
then if you want you can indent it then
you know console.
right line
what i have to do
as the grade is a
i'm going to save very good right very
good
because you know the grade is really
impressive
right
so now after that
after that
let's uh give another case that is case
b
now again write console.writeline
we'll just going to write good all right
b is also g grade b is also no bad
all right so as we have defined
two grades all right you can you can you
know
give more such grades in there all right
you can add c grade you can add d grade
all right you can get add e grade you
can add f grade all right but for now
for this example
uh this this one is enough
all right
so see
now
let's give default all right one thing
you would notice that i haven't uh you
know
uh gave the you know break statement all
right i would show you why
i'm actually wait let me write the break
statement first because
what will happen it will be more easy to
make you understand how how this break
statement is working let's give the
break to every you know every particular
step
or you can say case
all right now
let's uh
try and run it
see as uh the you know as a grade is a
it is retaining us very good now try
with b
it is telling us good now let's try with
c
it is telling us default why default
because uh
we haven't defined all right kc we
haven't defined case c
that's why it is uh going to the default
block
all right it's also you know very
similar to if an else statement there's
just a you know bit of difference now
let's try and remove this break
statements from there all right let me
show you
what is it exactly doing
now let's let's start with a grade
so here you can see
it is giving us
all right
it is giving us some error or it cannot
fall through from one case label case a
to another all right in general all
right in c sharp it is giving us error
in java if you would code in java or any
other language you will find that uh
they are not skipping
like uh
after they are as i've stated uh a
they printed the case a then without the
break statement they are going to case b
and without the
break statement in case b they are going
to default so
that's why we use break statement in
here of course in shop it's giving error
but in java
all right in java if you don't give
break statement it will print like
every other statement in there all right
so that's why i hope you understood the
reason why we give break statements
right so
yeah so make sure all right so make sure
you understand alright you understand
this concept uh very carefully all right
because this concept is you know going
to be
very very very very useful all right and
always remember this break statement now
it it
it is a jump statement alright statement
is a jump statement it basically breaks
the execution of after some condition is
met all right you can understand that it
like that all right
so
break statement is just
breaks the work work like breaks the
working of the statement right so this
is it for uh this lecture all right see
you in the next lecture thank you have a
good day
guys welcome to this lecture and in this
lecture we are going to learn about
loops all right uh see
this is a very important concept already
because we are going to uh use
loops a lot all right we are going to
use a loop or like loops a lot because
whenever you will be developing
something all right you uh you won't be
like uh like if you don't want to do
everything manually right you can loop
through it all right for example if you
are um
what can i say let's say uh if you are
let's say you uh like created an array
all right you create an array i know you
you might
you you don't know the meaning of array
as of now all right but that's totally
okay i would uh like in in the next
lecture only we are going to discuss
arrays all right and for arrays we are
going to uh
need
loops all right we have to understand
the loops to like work with arrays right
so
see we can use loops in multiple ways
like for example
uh let's say uh we want to apply some
materials all right
so i i'm taking an example all right in
terms of
er like the application we are going to
make during uh
like after we learn euphoria right so
the basic all right the basic
understanding of
the basic concept of looping is to loop
through something all right look through
something
loop uh see
the formal definition all right for loop
would be loops are basically a way to
you know iterate over something for
finite or infinite number of times all
right
so
let's say for an example
all right
do you remember uh i'm not sure if this
happened with you uh but this happened
with me a long time back i was in like
you know in class fifth and at that
point of time uh i was in uh like i i
learned my first programming language
all right that was q basic all right in
class fifth i learned my first
programming language and uh
you know uh i got punishment at that
time i was like uh like you know
very
you know what can i say a very naughty
kid i used to like you know disturb my
friends and because of that uh what i
got it was uh they the teacher punished
me told me that you have to write
something i exactly don't remember i
think it was i'm sorry you have to write
i am sorry a hundred times all right and
uh you know
at that point of time uh
i knew how to use for loops right i i
understood the concept of follow-up i
understood uh how to use it so then it
came to my thought let's why not see the
teacher is you know teacher is trying to
tell us that
you know
uh you have to write i am sorry a
hundred times
right
and you know teacher just wants it a
hundred times she didn't told me how to
write like i have to write it manually
or i can you know use some dynamic way
like you using a for loop tighter to
iterate over 400 times and
print right uh print i'm sorry right so
what i did is all right what i did
i basically
i uh use the technique of for loop all
right to you know iterate hundred times
i use the technique of follow titrate
hundred times and print
uh i'm sorry a hundred times all right
it like it uh completed in four to five
lines and uh after i shown it to the
teacher the teacher you know scolded me
a lot all right and then
gave me uh then told me that you have to
write
i'm sorry 200 times uh
for you know manually
and
after that i never tried tried this with
any teacher all right after that
actually i never got punishment from
class six so it never happened so uh in
class fifth this incident was you know
was a very funny incident for me because
that was the first time i actually used
for loop to save myself from you know
writing the whole thing so that's the
concept of loops all right
loop actually helps us to you know
reduce
all most of the work right like for
example
uh right now i can give you all right
hey brother uh write you know hello
world a hundred times all right so you
right now you don't know the concept of
loops but you are a very obedient
student uh and you will start writing
like a console
dot uh
right line all right
hello world right you will be writing
that uh
a hundred times
right you'd be writing that
a hundred times all right and that
that's going to take a lot of time right
that's going to take a lot of time so
what we can do is we can use you know a
loop all right we you we can use a loop
to actually do it for us a hundred times
all right so that
it uh the computer will only perform the
you know the function we don't have to
do anything currently we are doing it
manually but with the with the loop we
can
like
make our computer do the you know write
the hello world all right so i will show
you how to do that but before that let's
understand what a loop so loops
basically are a way to iterate over
something for finite or infinite amount
of time all right
so
you know
first uh let's understand how many types
of loops are there all right
see there are um three types of lopez
all right that is let's first write it
down in here all right the first type
all right the very common used is for
loop
all right then another one is while loop
and the third one is very least used all
right
actually i
really don't use this loop anymore like
i don't need it all right but
you have to
you have to have an idea about do while
loop right
so me that's why i'm teaching it right
now although i don't think you will also
be using do while loop in your career
yet uh but uh i i never use like you
know whenever developing
applications i never use do i loop it it
never came handy to me whereas i used
for loop and while loop a lot right so
that's why uh i'm going to teach you all
the three loops today all right and
we're going to start with uh fall all
right see remember
the concept of looping is sim simple all
right concept of looping is simple it
just tells that we are you know uh
repeating ourselves all right looping
means repeating all right we or looping
totally means repeating ourselves over
something right so that's the concept of
looping
but there are three different ways
to loop all right that is one is for
loop another one is while loop another
one is do value all right and i would
tell you all right when to use for loop
and when to use while loop all right
so
make sure to you know listen to this
lecture carefully
so first of all let's understand the
syntax of follow the syntax of for loop
is very simple all right so the first is
we have to write 4 all right inside the
4 we have to give
brackets and
the first all right the first would be
you know first statement we have to
write is start
then
we have to give a semicolon then we have
to give a condition all right
condition that for uh how many steps we
want to run means for for how many times
we want to run right
now the next would be alright the last
one would be steps all right that is how
many steps we want to take steps means
how many you know let's say if we give
step as 2 then let's say we are trying
to uh print
numbers from 1 to 10 right so let's say
if we give step as 2 then it would only
uh like you know if we start from 0 then
0 plus 2 let's say it would give us 2
then 4 then some like it would give us
like this all right then inside that
would be printing uh like it would we
would be instructing the program to do
something all right so this is
basically the syntax of follow
all right now
i told you you know my story of how i
was punished right now let's try to
implement that punish like
let's try to implement that all right
so for
you have to declare a variable right so
i'm going to declare a variable within
the for loop only so for i
equals
0 yeah it's uh and remember that i'm
starting the value of i from 0 all right
then i want to go till i
less than equals 100 i want to go
till 100 then
i have to give how many steps i want to
increment all right how many steps i
want to go with
so
i plus plus
means
1 all right
every step will be incremented by one
now if we if we want to you know uh
let's say if we want to increment every
step by two what we can do is plus sorry
plus equals two all right but for now
plus plus is totally fine with us so now
what you can write console
dot
right line
hello world all right so teacher told us
that
student
write hello world instead of i'm sorry
all right so now let's see if uh
it is printed hundred times or not all
right so
you know there's not really a way to you
know we are not able to count it right
so let's uh give a plus sign and you
know
add the i in here let's see now yeah so
here you can see that it's starting from
zero and uh it is going from hundred
going up to hundred now here you can see
as it is starting from zero the total
number will be 101 all right because if
one is starting from here then zero is
another extra one so it will be 101
times all right so to fix that we can
actually start the loop from one
or what we can do is we can you know
mark it uh like give the condition as
i less than 0 then what will happen it
would start from 0 and
end up to 99 so it would be total 100 it
will be total 100 times we looped all
right so that's how we you know work
with for loops
so for loop is a way to loop through all
right some sort of you know
some sort of condition now always
remember we use all right we use for
loop
all right we use for loop when we know
exactly how many
uh how many iterations do we want like
right so for in this example
we knew all right in this example we
knew that we are going to need 100 all
right we are going to need 100
iterations so that's what we did we
uh go we did 100 iterations in the
program to print hello world so that's
when we use follow all right so now as
we have understood the concept of for
loop
let's you know let's try uh writing some
programs let's try solving some problem
program right i want you you guys to try
it first all right so pause the you know
pause this particular video after i give
you the question and try it by yourself
then uh
come to this video and see the solution
all right so i'm writing a comment in
here let's uh
write a program to print
table of a number
using
for loops all right so what you have to
do is you have to code a solution all
right which will be able to print table
tab
uh
all right it will be able to print
table of that number all right
so make sure you do that and uh right
now pause the video and try it by
yourself it's okay if you are not able
to do it all right it just needs some
more practice
after uh practicing you will be very
familiar with the concept of following
all right so
let's try it out now
all right so for i'm going to implement
it so for
c
first of all uh the very first thing i
want you to do is to declare a variable
all right that is in
n alright this would be the number all
right that is i want to create a table
of two all right so now what i want
is
for
int i
because i want to start from 0 all right
and i want to
end up till
12 all right
and i plus plus
why because we aren't skipping any step
we are just incrementing by one all
right we are just we just want one step
each
all right
now
create another variable all right that
is int
let's uh you know let's name it f
all right and uh
what you have to do is
multiply all right this value of n all
right
with i
see remember how this is working
first of all in the first iteration
the first iteration
two is multiplied by zero
and the outcome is zero in the second
iteration all right how it is reaching
to the second iteration which is
reaching to the second iteration by
incrementing this i by 1 all right so
now in the second iteration i will be 1
all right i will be 1 and 2 will be
multiplied by
1 and in the again in the third
iteration it will be incremented and it
will be go to 2 all right then again 2
will be multiplied by 2. so it will be
working like this all right so i hope
you understand how
how this program will be working all
right then console
dot
write line
and
print
the value all right and also make sure
you know
write it like this
so
just wait in
let n plus
given asterisk in here all right
and uh
plus i
it's it's just a you know i'm just
maintaining a decrement here all right
it means i'm just actually let's leave
this thing all right we will try this
one later on
first of all let me show you if it is
printing the table of two or not yeah it
is
of course printing so two zeroes are
zero two ones are two two two the four
two three the six two fours the eight
two fives are ten two six are twelve and
so on it is going up to two twelve twos
at twenty four right
so we have successfully printed the
table of two now let's uh you know print
the table of 12 let's see if it is able
to do it or not see 12 ones are 12 12 to
the 24 12 36 and it is going up to 12 12
144 so
that's how it is working all right
that's how our for loop is working first
it is remember it is iterating
till the condition is met all right and
for us the condition is 12. we exactly
know how many times we want to iterate
we know that we want to alter it 12 10
that's how we set uh that's how we
actually set up you know the condition
so that it iterates up to 12
all right
now
for each iteration it is incrementing
the value of i that is
in the first iteration the value of i is
0 and you know 12 is multiplied by 0 and
it is printed and in the second
iteration when it goes to the second
iteration the value of i is incremented
all right the value of i is incremented
and this 0 is changed
uh to 1 all right so and then uh again
in that iteration
12 into 1 equals 12 right so that's how
this whole thing is working all right
so i hope you understand how this worked
right
now i hope you know
follow this uh the concept of follow-up
is cleared because right now i'm going
going to go to a while loop
so make sure if you are not uh you know
not clear with the concept of for loop
make sure you uh
practice it a little bit all right watch
the
portion of for loop
all right the one i taught right now so
watch that again practice for loop
wallet then only go to while loop all
right
so make sure you do that
so now let's uh you know remove this
whole uh syntax thing and
let's mark for loop as
done all right now here we uh go to the
follow
all right
so
what is follow why look sorry what is y
loop yeah
see you can say while loop is a brother
all right
brother of for loop alright it is also
used for looping all right
but
the thing is
all right
while loop all right while loop
runs all right
while loop runs
till
the condition is false
all right it will run till the condition
is false
and this proves
one of our concept that for loop is only
used well the for loop is only used
when all that for loop is only used
if we don't know how many iterations we
want all right
that's when follow is used
all right as simple as
that
all right so now let's uh you know learn
about the syntax
so let me comment this out all right so
there's the basic syntax
we have to you know first uh declare uh
a variable all right it's better to
declare a variable at first then you
know uh write the while all right and in
here the condition will go on all right
actually this you know this variable is
not a part of
uh the syntax but i'm showing you
because you would be needing it all
right then curly braces and inside that
you have to you know alright do
something
all right
so that's that is what the syntax of
fault while loop is all right now you
know uh i told you about the whole hello
world example let's you know try to
implement it so first of all i want you
to declare a variable all right
in time
equals you know zero it should start
from zero all right and give it a
condition while
all right
while i is less than equals hundred all
right i is less than equals hundred
i want to print hello world
all right i want to print
hello world
now one more thing all right in for loop
remember how we were incrementing the
value right do you remember that how we
were incrementing the value by i plus
plus
similarly in here also we have to do
something and we have to do that after
all our statement is done all right that
is for now our only statement is
sponsored our heart right line and
at the end we are going to write i plus
plus
all right
now i will i will let you know what will
happen if you don't give i plus plus but
for now all right for now let's see
what happens if we give it all right
let's see
uh the basic example
see
it is you know printing hello world
till 100 all right it is printing hello
world till 100
and it is stopping when the condition is
becoming false all right
it is stopping like uh say uh like see
when it reached 100 when it reached 100
after when it was go it was going to 101
as the condition is not meeting as 101
is greater than 100
it stopped looping all right so that's
how it is working so let's understand
first of all we declared a variable
declared a basic uh you know a basic
variable
all right we declared a variable i
then we created a while loop
in the while loop there's a condition
i less than equals hundred now this
condition
will be
like
what can i say
this condition is responsible all right
for executing this particular line
console.writeline
all right and then
we are going i plus plus that is
incrementing the value of i by 1 all
right
that's what we are doing
let's say if we
you know let's say if we uh
remove this i plus plus let's see what
will happen
see it uh you know this uh
particular website now sort of crashed
for for a moment like it you know it uh
not exactly crash but you know uh
what can i say to freeze or it freeze
for a moment
all right and here you can see the val
you can't everything in here is zero all
right everything in here is zero and at
the end has a error that
range error
all right range error max buffer length
exceeded that's because only that's
because
we ran into an infinite loop
all right
means it it is a never-ending loop it
won't end ever all right that's why
uh that's because we didn't give i plus
plus the reason is what role is i plus
plus playing is it is incrementing the
value of i all right like
for the first order for the first
iteration
it perform this particular thing then we
are incrementing to one all right so
then y is the second i uh means then one
all right then one is the second
iteration in the second iteration means
the second iteration completed we
incremented the value of i now one has
gone to two so like this all right like
this
we are uh working on the for loop all
right
so if you don't give the i plus plus
then what will happen
if we don't give the i plus plus then it
will run into a
infinite loop all right and
of course we don't want that so that's
how a while loop works all right so
i hope you are clear with the concept of
while loop
all right and also one more thing we can
you know we can write this i plus plus
2i plus equals 1 i plus equals to let's
try it out with i plus equals 2 also
let's see what happens so you can see
that
it is iterating even number of times
like it is iterating half the number of
times 100
so that's how it is working all right so
that's how we you know code uh you know
for loop
all right now
uh let's all right
remember the uh program which i i taught
you like to print out a table of
a certain number right we are going to
do the same thing with with while loop
all right so the very first thing i want
you to understand is
write a variable all right n the that
would be containing the number then
right all right
write a variable i it would be the
counter counter variable means uh the i
that we had taught you all right it
would be incrementing the value after
each successful statement right so
now go to
while
i all right just wait
i
all right is
less than equals 12 all
right what i want
i want is
to
multiply
all right multiply
multiply the number
n
with i all right then after that i want
to print it
all right i want to print it
console.writeline
i want to print it then after printing
it i want i am going to increment the
value
all right i'm going to increment the
value by one
so now let's see
cool
so we got the same output that we got
for for loop right so that's how the it
is working all right so i hope
uh you are very clear with the concept
of for loop and while loop all right
so are you all i guess you also know how
when when to use
which right so we use for loop when we
exactly know how many iterations we want
and we use
for sorry
derive sorry sorry i guess i messed it
up so again we use for loop when we know
how many iterations we want we use while
loop when we don't know all right when
we exactly don't know how many
iterations we want so that's when we use
for loop all right and a for loop
statement stops working when the
condition
know when the condition gets to false
all right so always remember that
now here comes our last looping
statement all right
and uh the least
used ones
all right
this is
known as do while loop all right it's a
see do while loop now is uh you know
very similar all right it is very
similar to uh
what can i say a while loop all right it
is very similar to why look just there's
a one difference all right
in while loop
if the condition is false from the
starting point now it won't even execute
a single statement
but in do while loop even if the
condition is false all right it will all
right even if the condition is false
it will execute once
all right it will at least execute once
all right so let me first uh make you
familiar with the concept of do value
means the syntax of develop actually so
i hope you are familiar with the concept
of you know do while loop
so do
first of all you need to write do then
curly braces
all right
inside the curly braces you have to you
know
go for uh
writing the you know particular code you
want to give then you have to give a
while statement in here
then the condition in here to uh to be
executed all right
so that's what
the syntax is
it's a bit weird syntax right i know i
know so now what you have to do is
define i variable
[Music]
all right see we are going to uh you
know write the same example we did last
time that is the hello world one so
then
write do
write do all right then console
dot write line
hello world
then i'm going to increment the count or
it means increment the value of i i plus
by i plus plus or you can also do i plus
equals 1 all right then in the while all
right i'm going to give the condition
i less than equals no 100
and then semicolon
now let's try to run it
so here you can see
we actually
got
the hello world now to verify that if we
actually ran 100 times or not i'm going
to you know
add i to the
equation so now here you can see
it has ran 100 times
now
you know what i told you just uh a few
seconds ago that
even if the condition is fall from the
starting point do while loop will at
least execute once all right
so you know let's uh
let's verify it
all right
let's give
if the condition is greater than equals
100 all right if the value of i is
greater than equals hundred and of
course the condition is false so here
you can see here you can see
with being all right even though the
condition falls it at least executed
once all right
so that's what all right
that's what
i do that's what a difference between
dual and while loop is all right and
see you won't be using this uh do while
loop much i'm very sure of that because
i even like i've been uh like
using unity engine for almost four years
yeah so it's been almost i started in
2019 and it's been almost uh four years
i've been using unity engine and uh
it's been more like almost two years all
right i guess two to three years i have
been uh
doing augmented reality development
all right so
here's the thing all right
i have never used while loop all right i
have never used while loop while
developing
uh games or ar applications so
maybe in your case you might face uh you
know some moment where you have used uh
where you
should use or can use do i look so it's
totally totally okay all right but in my
case i never used uh do while loop in my
you know development journey so
yeah that's it
now
here's something you know
last alright here's the last uh
concept we are going to learn in the in
this conditionals
oh sorry not in this condition i guess i
forgot to change the name sorry i'm very
very sorry so i'm going to change the
name
so uh in this looping all right in this
loop concepts we are going to learn this
last thing that is jump statements all
right there are multiple jump statements
c sharp like there's go to there's break
there's a continue statement then there
is return statement all right then there
is throw statement but in this
particular lecture we are going to learn
about only two of them
that is continue and break statement all
right so
they are very simple all right jump
statements basically now they are a
statement all right jump statements are
basically a statement that instructs
uh the flow of a programmer that
instructs the program to deviate from
its normal flow sequence and jump to
another line of code all right so jump
statements are commonly used in loops
and other control flow statements all
right you will also you you know use
this in switch case statements
often in uh
if else statements alright so let's see
what are these
so
first of all let me uh show you
let me tell you which uh statements we
are going to learn today all right that
is break
all right we are going to learn about
break and continue
all right we're going to learn about
break and continue so let's implement it
so i'm going to use for you for this
already you can try out with while loop
do i loop anything you want all right so
i'm going to create a follow alright i'm
going to iterate you know i trade this
for loop over
up to 10 all right i'm going to iterate
this follow up to 10.
um
all right now
what i want to give a condition all
right
let's say
i want to print i'm
i'm printing all right all
all the numbers in here so i'm going to
print all the numbers in here and now i
what i want if all right
if uh the i if i reaches to 7 all right
if i reaches to 7
what i'm going to do is all right if i
reaches to seven what i'm going to do is
i'm going to break all right
i'm going to break so let's see if this
works or not
see
it didn't print it it broke it broke the
program all right after i reached to
seven
it broke the program all right
so that's what is it it is doing now
basically uh break statements now after
reaching some point a break statement
helps us to terminate the whole program
all right that's the whole point of
break all right
that's the whole point of break
statement now here comes continue
statement all right
see continue statement is a bit
different it will actually skip that
particular value and move to the next
value
let me show you
all right just give me a second
so you guys might be thinking all right
that i told you that continue statement
skips some part right it skips some part
and uh then moves to the next one
alright but here in the output it didn't
happen
right
because all right
because
here you can see
before the if statement
this uh console.writeline is being
executed so
in this case
it already had printed seven
then how is it going to skip if it has
already printed it
right so
that's why to actually use the continue
statement in this case what we do is we
first of all we check for the condition
and then
we write console.writeline and now here
you can see
that we are able to print up to 10 by
skipping already by skipping
number seven
all right
so
that's how this whole looping
works all right and i hope
this concept is very clear to you all
right so
yeah that's it for this lecture so see
you in the next lecture thank you
hey guys welcome to this lecture and in
today's lecture we are going to learn
about arrays all right arrays is a very
important concept all right it's a very
important concept in c sharp or any
other programming language so uh like
buckle up your belts and
see tightly because
it's really important for you to
understand uh
the concept of arrays all right because
uh
when uh see at this stage all right
at this stage in the beginning stage you
might
have very less use cases for array even
actually in the beginning stage also
you'll be using arrays more often all
right then you know
so
what i want to say is let's say take for
an example in augmented reality only all
right we
we use arrays in a lot of things all
right we can we like in plain detection
when we want to like you know uh let's
say
we want to
place all right place multiple objects
into the real world all right means in
marketless ar whenever we want to try to
let's say
place multiple objects in the real world
we
create an array of this object so that
we can uh
you know place them in the real world
all right so uh you are going to use
arrays in
everywhere all right so it is one of the
very important concept
so
let's dive into this topic all right
without waiting anymore so see in
general when we store values
we use a variable all right
but there's a problem all right
the problem is the problem that comes
with it is that we can only store one
single
one single value
all right
we can only store one single value we
can't store multiple values all right
and that's a problem if arrays or ratif
arrays or lists or
uh they wouldn't have been there now
then uh
we wouldn't have been able to you know
store multiple values in a variable all
right so what arrays does is
arrays
actually enables us right arrays
actually enables us to store numerous
number of value of any data type already
it can be of string it can be of integer
it can be of double it can be a float
all right it can be of care
so they
help us already provide us
uh
a technology so that we could not we
could store multiple values all right we
can store multiple values within one
single variable all right so that's how
we use an a sorry that's what is an
array is
an array in simple words all right an
array is a collection of data all right
an array is simply a collection of data
all right now
as we have learned about what actually
array is let me tell you about the
agenda of today's lecture so today we
are going to be uh going through the
very basics of array all right that is
we'll be learning how to initialize an
array then uh would be
uh learning how to access values within
an array all right then it would be
learning about some different different
methods
all right available in in uh an array
all right so let's get started so the
very first thing is that we have to
understand how to uh you know
implement an array all right see there
are two ways of uh implementing an array
let me uh first of all
not in comments wait so let me show you
all right there are two ways one is a
dynamic way and the one is a static way
all right i would tell you why they are
called those all right first of all
let's try out the dynamic way
so
the first thing all right see whenever
you declare variable how do you do that
so you can say into val equals 12 right
you declare a variable like that now
all
when creating an array or when creating
an array
make sure all right
that you don't miss the square bracket
wait to put the square brackets you have
to put the square brackets after end
variable
all right you have to put the square
brackets after in variable after that
this variable all right this variable
you created would be considered an array
all right it will be considered a
a variable that can store arrays all
right now to store arrays what we have
to do is open curly braces all right and
within that curly braces
put some values all right
2 1 6 let's say 3
all right so now let's run it and let's
check whether uh it's returning us any
error or not all right so here you can
see it is uh telling us your program
didn't did not output anything all right
don't worry about that alright because
we actually haven't printed anything i
would show you how to you know how to
print each and every uh value within an
array right so don't worry about that
so this is one way all right this is one
way of you know
initializing or creating an array and
this is known as dynamic array all right
now
another way around all right in creating
array is you have to again follow the
same thing that is uh int square
brackets then give the variable name all
right after that
all right
after that what you have to do is you
have to write a new keyword all right
then int
then
again square brackets
now this square
uh this square bracket has a spatial
meaning i would i would uh tell you all
right
so what is the meaning all right see
there's a reason why we call this type
of array and static array the reason is
we
already all right from the start only
when we declare the array all right from
the start only we specify the size of an
array that's what we are doing right now
so in this square brackets we have to
give a size of an array so let's let's
give it five all right so
now this is a static array all right
this is a static array
it doesn't have any value in it means uh
of course it does have all right it does
have value in it
but
all right but
it is static the reason is we have
already all right we have already
initialized
this array all right we have already
the array and uh because we have
already means declared the size of the
array because we have already declared
the size of the array in the memory all
right in the memory it has created a
static space already the ram it has
created its own memory that cannot be
exceeded
all right so that is it
now after after this whole bracket thing
what you have to do is again open
uh your curly brackets all right and
after that
write the number you want to give all
right
so yeah that's how we declare a static
array
all right now let's again uh run it and
let's see if it's retaining any any
around no it's not returning any error
because the syntax is totally correct
all right
now
all right see
the difference now the difference
between both all right both dynamic and
static array
all right is
basically
it means now
see static why is it called static audit
why
something is called static static means
which can't be changed afterwards all
right which we can't change afterwards
what
if it is declared on the start it is
declared declared all right we can't
actually change it or
means we can't actually add something
more up to it all right we can't exit
that memory all right but dynamic means
it is you know uh what can i say it is
adjustable
in the runtime dynamic is adjustable in
the right time so that is
what the you know that is what the
difference is
between dynamic and static all right i
hope uh you are clear about this all
right
so yeah so i'm going to uh
keep working with dynamic arrays only
all right
now
here's the thing all right so we have
learned about uh initializing array we
have learned about what exactly is an
array all right
now let's you know learn about uh
accessing
values within an array all right do you
remember when i uh taught you about the
window in the audience in the second
lecture only i
taught you about indexing all right i
hope you remember the concept all right
but if you don't let me uh tell you
indexing now it defines all right
indexing basically defines
positions positional value
of
some
data all right
in simple terms it means all right it
means let's say
there how many how many elements are
there in this you know how many elements
are there in this particular array there
are total five elements all right and
if we start indexing them all right
indexing uh in in uh in simple words you
can you know you can understand indexing
as uh um
basically address all right means
exactly uh if we talk about memory
address of any variable it's totally
different it's totally different topic
i'm just trying to make you understand
how like
what is indexing with indexing now it's
uh
think of it as an address of someone all
right like uh for example i am priyanshu
all right there are two priyanshu right
and uh
both
live all right both live in two
different uh like
two uh different places all right but
both are priyanshu uh
both are means
whose name and title are totally similar
all right
but
how will how will we uh know that uh
priyanshu uh means the priyanshu he is
finding is the actual one all right so
that's how address comes in all right
the person will ask for the address and
if the address is right he'll get to the
right financial so basically now
indexing is basically the positional
value of some data it's simple as that
it's it's the address of some data like
see uh for two the for the first element
all right the first element of an array
the address is zero means in the index
value of first element is zero the index
value of second element is one the index
value of third element is two
and it goes like this all right
it always goes like this so that is what
indexing is and
this is how indexing will help us
accessing the values all right now let
me show you so uh
let me uh show you by printing it all
right
so i want to access all right i want to
access let's say this all right three
three from the array so how would i do
that so let's count it so as it is
starting from zero zero one
two three all right so this is in the it
is in the third position so what i'm
going to do is
i'm going to write 3 in here and let's
see
if it works yeah we got it
right we definitely got it because the
positional value of 3
sorry the positional value of three is
three right uh
if if you are confused all right let me
let me uh give uh give you another way
around all right so let's say i want to
you know um
access this alright uh this particular
value already
means i want to access the six so how
would i do that so let's count it 0 1 2
so it is in the second position right so
now let's run it
so here you can see we are with the
index all right with the help of index
values we are able to access it and
always remember whenever you want to
access index value now
uh write the variable name then open uh
square brackets and inside that put the
index value
all right
so this is how we access all right this
is how we access values within an array
now
let's say if we uh let's say i want to
print all right each and every element
within this array all right
i i let i want to print each and every
element
within this array so what i'm going to
do is
for
in thai equals zero i less than equals
all right
how many elements are there
one two three four five right
so what i'm going to do less than all
right val
dot length all right see this is a
method all right you already learned
another um for your first method all
right dot length all right see this dot
length method now this length method
returns
the total length all right the total
length
of
your array all right so as our total
length is you know 5 that's why it has
returned 5 now here's comes the problem
here you can see
what i've written in equal 0 i less than
means it will iterate less than 5 all
right
do you know why it is ideal and why this
solution will work and why why not less
than equals will work
actually it is better to try by yourself
actually uh pause this video all right
pause the video
try both the uh both the way all right
try both the way
and check which one is running all right
i will show you right in here just give
me a few seconds so now uh as we have
you know try to access as we are trying
to access
the values with each and every value
what i'm going to do is i wrote
console.writeline then i'm going to take
the variable name the square brackets
and i'm
going to put the i inside because you
know with every iteration the value of i
is increasing
all right so here you can see we got all
the elements we got all the elements
because we started from 0 zero is this
one all right and ended with four
all right and the fourth positional
value is of this one right now let's try
out less than equals one let's see what
happens
let's see
see it has printed but here you can see
it has returning us error now what's the
error index was outside the bounds of an
array the reason is the reason is
the length of an array or the length of
an array
is uh
5 all right the length of this array is
5 but
indexing ends at 4 all right and we are
trying to access the elements of we are
trying to access the elements of this
array through indexing so if there is
all right if there is no element present
if there is no element present
in
the fifth position all right if there is
no element present in the fifth position
then of course it will return error it
because it doesn't have any value all
right now
here's a fun fact
all right here's the fact that you you
must know all right like i guess i
forgot to tell you about this like when
we create this kind of array now
just wait
when we create
this sort of array
all right
if we let's say if we don't assign
values in here now like i assigned
previously if we don't assign those
values in here now it will automatically
like automatically zero all right zero
will be assigned to each and every
position all right so this is for a fact
and you guys must you know know it all
right
so
now
we have learned the very basics of array
right we have learned how to access
elements in an array right
so now it is our time to look into the
methods all right the methods
are present in an array all right you
already saw all right you already saw
method length now let me show it to
again so here i am declaring a variable
that is int
val
all right
so into val then let's give it uh 5
a 7 let's say
nine eight
so
here you can see all right we
got uh we created our own array now the
first method we are going to learn about
is length method all right and you you
already know uh what exactly is length
right how length method works so what
i'm going to do is console.writeline
val dot
length all right so what this will do it
will return all right it will return us
the total length of the array so here it
is returning 6 because there are six
elements present in the array similarly
we have let's say we have another
variable all right we have
another variable uh not exactly a
variable just uh just
so we have a variable of array all right
so we
have a variable of array now what we
have to do is now what we have to do is
we have to uh learn another function all
right and that function is basically
sort function all right see sorting or
sorting is basically rearranging uh re
and rearranging you know the
rearranging the values all right means
the gibberish values in an ascending
order or descending order all right so
that is what uh you know uh sorting is
all right so
here comes the function all right so
this is the sort functions first of all
let me remove this length one because uh
of course we don't need it anymore
now what we have to do is let me show
you that we have uh you know i have an
array initialize now what you have to do
is you have to write a function
array dot
sort all right
and inside the sort for function we have
to pass an argument and that argument
will be an array all right and now what
you can do is
for
int
i
equals 0 i less than
array all right so oh sorry not array
val dot
length
i plus plus
all right and
let's uh try to print it all right let's
try to print this
value all right let's let's try it out
let's see
let's see what happens all right
currently uh this is uh this
this particular array is not ordered all
right and now to make it ordered we use
the sort function so here you can see it
has uh arranged all right it has
arranged all the uh elements
in an
ascending order
all right
so that's how uh this thing works all
right
so
now we we are going to learn another
function already that is index of
alright
this is index of function that is it
will return the index of some value
all right so you already know how this
works right i guess i showed you
previously means not in this uh and not
in case of arrays so
int idx equals
array
all right dot
index of
all right and within that we have to
pass two arguments the first one would
be the array all right means the array
from which you are looking for the value
and the second one will be
the value
means the value
on which you will be taking out the
means uh you you have to put the value
uh
which you want to get all right means
which you want to get in the sense let's
say i want to put a value and i want to
get its index value right
so that's what i am i will be doing so i
am just going to put a certain value in
here so i'm going to put 7 in here
all right and you know let's uh
let's print it all right console dot
writeline
idx all right so
let's uh run this program and let's see
what happens so here you can see it is
returning 3 the reason is
0 1 2 3
7 is available in index 3 all right so
that's how this whole index of function
works all right now here comes
three more functions all right that is
maximum minimum that is max min and sum
all right so the
meaning is hidden in their name only so
it's like the max function all right
first of all understand this math
function max function will return the
maximum value
available all right the maximum value
available in array the min
or the mean function will return the
minimum value available in the array ah
and
the sum all right the sum function will
return the total sum of elements from
the array all right so
let's uh
try to print it out alright so console
dot
right line all right and inside this
val dot
max and give parenthesis all right
so now
let's see what is the maximum value in
here
in our case the maximum value eight is
eight now let's see the minimum value
and that's totally right and let's see
the minimum value the minimum value is
zero and that's also totally right now
let's print out the sum of you know the
sum of total uh array so you can if if
you want you can perform the calculation
and you will be surely getting 25 all
right so
these are the array methods all right
that
you must like you must have an basic
idea about all right and uh i would
suggest all right i would suggest you
guys to look more into arrays after this
session also all right because
array is a very important concept all
right and uh
there are a lot of algorithms that works
on arrays like there are multiple
sorting algorithms searching algorithms
so i want you guys to have a very good
idea and understanding of arrays all
right so make sure you do that and so
yeah that's it for this lecture see you
in the next lecture thank you yo we are
going to learn about functions in c all
right see functions uh are a very
important topic all right in terms of
programming all right the reason behind
that is because functions uh helps us to
manage our code all right it uh
helps us to you know lower the number of
codes we write uh function helps uh our
means uh function helps us to keep our
code clean all right
so function a function has a lot of use
cases all right in
uh when you will be developing all right
your ar applications you'll be working
with
functions all right like uh update all
right like the update method
in unity is a function
the start method in a unity is a
function
right so basically functions and methods
all right are an essential part of
programming any software all right see
whenever we code we have to follow a
very simple principle of dry now what is
dry dry means don't repeat yourself all
right
why because it increases the code
quality it saves a lot of time all right
and functions uh in simpler terms
functions or methods are basically a
block of coder right
they are basically a block of code which
can be
used anytime we want all right without
repeating ourselves all right like for
an example
you uh i have implemented an algorithm
all right that is a sorting algorithm
let's say you have implemented a
selection sort algorithm all right now
you have to use that algorithm
at multiple places in your program right
so the let's say the algorithm is of 10
to 20 lines all right for example
now the problem would come that if you
like you know manually write that
algorithm in each and every portion now
it will increase the code base all right
it will increase the code base then it
will uh
you know cost you a lot of your time all
right and time is money
right so
uh what function does is we can create a
function of that particular sorting
algorithm and use that function
everywhere all right so that saves a lot
of time and makes the code base more
optimized
so
it is very important all right to
understand the concept of functions
all right
so basically there are two steps through
which we can you know use a function the
first is we have to create a function
all right
and the second is we have to call a
function all right
now see call i would show you what what
does calling a function means is all
right see for an example if i had to
show you a function right now this you
can see this main method right in here
all right or main function right in here
is a function all right the difference
between a regular function and this main
function or the main method
is
that main method
calls itself automatically all right it
is called automatically whereas
a regular regular function has to be
called by the user all right or the
developer
so
ah this is the major difference between
a specified means of this main function
and a regular function all right
now
by calling it we means we have to you
know
call the function we have to say to the
function that function do this task for
me then only the function will work all
right he won't do the task by himself
we have to command him all right so
that's why we call a function
okay now as we have discussed about
function one more thing is that
you have to keep in mind whenever
creating a function now you can't write
means create a function inside another
function all right always remember that
so whenever we create a function it
should be outside a function alright
like this
public static
all right
void
set score
all right and
like this all right we create a function
like this now i know this might be a bit
confusing all right so i'm going to
explain you each and everything first of
all let's start with the syntax right
let me comment or create a comment third
line all right
in this commented light the first or all
right the first that would come
will be an access
modifier all right the very first thing
will be access modifier i will tell you
what exactly is access modifier all
right after that
there will come a return type all right
after the return type all right you have
to give your function a name all right
and then you have to give a parenthesis
all right inside the parenthesis you can
add parameters what are parameters
parameters basically
takes uh it is basically a list of
arguments all right that we provide like
like uh an array.sort function that i
taught you in the
arrays lecture what happened in there we
provided an argument inside that sort
function right so that's how uh that's
why we use parameters so parameters
would come
inside
this function
means this parenthesis and then you
already know what to do
open and close curly brackets all right
and inside this you have to
put some code all right now you know
let's see the actual code for it
first of all all right
here you can see we are writing a
function first of all we are giving
access modifier all right public
all right
void
and then
what you have to give is a function name
what would be the function name
the function let's set the function ms
set scope all right
and now
inside this function we have to give all
right some write some code that is
console
dot
write line
and inside this
you have to
print something let's print hello
world
now
to call this function or let's say let's
rename this function to hello world only
all right
so now to call this function what we
have to do is
just wait yeah
to call this function what we have to do
is we have to write the function name
like this and then add parenthesis into
it and let's run it
so here you can see all right
here you can see
it is giving us an error what is this
error
it is telling us an object reference is
required to access non-static member all
right
the reason is we didn't give any
reference to the object alright and
currently as you uh have not learned
about object-oriented programming we'll
be learning about object-oriented
programming in the next class so here's
a keyword all right static
all right
right now
you don't you know you don't have to put
your mind into the
keyword static and public all right
because uh
these two keyword will make more sense
after the next lecture all right because
uh these uh these two
uh basically these two keywords uh are
mostly used
in object-oriented programming only all
right so
now let's run the program and let's see
what happens see we are able to get the
output all right now
uh i would explain you all right
i would explain you this code all right
what exactly are these first you can see
we are specifying an access modifier
that is this one this is access modifier
now what is what exactly is an access
modifier access modifier is like a
gatekeeper all right like uh like let's
say you have a security guard in your
house all right the secret the you have
guided means you have told that the
security security guard that you are
like you don't want anybody to uh
disturb you all right so at that point
of time here you have gone private
but
if your security guard if if you haven't
like if you have told your security
guard that
brother uh if anyone comes to meet me
then
let him inside all right
let him come inside so then you are
public all right the security guard will
let it go it's
the access modifiers are also something
like
this public and private all right public
and private
public means you can access that
particular thing from any class all
right
whereas private means you can't access
that particular thing let it be a
variable or method you can't access it
outside of their class
so i know this might be my this might
seem a bit overwhelming or maybe it
might seem you know a bit confusing but
that's totally okay because
all these concepts all right you will
get a grip on all this concept after the
next lecture because in object-oriented
programming we are going to learn more
about methods we are going to learn more
about access modifiers we are going to
experiment with it all right so
don't worry
all right
now so as we uh i hope the basic concept
of access modifier is clear it just
access modify helps us to modify
the access all right it help us to
modify restrict the access of any
variable or of any method
all right so that is what an access
modifier is next here comes the static
keyboard all right
don't worry about that
don't worry about the static keyword all
right
let me uh i'm going to explain the stat
keyword
uh uh in the next lecture alright
because this static keyword is one of
the very important uh concept that you
should know all right
after the static keyword comes return
type all right return type all right
return type is basically
what kind of value we want to return to
the function all right return type
basically defines
what value can be returned to the
function it can be of
void all right it can be float it can be
string all right
so now see access modifiers can be of
multiple types all right it can be
boolean all right it can be of bool it
can be you know of a float it can be of
string all right another type
uh is void
in a void all right in a void return
type we didn't we do not need to return
all right we do not need to return
anything
in a void you know in a void function
but
let's say we create a function with a
different return type let's say in all
right so public static
int all right let's say we are you know
let's let's create a function that would
you know give us the square of some
number so
let's write a function that is square
off all right
then in here
what i'm going to do is i'm going to
create a variable all right that is int
let's say
square
all right square off
square off i'm going to create this
variable all right in here the s is
small and in the function it is uh in
caps all right so don't worry so now
what i can do how to you know how can we
exactly uh
make a square of the number right
multiply that number with the same
number right
so here i'm taking an parameter all
right so the parameter would be uh
integer n all right
you can take as many parameters you want
all right i can even uh take another
parameter as a float
all right i can even take that that is
float
n one all right i can do that so the
thing is i you don't you know you don't
have to
be like uh the function can only take
one parameter you can give as many
parameters you want all right so now as
we have given the parameter we are
doing it n into n and after that i'm
returning all right i'm returning we we
are using the return keyword i'm
returning this square off
all right i'm returning this
square of variable to the function
now in here as we called this function
it printed us hello all right but
to you know get the value of this
function all right that is the square of
function it would be a bit different how
let me tell you let's try it out
actually all right let's take the square
of you know square uh
square of function and uh let's put a
value let's say 2 we want square of 2
now let's run it let's see
see here you can see your program did
not output anything the reason behind
this it is not printing anything it is
returning the value to the function now
to print all right now to print the
value of the function what we have to do
is we have to store this
uh we store the returned value into a
variable so how would it how do we do it
do that so create a variable that is in
final
you can name it anything after you have
stored it like this then you can do
console dot
write line
final all right and after that
you can simply print anything all right
i mean simply print it now let's say try
out a square of 4
so the square of 4 will be 16 right so
here you can see that it is giving out
the output as 16. similarly you can
also create your return types as boolean
all that you can create your return
types as string all right one more thing
you have to keep in mind if you are
specifying a return type like ink you
have to return integer values only if
you try to return float value floating
point or string value uh it would give
you error
all right
so make sure uh you practice on this all
right and don't worry about the uh
access modifiers and the static keyword
all right because in the next lecture in
the next lecture that is uh where we'll
be exploring classes and objects that is
a basics of object-oriented programming
there would be lo there you would be
learning about the static keyword the
you know about static classes you'll be
learning about objects or that you'll be
learning about instances then you would
also be learning about this access
modifiers how we use them right so
you'll be learning all those things in
the next lecture so don't worry if you
are if you are confused somehow by the
next lecture the functions the topic of
functions will be very clear to you but
if i had to say in a very simple word
functions are just basically a block of
code that help us to reduce the uh means
reduce the lines of a code all right we
can reuse that function and always
remember don't repeat uh always follow
the principle of don't repeat yourself
all right like let's say if you are
creating an algorithm then uh create a
function of that algorithm so that so
that you can use that function anywhere
you want all right so make sure you
follow the principles of
dry all right so yeah that's it for this
lecture so in the next lecture we are
going to learn about classes and objects
in this lecture we are going to learn
about object-oriented means the very
basics of object-oriented programming
all right and in that we'll be learning
about classes and objects all right so
this is the very basic of
object-oriented programming there are
many other concepts already that you
would be needing to learn but for now
for the starting all right for starting
uh this is the topic that i'm going to
teach you alright we'll be learning
about classes and objects we'll be
learning about fields we'll be learning
about methods that is class members all
right we'll be learning about you know
constructors how to create a constructor
we are going to learn about access
modifier static keyword we are going to
learn about static classes all right
so
without any further ado all right
let's
start with the lecture all right see
to understand classes and objects now
understand this
object-oriented programming all right we
have to understand the uh very
fundamental concept of object-oriented
programming what exactly is it see
object-oriented programming
is basically an approach all right
that breaks a programming problem into
you know uh objects that interact with
each other all right
basically objects
are uh created from you know templates
and those templates are known as class
all right
ue actually we actually can you know
think
class as a blueprint all right class as
a blueprint and
you know just like a you know a
blueprint of a building all right and
from that blueprint of a building we
build
an object that is the actual building
with bricks and mortar and all those
things
right
so that's what object-oriented
programming is
all right so i hope this uh
you have understood what exactly
object-oriented programming is
right
now
as we have understood what exactly
object-oriented programming is it is our
time to understand about classes all
right
as i told you class is like a blueprint
right like here you can see this is a
class public class program
right inside there is a method that is
the main method
right so we can write our own class now
to write our own class first of all
remember you can't write a class inside
another class all right you have to
write
a new class outside of that class all
right so
what we have to do is write
public all right
public
class all right and give
the class a name all right give the
class a name
and
let's give the class a name as person
and then what you have to do is you have
to open curly braces and close it so
this is how we write
a class all right this is a public
method
this is the class keyword
and this is
the name of the class all right so
that's how we create a class all right
now there's some there is another thing
called fields
all right to understand field you can
say fields are you know
variables only all right they are
variables
only a field is simply a variable that
is we know we declared
we declare inside a class all right
like any other variables all right they
are used to store data like here you can
see we can write public
all right in or let's say public
string
name of the person all right
then
we can write public
in
age right so this is how we are this
this is called fields
all right so this is are called
all right
now here you can notice that there is
public keyword and you know in front of
all the variables
all right so they are now they are known
as access modifiers
they are basically gate keepers they you
know control who has access all right
who has access to the
uh fields or methods now the who in this
case is another class all right now if
we make this to private now this program
class won't be able to access this uh
variables from this person class all
right now to you know uh to access this
class we have to create an object of
this class all right so i'm going to
teach you how to do that but before that
let's
learn how to create methods all right
let's learn how to create methods inside
inside a new class
so it's or it's also similar like this
public static void main just like i uh
taught you in previous lecture about
functions so what you can do is
public
all right
static
void
and let's give it a name all right
let's give it a name that is
uh
get name all right and in here it is not
necessary to give the static keyword all
right i would
there's a reason behind that i will you
would be learning that reason after you
know after we get into the concept of
static keywords so don't worry we are
going to get in there all right for now
remove the static keyword for now remove
the static keyboard what you can do is
console
dot
right
line
all right and uh
write it like this name is
uh
get the you know get the name variable
in here all right get the name variable
in here and similarly do the you know
same thing
for the age variable all right
ages
all right so now what you have to do is
now we
as we have created our method as we have
created our method
what we have to do is we have to create
an object of that class all right
or in simple word
an instance of that class what does that
mean see an object is created from a
class all right we have already create
created a class named person so now we
can use this to create objects
object is basically an instance of a
class all right
to you know to create an object of the
class we use
the new keyword
let me show you how
all right so it's very simple
what you have to do is first
what you have to do take the class name
that is in our case the class name is
person
after that
give you know give it a name that is i'm
going to named p for now and then
put equals to in there then write the
keyword new
and then again
call the class like this all right and
then
give parenthesis to it after that if you
run it let's say if you get any errors
or not you are not getting any error so
that means we are good to go all right
so now
here we have created an instance of a
class or you can say an object of a
class
all right
we have created an object of a class
now as we have created an
instance of the class we can you know
also access the fields and methods
available inside the class from our
program class all right and make
modifications to it all right
like
in here all right so what i first what i
can do is p dot
all right here uh first of all to access
you know to access the you know fields
and methods of the class you have to
call that right so what you can do is
here you have renamed the class right
that is you have name the object as p so
write p in there then dot all right
then give the variable name and set the
variable name to you know anything let's
say your name all right
and after that set it uh set the age
value to
let's say uh my age currently is 17 all
right so i'm going to
put it like that after that all right
here you can see
uh let's change the name to gate details
actually yeah that would be better so
now here you can see
let's actually uh try it out let's see
if any error is coming or not so here
you can see we are not getting any error
now
now let's get the details let's see if
uh like the means uh in the object the
details we have filled
has been set or not to do that what if
as i have created a
you know method that is get detail so
what i can do is p
dot
get details
and let's
see if everything is working or not
so here you can see
all the things in here are working now
you can create all right you can create
multiple objects all right you can
create as many objects you want all
right like this let's let's try another
one
that is person
p
equals
new person
and in here what you can do is p
dot
name equals let's uh you know give it
row hit
all right
and
let's give give its age
also you know 18 let's give it and now
let's see oh all right always remember i
did a mistake i you know name both the
cla or means both the instances with the
same name so don't do that all right
change the name in here
my bad so now what you can do is
p1 dot
get details
all right now let's see if this works or
not
so here you can see
both the
uh instances are working so this is how
we create a class and we create an
instance of that class all right so this
is how we do it
now
see the fields and methods inside all
right the fields and method inside a
class all right like this is the field
all right this variable is a field this
variable is a field and this is a method
this uh this whole thing is a method
so they
are often referred as class members all
right they are the member of the class
called person
all right so make sure to keep this in
mind
all right so now as we have learned
about you know classes and objects
now it is our time
to learn about constructors
all right
to learn about constructors i know it uh
this you know this
term might seem a bit unique you know
confusing but don't worry all right
don't worry i'm going to tell you how to
do it all right see
what is a constructor
a constructor is basically a special
method all right that is you know used
to initialize objects
the advantage of using a constructor
is that
it is called when an object alright it
is called
when an object is created it can be used
to set initial values for fields
all right means
right now all right whenever we are
calling this you know whenever you are
calling means creating an object of this
class
no value is being set by default all
right we are not able to set any value
by default we are setting them later on
what constructor does is whenever we
create an instance of a class
a constructor is called
all right
a constructor
is you know
is called
so
to you know to set means to create a
constructor it's very simple
what you have to do is
public all right
then
you have to write the class name all
right you have to write the class name
then parenthesis it it just looks like
the function just you don't have to give
the return type all right
then
in the person
in the person i'm going to set all right
i'm going to set
the name to let's say default
human
and the age to
let's say 100
all right
now you know let's remove the uh
previous code all right let's remove the
previous code and let's see how this
whole constructor thing is working
right
see i won't be setting the name uh right
now what i'll be doing is i would just
i would just be you know
uh creating an instance of the class and
then we'll be calling this method
directly i won't be setting the name
right now you you will see what will be
the output
all right so let me show you so first of
all what you have to do is create
create an instance of the class so how
do we do that person p equals new
person all right
semicolon and then p dot
get details all right and in here
let's see if it works or not so here you
can see here you can see we didn't said
uh set the name all right we didn't set
the class name in here
we didn't set it explicitly all right we
didn't set it explicitly
the constructor all right the
constructor is called when the object is
already created so that's why by default
by default
the constructor has set
the variable name and age
to the specified value and in our case
for the name the specified value is
default human and for the age the
specified value is 100
all right
i hope you understand that you know the
concept of
you know constructors all right now
there are a few pointers that you need
to remember all right a constructor name
must match the class name all right and
uh always remember our
constructor cannot all right cannot have
a return type all right and all uh
remember this a constructor all right a
construct is called whenever
whenever an object is created or you can
say an instance is created of the class
all right and always remember uh
see all classes now
have constructors by default
all right
all classes have constructors by default
if you don't create a constructor by
yourself now the c programming language
all right or any other programming
language
will create a you know default
constructor for you all right by himself
all right by means the c sharp will
create
uh automatically a constructor for you
all right however the problem with that
comes is that you won't be able uh to
you know set the initial values for the
fields so that's a problem that's why we
can you know we define a
means we define a constructor manually
all right
so i hope the concept of constructors
uh
classes and objects are clear all right
i hope you have you know understood the
concept of classes objects and
constructors
you have understood about i hope you
have understood about fields and methods
about class members so now
our next topic all right our next topic
is of constructor parameters all right
like you know in functions how how i
told you about parameters
uh this is also something like that all
right this is also you know same
so to
create a parameter what you can do is
in within the parenthesis you can create
variables all right that is you can
create parameters now let's create a
parameter name all right and let's
create another parameter as
age
after that what we can do is
what we can do is we can remove the
default human from name and set it to
dash name and again do the same thing
for age to dash age all right now
what is the you know what is the benefit
of it
let me show you
all right let me show you the first of
all this will reduce the lines of code
all right this will reduce the lines of
code by a lot
so now as we have said the parameter it
is very simple you know it is very
simple so
i'm going to create another object that
is let's say
person
all right person b equals new person
all right and then p dot get details
and now in here here you can see there
are parenthesis inside of this
parenthesis we pass some value so how do
we do that it's very simple
first of all the first parameter is a
string so we are going to give it a
string that is priyanshu
and the next parameter
is age and we are going to give it 17.
now lets run it
and here you can see
just within two lines like previously we
were using four lines now we have
reduced it to two lines so now here you
can see
we are getting the same output we got
previously
all right so that's how they save a lot
of time time
so i hope constructors the concept of
you know the cons concept of
constructors are clear to you all right
because the next two topics are going to
be very interesting that is access
modifiers and static keyword
all right
so
let me show you
see
access modifiers basically defines from
where we can you know access our methods
and variables from
so far
there are two access modifiers that you
that you should know all right that is
public and private now
public means that you know we can access
the class members from outside the class
whereas
whereas in other side private doesn't
allows us to access the class member
outside the class but only can be
accessed within the class all right so i
know it might uh you know it might seem
a bit overwhelming or
uh
you know it might get a bit confusing
but that's totally fine all right that's
totally fine
the thing is i'm going to show you show
it to you by doing it practically now
let's remove this constructor because we
don't need it as of now all right let's
remove this
all right now in here let's change the
name all right let's change the public
keyword to private all right
let's change it to private
now
let's create another instance that is
person
p equals
new
person now in here
p dot
name
equals let's set it to you know
priyanshu all right again let's set it
to priyanshu
and again let's set the age
to
let's say
17 all right
and let's get try to get the details
now let's see what happens first of all
let me ask you will it return an error
or will it work
will it work or return any error just
give it a thought all right pause the
video give it a thought and then return
so i'm going to show you
here you can see
there are three errors
the errors are the uh hello world all
right the person.name means this is the
name page hello world all right the
person.name is inaccessible due to its
protection level
again another is person dot age is
inaccess inaccessible due to its
protection level the same goes for
personal.getdetails is inaccessible due
to its protection levels so
because of the private all right because
of the private
you know
uh this private keyword what is
happening it made our fields and methods
private so we can't access the variables
and methods outside of the class whereas
with public keyword we can do that
right and uh let's say uh there's
another way to you know make uh you know
field or method private
is that you can simply you know remove
the private and it will be go to private
by default but you know i don't you know
i i always like to write private because
i i don't know but it seems really good
to write private at first so
that's why i always write private and i
also suggest you for initial stages all
right for initial stages
uh write private all right
if you are creating any private method
then for initial stages write private
all right so that you know you get it
more clearly that what is the use of
private so i hope you are now clear with
the
concept of access modifiers what are
public and private all right
now there are two more access modifiers
that is you know protected all right
protected is there
and uh
so you can you know learn more about
them
all right
you can learn more about them you can
search about them you can learn more
about them all right through google
so make sure you do that
now
next all right the next concept we are
going to learn is static keyword and
static classes
all right
so
first of all let's understand the
concept of static keyword all right see
the static keyword actually helps us to
get access to the class members
such as variables methods etc with it
without needing to create an instance or
object of the class whereas um i hope
you understood this right
right now all right let's make this you
know variable to public as of now let's
make them to public
so now here you can see we are creating
an instance of the class right
we are creating an instance or object of
the class to access these variables
right we are creating an instance of the
class to access these variables
now
the thing is if we put a static keyword
already if we put a static keyword in
front of every variable or field of
method like this static
all right
static
public again public static
and let's you know let's not create the
object now what we can do is person
dot name
equals priyanshu
sorry
then person
dot
age
equals
then person dot
get details
now let's see if this works or not
see this is working
this is totally working now let's again
try the same thing
without this you know static keyword
let's try it out let's see if that works
or not
here you can see it is uh telling us an
object reference is required to access
static member so non-static member so
here you can see
remember all right always remember if if
we if it creates if we make something
static now we don't need to create an
object of that class to access it we can
access it directly but if any variable
or method is non-static all right like
currently this uh all these all these
methods and variable right in here
are
non-static alright that means they are
not static so we have to create an
object of of this particular class
to you know edit or you can say access
all the fields and methods present
inside the class all right so i hope you
are clear about this so basically what
we get static keyword helps us to get
access to the class members all right
without needing to create an instance or
object of the class all right so that is
how the static keyword helps us
all right i hope you are you know clear
about the static the concept of static
keywords
now
what we have to learn all right what we
have to learn is about static class and
this is the last concept that we are
going to learn into today's lecture
see just like we learned about you know
uh this
static you know variables
basically let me tell you in uh you know
just like
having uh static methods or fields or
properties or constructors we can also
have you know static classes you know
our static classes can only contain
static members all right a static class
can only contain static members that
means let's say if i you know create a
static class right now and again let's
let's uh you know
let's try the old step we are doing like
creating an object
let's uh do it now all right p p dot you
know
p dot name equals uh let's say priyanshu
then uh p dot h
equals
then
p dot uh
get details now you uh you'll be getting
an error all right
the error is
cannot declare instance members in a
static class
static class the reason be the reason is
all the variables and method right in
here all the variables and method right
in here
is non-static and
let's let's turn it to static as of now
all right let's turn it to static and
let's see if we are getting an error or
not
here we are getting again an error the
reason is
the reason is not because all the all
the variables are in here are static the
reason is because
as the class is static we are trying to
create an instance of the class and that
is not possible because uh
stat we cannot create instance of a
static class
we have to direct we have to get direct
access to it right so for that person
dot you know name equals uh
uh priyanshu
priyanshu then person dot age
equals 17 now let's do it person dot you
know get
details
as
let's see it now
see it is working like that so this is
what a static class is all right so i
hope
the concepts of classes objects fields
method class members then access
modifiers and you know static classes
are clear all right and this is going to
really help you to understand how we you
know work with c sharp in
unity all right so as of now this module
all right in this module we have
completed our lectures we we have
successfully completed this lecture all
right
so
next will be start creating our own ar
applications all right with euphoria
so
yeah
let's get into the next module thank you
hey folks uh welcome to module 4 and
this is the first video of
module 4 and in this lecture i'm going
to explain you all right we are going to
dig deeper into the concepts of marker
based augmented reality that is we are
going to learn about the architecture we
are going to learn about the available
sdks we are going to learn about how
things work in market based augmented
reality all right and later on i'm also
going to tell you what you uh what means
how like which tools are we going to use
to develop
our uh like ar applications right so
without any further let's get started
so what is see
first uh let's recap all right first uh
let's recapitulate our concepts of uh
market-based augmented reality all right
see market-based augmented reality all
right uh this is a type of augmented
reality all right that makes users that
that makes use of uh recognition and
tracking alright it is the property of
or you can say it is the
uh feature of computer vision all right
so it make uses the uh properties of
computer vision that is our tracking and
recognition all right to to uh recognize
and track a marker and uh put all right
and
place or augment a 3d object or any kind
of digital objects on top of that marker
right you can even augment a video on
top of that marker so that is what
marker based augmented reality is all
right um
so yeah that is what marker-based
augmented reality is you can even see
the diagram right it's not exact diagram
but the gif right in here uh there's a
mobile and there are some a b c d uh are
written some alpha alphabets are written
and they are working as a marker right
in the sen in the center marker the
batman is like the lego form of batman
is uh placed so this is what
marker-based augmented reality is it
basically makes uses of
markers to uh augment all right to place
digital objects into a real world that's
just it all right
now if it uh see
we already know what uh what our marker
based augmented reality is now it is our
our a very time alright it is our time
to understand
uh or learn about
different types of game engines all
right different types of development
engines available
all right if we talk about uh there are
multiple available in the market alright
these are just some of them right i have
i have just listed down some of them but
there are many others available in the
market all right if we talk about the
things that are the engines that are
available here uh that is unity unreal
go dot cry engine then uh if you want to
uh develop
your own ar filters let's say for uh you
want to develop for uh instagram or
facebook right there is park air studio
that we are that i am going to cover in
this course also so this is the bonus
section all right in the bonus section
i'm going to cover the sparkier studio
similarly uh if you if you are a user of
snapchat and you want to create your own
uh filters for snapchat then uh there is
there is lens studio all right these are
augmented reality technologies all right
um then then there is appertus vr
although i haven't used uh used apart
svr uh the engines that i have used till
now right the the development tools that
i have used till now is unity unreal go
dot uh i have tried out cryengine but it
wasn't suited for me i didn't like it so
and another i used was sparky studio all
right i haven't used lens studio or
apertures vr but you guys can try it out
all right
uh so these are the development engines
uh that are currently available in the
market and
the most used all right in the in the
field of augmented reality and virtual
reality and mixed reality the most used
is the unity all right like the major
major companies uses unity for
developing arvr applications unreal
unreal engine also is also used
so these two are the main like major uh
development engines that are used even
go dot uh godot supports uh a ar vr you
can even you can try it out same does a
cry engine two they also support ar vr
all right so you can try these out all
right and in this course i am going to
teach you unity all right and we are
going to cover uh the ar ar part with
unity
all right so as we have learned about
the development engine now it's our very
time to learn about
the software development kits available
all right here you can see there are
multiple available like like google's ar
code then there is kudan then there is
apple's ar kit then maxed is there then
viewforia 8th wall xr then lightship
ardk then easyar is there and wikitused
is there right see these are uh software
development kits that is sdks the they
come in packages all right
they come in packages all right and in
this course i'm going to cover the
euphoria all right i'm going to cover
euphoria
as viewforia is very famous and very
good for marker-based er and
it is also easy for beginners so it is
better to cover euphoria in this course
so i'm going to cover euphoria all right
and the tracking tracking feature of
euphoria is better than any of these
all right means
better than any other uh marker based ar
technologies all right so
that's why i'm going to cover euphoria
in this course and also if i if i tell
you which
sdks have i have i tried i have tried
out uh ar code i have developed multiple
apps with it i have uh tried out ar kit
that is apple's uh then i have tried out
euphoria of course then uh i have tried
out eighth wall xr
although i didn't like that much but
it's a decent enough all right then i
have also tried out niantic light ship
ar all right uh it it has just launched
like it has launched uh on 8th of
november currently it is in beta alright
you if you want you can go through the
documentation and download the sdk and
try it out all right so uh niantic has
launched their uh
own lightship sdk niantic is the same
company who developed pokemon go all
right so uh they have released their
technology behind pokemon go on the uh
like publicly so i would suggest
exploring the light ship ar dk all right
um
and yeah i have tried these already but
if you want you can try the others also
like you can try out kudan you can try
out max you can try out uh easy ar
wikitude and all these available in arc
these are not just all right means
there are many others also all right
like i haven't listened to all of them
but there are some of them that i have
listed all right so
try to do some research all right do a
research by yourself and find out uh
what more sdk that uh ar sdks are
available in the market all right so
yeah these are the sdks that are
available and uh in the development
tools all right in the development tools
i'm going to use unity all right i have
already taught uh unity
and uh in module two and
in module 4 i'm going to teach you
euphoria all right so
we are going to uh for this course we
are going to uh we are going to cover
this whole course in
unity
and euphoria all right
so yeah let's get uh dive into the
concepts all right
see what is recognition all right what
is it uh
uh think of in human terms all right
just think of in human terms see a
person is coming to you you all right he
is uh the person is uh you're relative
all right uh you know you know the face
alright it is stored in your brain
already uh the face of that person is
stored in your brain now you can
recognize that person right you already
know that
right you already know that so that's
how you are recognizing
right that's how you are recognizing the
person yeah this person's name is abc
and uh he works at this abc company and
this and that all right you know that
person you you are able to recognize it
similarly if you think about devices all
right uh
let's say um
barcode devices right see if you buy any
sort of product all right let's say we
go in a mall uh when you buy any sort of
product you uh submit it in the counter
to make the bill all right what they do
they have some sort of reader right i
exactly uh don't know the name i think
it is called barcode reader so what they
do they uh with the help of the device
they read the barcode all right and then
uh push the uh object or the thing that
you are buying uh forward right and make
the bill so
how the how the device is recognizing
the barcode right because
uh
the device also already knows like it
already has the data about the barcode
right it already does have the data so
that's how it is recognizing it
so uh like i have bought some some
let's say i have bought a pair of shoes
all right and there is a barcode the
person i have submitted in the counter
the person scan the barcode and push the
shoe forward to uh for the billing for
the billing all right so
the particular barcode is stored on the
database all right so that's how the
barcode reader recognized it similarly
if you talk about face recognition
system
same thing works like in big big
companies they use face recognitions
also to
verify the employees right they use
fingerprint recognition also so
these are stored in the database and uh
some algorithms are there all right
there are some algorithms some computer
vision algorithms which
which are able to uh recognize the
person right similarly in ar also there
are some sort of databases all right in
marker-based ar there are some sort of
databases uh databases in the sense
there are markers all right those
markers are stored somewhere right those
markers are stored somewhere and our app
and we design our app in that way all
right in a way we design our app in a
way
so that it can recognize all right it
can recognize the marker if the marker
isn't in our database then it won't be
able to recognize it right and if it is
not able to recognize it then how would
uh like then how will it uh put the
marker like uh how will it put the
marker on top of that
uh sorry put that object on top of that
marker right
how did he do that how would the
algorithm how would the sdk do that
so it is always important all right to
uh whenever working with markup is there
we have to put a marker on the marker on
the apps database and don't worry we are
going to see how this is done all right
there's a very basic of euphoria only so
uh
yeah so that's how uh recognition works
all right uh in in marker based ar
and uh
this this uh process is uh valid in
multiple uh ways right so this is what
recognition is recognition is basically
recognizing something all right that is
in the database like in our human mind
all right if i if i see a person i uh i
must i might know the person right like
uh i know my brother all right he's a
person that is in my brain's database
right
i know that person so i will be able to
recognize it all right now let's say
some new person come all right i won't
be able to recognize him right i won't
be able to recognize that person if if
it was a random person because i don't
know the person his uh his details
aren't stored in my database right so
these things work something like this
all right so yeah this is what
recognition is
now if we talk about um
tracking all right see this is a this is
the image alright this is the image of
ganesha lord ganesha all right and
in here you can see multiple plus right
you can see multiple plus are there
do you know what is this
these these are uh basically uh the
trackers small small uh trackers the
these are feature points you could say
all right these are feature points of
the image that help us
tracks all right that helps tracking the
uh marker all right that helps track in
the marker how this help see
uh basically whenever uh
whenever we uh
upload a database all right uh in in our
database system all right
in view for you in viewforious dashboard
after you have uploaded your image
in the database all right you can you
can view the tracking points all right
this is the image from viewforia only
like
uh i
means i uh uploaded this uh image on the
database so that i could get the feature
points alright i can i will show you how
to get that feature point how to see the
feature points by yourself right
yeah in the next video only so
these feature points all right these are
some sort of patterns you could say all
right
see uh
the tracking all right the tracking
technology all right in ar basically
finds all right they they try to find
some sort of pattern all right they
these feature points are useful for
tracking and recognition
all right
means see if the
how would uh see uh if i if i had to
give an example all right you you have
created a marker already you have
successfully placed all that you
successfully place the digital object on
top of that marker
all right you have successfully placed
the detail
object on top of the marker
now
how do you think will the like if i if i
move my move my marker on onto let's say
10 units to the left side all right
how do you think the object will also
move because yeah yeah it is recognizing
the marker right it is recognizing the
marker that part is done and it has been
placed on top of that marker but
uh when we will move our our marker from
one place to another all right
how will how will the digital object
move
can you think of it
that's where the tracking helps all
right
how it helps see
the uh there are you can see the feature
points right here are the feature points
and these feature points all that these
feature points
helps the marker or it helps the app to
to track the track the marker all right
to keep the marker in track and
also move or and also move the
particular digital object
along with the marker if i am
moving alright if i am moving uh the
marker to the left uh all right let's
say i have moved 10 units to the left
all right
the same thing will happen with the
object also
because the marker has moved all right
and our app has tracked that the that
the current position of the marker is uh
10 units from the center
right
so uh our what our app has done it has
tracked and again placed it in there all
right
although if you try to move it the
object will also move with itself it
will be as
smooth like it will be really smooth so
that's how tracking is tracking helps in
market-based augmented reality all right
so
tracking
and recognition all right these two are
very fundamental and important
technology of
marker-based augmented reality all right
so
yeah i hope you have understood that
what is recognition
and what is tracking and how they are
helping in a marker-based augmented
reality all right
so
yeah the same thing it is written here
markup page augmented reality makes use
of both recognition and tracking all
right and you you and now you know
how it makes use of them right
why it makes use of them what is the use
case of them right you
know right now so
also before moving to the next section
all right
so uh do subscribe my channel all right
because it helps me uh to
bring more videos all right more uh
courses for you for free all right and
also join our discord community all
right and if you have any doubt alright
if you have any single doubt join our
discord community you can ask in there
we are
we we will be helping you in there there
are many like-minded people who are uh
who will if i am not available for some
time then they will help you to figure
your doubt
so
uh make sure to join our community and
if you have any doubt you can ask in
there all right
i would like to help and also if you uh
you can even comment alright comment
down in the comment section that what
your doubt is and i would clear that
right in there all right so
now our here is our another topic that
is marker design detection and
recognition
all right see
uh this is a this is a very basic
fundamental thing all right now
there are colorful markers also all
right but uh
to make you understand i have taken
example of a black and white marker all
right
see
basically uh
majorly all right many people
prefers to use uh like
black and white markers something like
this all right
which are basically square shaped and uh
and uh a black and white like uses black
bordered images and uh also like the
image inside those black borders are
black and other are white
so
uh basically what it does right
see the these this uh this type of
images already this type of images
helps in
image unwrapping all right
here you can see that this is a bird all
right
this is a bird all right
aft after the image unwrapping all right
after the image unwrapping technology is
applied here you can see uh
like in this image alright from this
image the face all right the white
borders are there and here is the face
it the face has been unwrapped from that
whole
sorry black borders right
so here you can see the face has been
unwrapped and it has been positioned
like this the similar thing will happen
with this bird also
all right it would be unwrapped alright
this image would be unwrapped
and then
it would be uh placed like this all
right this would be the main image so
this is how image unwrapping works all
right and image unwrapping is also a
very important concept
similarly uh here you can see this is a
uh like many people use this all right
and it this black and white image makes
it easier for the algorithm all right
makes it easier for algo for the
algorithm to do the detection uh to
uh
unwrap the image all right but there are
many powerful algorithms data that have
been designed and they can efficiently
extract or you could say unwrap the
images of unwrap the color images also
so that's why we can also use
uh colorful markers too
all right
so
yeah and even if you if you notice all
right uh if you go to uh
let me show you in here also all right
here you can see
uh
the marker already i have already told
you that this is the the marker this is
the image of the marker that i have
uploaded on viewforia's database right
for marker-based tracking
as you can see the image has been like
the texture of the image has been is
really low like the quality of the image
is really low it has been pixelated you
can literally count the pixel if you
want all right although it would be hard
because there are lacks of pixel in
there but
uh here you can see that the image has
been pixelated the quality has been
lowered all right the image is distorted
alright that's how it it helps to track
right and that's how it helps to track
it tracks pixel by pixel
it this things helps to unwrap the image
also
so
that's how my uh
marker image unwrapping works all right
it unwraps the mean mean particular
portion from the whole image
all right
so now now it's our time alright it's
our very time to understand
ar system architecture all right see if
you understand the architecture you can
even create your own ar sdks or red
marker based ar sdks although that of
course won't be easy all right because
uh for before developing any sort of sdk
you need to have a good amount of
knowledge of computer vision already
because see
augmented reality
was built upon uh computer vision only
it is it is uh you could say uh
a product all right or you can say it is
a technology of computer vision only if
computer vision
wasn't there then augmented reality also
wouldn't have been possible so come to
vision is the is the root all right it
is it is the root of
uh augmented reality so it is really
important see if you want to create your
own uh
ar sdks all right if you want to create
your own ai sdk
you need to have a good knowledge of
computer vision you need to know the
algorithms all right even i'm learning
computer vision for augmented reality so
i can get a more deeper understanding of
how these things work all right i have a
like i currently have a decent
understanding all right i i understand
how these things work but i don't know
how to
uh develop these things all right what
algorithms are used so for that i need
to learn computer vision
so i'm also learning that so it is very
important for you all right if you want
to develop your own sdk you have to
learn computer vision all right so
without any
more talk say let's start
with uh understanding the uh ar system
architecture
all right see
in this architecture you can see there
is a camera all right then uh from the
camera the image is passed all right uh
image is passed to the
tracking module all right some things
happen in there all that will understand
what things happen in there all right
then it is passed uh to the rendering
module where the real world and the
virtual uh objects are combined in the
rendering module all right and the
augmented uh augmented output all right
the output is passed through the
rendering module to the display
all right so this is this is how it
works you can see the diagram all right
like like if i if i had to show you like
this all right
uh
pen
first of all it is uh moving from here
and there
uh then from here
it is going to here alright
then from here
it is literally going to the rendering
module and this all right this virtual
module
is
adding all right this virtual module is
adding to the uh
real world component all right um sorry
for this bad handwriting but this is rc
means real world component all right and
real world component and real world
component sorry virtual component and
real world component
are like
actually attached all right uh the real
world uh the virtual component uh is
attached to the real world and then the
output all right then the output is
generated that is the augmented image
all right and after that
it is being displayed in in your systems
display
all right
so
this is it that's how it is working
all right
now if we talk about understand the
module all right see if we talk about
you already know what is the camera
right what this camera module does right
because it it renders like it renders
the
image of a real world all right into
your phone that's what a camera does but
uh what is the capturing module all
right see the things that you see from
your mobile camera right you cannot even
capture it right you can even capture it
so uh through the camera some sort of
image is passed
to your display all right and when you
click on that centered button available
in your
mobile camera
software when you click that it is
captured right so the capturing module
basically helps to capture the image all
right basically it helps to capture the
video or the other image all right so
this is what capturing module does
now if we talk about the tracking module
all right see the tracking module is the
core
all right the tracking module
uh is the core
and if we talk about uh
see
the tr how tracking module works now it
it calculates all right it calculates
the pose already of the camera all right
in the real time all right like it will
uh calculate where your camera is
and if i talk about uh fovs all right
that is six degree of freedom
it means that uh you have a freedom of
uh to look anywhere already you could
this is a very basic definition of uh
six dofs all right
see what this
term pose does let me tell you
uh pose estimation all right basically
helps uh helps to get the orientation
and location all right get the
orientation and location of
of a particular object
this is what the tracking module does
all right it is basically the code
alright it helps to calculate the
pos pose of the camera all right
in real time it's not like he uh
it will uh only capture once then it
won't do it again it happens in loop so
the pose estimation is
done and also because of that we get the
3d location or you can say the
orientation of any sort of object
that is the work of tracking module
all right if we talk about the rendering
module
all right see
uh what this rendering module does is
basically it uh combines all it it
combines the digital object all right it
combines the digital object
with the real world visual all right
with the real world image
right if you if you you have used any
sort of augmented reality
you might have seen that right that some
3d object is appearing on sort of on any
marker
right
on an image a 3d object is occurring
so
a virtual uh a virtual basically a
virtual component
is being attached with that image and
then
it is being processed and
pushed forward for the display all right
and
if you are confused already if you conf
if you are confused about these uh
modules don't worry all right we are
again going to look into another all
right this is a very much more
simplified version
all right
this is a much more simplified version
of that ar system architecture i have
included this because i thought that for
the first for the first iteration i
think people will get confused that how
this like what did i explain to you you
might not understand it right so i have
also included another architecture all
right the same thing happens in here
also but i will re-explain
see in here all right a live video feed
all right
is going through the camera
all right to the image capturing module
all right and it is alright and it is
divided uh in frames
the the video is divided in frames and
then it is going through the image
processing mode module all right and in
there
in there the marker is detected and
tracked all right
means uh in there the marker is detected
actually all the processing is done all
right all the post calculation is done
and then we go to the marker tracking
module all right where the post
calculation is generally done and all
the tracking
stuffs are being done in there only all
right all the uh what can i say
those are virtual points right those
feature points are applied in the image
in there only uh the pose calculation is
there only see if you are confused about
ports pose calculation
don't worry all right uh let me explain
it to you again suppose calculation is
basically it calculates the position all
right it calculates the position
of any object all right that's what pose
calculation is it calculates the
orientation of the object and
the location of the object all right so
that's what pose calculation is and then
after all these processing and tracking
is done it is passed to the rendering
module all right the virtual object
all right the that the virtual object
that we want to augment all right
that we want to augment
is combined with the real world image
all right the virtual object is combined
with the real world image
then
then it is passed to the display screen
and we actually see the output on our
displays so that's how this ar system
architecture works all right i hope you
are clear with the concept
right
again the same definitions all right the
image capturing module that takes the
images it
breaks it to frame by frame then
and all those
things are that are being done then
there is image processing module already
the processing that are being done all
right means the detection or you could
say the recognition techniques are being
applied in there all right
then if we uh talk about the marker
tracking module in there the position is
being calculated all right
the position is being calculated and
then feature points are provided
and uh the rendering module all right
this rendering what this rendering
module is doing this rendering module is
basically
uh
combining the virtual object to the
digital object this is just it all right
it is doing that
and yeah
that's it
so
that is that's it for our today's
lecture and i hope you have understood
alright i hope you understood uh how all
these things work all right i hope you
have understood how the market based ar
system architecture works all right
so i don't think now it would be any
problem as you have uh as i have cleared
all the very basics or the very basics
of marker-based augmented reality now i
don't think it would
would be any problem learning marker
based ar development
in this lecture i'm going to tell you
how to uh set up your unity and euphoria
engine for developing ar applications
and later on in this video only we'll be
creating our very first augmented
reality application
with
unity
and euphoria so
yeah the very first thing you have to do
is go to this website
developer.viewfourier.com
all right and in there you have to
create your
account after creating your account all
right you can see
right in the top that
there's a download section click on that
particular section and you will be
redirected to this page all right and
in this page all right you are seeing
multiple options and the uh yesterday
only
like in 15 november
uh the latest version of v4d engine has
got released that is 10.3 view 4d engine
10.3 all right you can even uh select
your particular version
right from here already that is 9.8 or
18.3
uh i have seen one problem
that is uh when using any version of
any 10 uh
like any view fourier version of
10 uh
i am facing an error in unity uh so i
would suggest using 2020 only all right
for this
course because i'm going to use the
latest version of euphoria and uh
now you have to download the sdk all
right what is an sdk sdk is the software
development kit that will help us to
develop for uh
means ar applications with unity and
euphoria right so we have to download
our uh
sdk now here you can see there are
multiple options available all right uh
let's say you don't want to develop with
unity alright you don't want to develop
your marker based ar application with
unity you can go for android studio or
if you want to do it for ios you can uh
that is xcode you can you can download
for ios then there is a uwp then
there is uh
lumen so
you uwp is a basically universal windows
platform so uh you can use that too so
for uh for this course all right for
this for the sake of this course we are
going to use
um
view fourier engine alright the very
first option that you are getting that
add view for the engine to a unity
project or upgrade to the latest version
so just simply uh click on it all right
and uh some things will be loading up in
here all right and then click on agree
i'm going to decline it because i have
already downloaded uh the
sdk but you can you have to click i
agree and then download the sdk all
right so yeah after downloading it all
right
after downloading what i would suggest
is first let's set up the web version
all right like set up all the things
from the website
right and then after that
we'll be moving towards unity so how to
do that right so
now we have to get uh into another page
that is this develop section all right
remember you have to create your account
first to uh get all this thing so do
create your account so now click on this
develop i've already opened it on my
second window and here we go
so here you can see uh there are target
manager license manager so what are
these two the license manager actually
helps us to manage the licenses all
right licenses means there are some
particular lines of code all right there
are some particular lines of code code
you could say some special unique code
that helps view fourier to connect with
the backend server and verify actually
uh what kind of uh services are we using
right like uh i'm going to use the uh
basic uh service of euphoria that is
free so
yeah all right so that uh
that uh basically
uh particular key actually uh we call
that a key that
that particular key would help us
actually to uh connect to the viewforia
portal all right from our unity all
right so that our app can utilize the
features that we uh get
after uh using the different versions of
euphoria that is basic premium all right
any of these two versions so yeah now uh
the very first thing we have to do is we
have to create our
license so how would we do that see uh
you can even buy the premium version but
i don't i don't have the money to buy it
so i would uh simply get the basic all
right i would click on the basic all
right and uh
it would load some sort of page so as
you can see it right here it is loading
some page
and uh in that page all right uh
keep your license name all right let's
say i want to uh name it to view first
first
ar
app
all right this should be the
name for my license and here you can see
this these are the things and uh
we have to check this box all right we
have to check this box and after that uh
click on confirm all right and that
would uh
redirect uh that would create actually
our um
license and we can click on that and
then simply go uh
go to that license and copy the license
for us
right so i would simply click on the
license all right i would simply click
on that license
and here we go we go uh it copied uh it
got copied in our
clipboard now another important thing
that we have to do is we we have to go
to the target manager right just click
on the target manager
see what uh this target manager does is
it helps us
uh keep the markers all right see i've
already told you that in market based ar
we need markers and we have to store
like store it somewhere right so uh
the target manager uh helps
uh keep track of the marker on the
servers of euphoria and also we have to
download a unity package for that so
that we can include it on our
unity means local uh local computer
right so how would we do that so for
this simply you have to click on add
database
right and then you have to uh name your
database let's say uh
first ar app right
first
first ar
app
uh oh i missed that r
no worries
yeah so then i have to click create all
right
and
then uh
turn it on then then
go to that particular target
and you have to upload your target in
there like means the marker image
so that we can use it right and i would
show you some other things also so that
you can choose your right marker all
right uh choose the right marker for
your application it's really important
to get the right marker because if the
marker is of low quality then
marker based ar won't work well so
that's why right so click on add target
all right so i i already have some
images so i'll be choosing from that now
here are three other options all right
uh we won't be looking it
now all right so just uh click on the
single image all right basically a
single image is selected by default so
no worries but then you have to click on
browse you have to choose an image all
right you have to choose a
image
so
yeah here we got an image of a car all
right
uh
i don't have any other image so i'm
gonna use that one and you can give any
width you want all right so my uh i
would like prefer to give six basically
what would happen now that uh the width
you give all right it would uh get
that particular units of width in uh the
unity engine right so uh remember that
that won't be like
give any sort of difference so i want to
name it marker
all right
so then click on add
and now it's uploading our target all
right it's uploading our target
and that's really cool
so let it do its job
cool now as our
means marker is has been added i want to
show you some other things also so to
get those things click on the marker
right click on the on the marker
it would redirect you to the marker
properties you could say that
so
then i'm going to show you some very
important things all right and
that would give you an understanding
that what sort of marker you should use
and what sort of marker you should not
use for your marker based ar
applications all right
so as you can see here all right in the
in the
if you can see in the right side there
are multiple texts right type single
image status active target id
augmentable all right this is the
section that this is the text we want to
focus on as of now
what this tells us five star means this
image is very good already it it is
going to be superb for uh
tracking
now see remember always that
three uh the range between three to five
star is okay all right below uh below it
won't give you good results even three
sometimes won't work that great so
always remember to take a picture all
right always remember to take a picture
that is that has got four to five rating
all right four to five star rating and
it's really really really important all
right so
uh yeah
so now
as we have seen that what sort of marker
we should use so we should use remember
we all we always should use a marker
that is really good now you have to
click on this uh show features option
all right i'm going to
see
here you can see that remember that
slide that uh that uh in that slide
there was uh a ganesha's picture and
there was some dots in it so you can
call those as tracking points all right
those are known as tracking points with
the help of these the marker actually
tracks the marker and helps to put it up
on the
marker right so uh yeah
this is these are the details that you
need to know all right and now uh
another thing we have to do all right
another thing we have to do is to
download this database and then after
that we are going to set up our unity
engine all right we are going to work on
our unity engine
so first of all
let uh let the scene load let the scene
load
all right and uh then
click on this download database all
right
and here you are going to find two
options that your android should export
or visual studio but of course we aren't
working on any of them so we are going
to choose unity editor right we are
going to choose this unity editor and
then simply click on download so it is
compiling our database as of now all
right after it is done compiling
uh we are we are uh
going to save that file and uh then
we are moving towards unity right so
yeah that's cool so now
just click on save all right and our
unity package uh will be downloaded just
as you can see it has got downloaded so
let's move towards unity
so as uh we have uh created our
viewforia
assets that is we have created our
marker and set it a set at i have set a
target so now we have to
actually change our platform so how
would we do that right see uh
basically we are developing ar
application
for uh
our mobile right for our mobile devices
that is android devices so what are we
going to do see uh currently currently
if i if i show you as you can see in the
top the the
currently we can develop for pc mac and
linux standalone right
that's what we can develop for but we
have to develop it for android so what
we have to do it's fairly simple all
right just go to this file all right
then click on build settings
now here you are seeing multiple options
that is pc mac and linux standalone and
the unity logo you are seeing here it
means this particular thing is active
all right now if i click on android
you are getting multiple options don't
look at that as of now all right you can
uh actually
take a look uh at that afterwards uh
this uh whole lecture all right you can
try it out by yourself
but we have what we have to do is we
have to click switch platform but let's
say you don't want to develop for
android you have an ios device so you
can
click on ios also uh see
these things won't work if you haven't
installed the ios module alright i'm on
a windows laptop so uh it doesn't makes
any sense
to
install uh
uh basically to install basically ios
module uh in unity so i haven't done
that uh but i have android ones right so
what i'm going to do is i'm going to uh
click on android and then switch
platform it's simple as that what it
will do is it would uh make our unity uh
means it would uh give the
means it would give the power to unity
to develop for android so just click on
switch platform and it would start doing
its work all right and after it gets
switched uh i will return back with uh
with the next section
so now
uh basically our platform has been
converted to android or you could say
shift it to android now we have to
import our sdk and one tip i would like
to give you guys is that
before all right if you are developing
for any platform let's say you are
developing for android only or ios only
always remember
first change the platform then import
anything you want
because after importing all right uh
this happens to me a lot like still it
happens what happens uh is basically uh
i do the development all right let's say
i'm doing doing it for android all right
i do the development and later on when
uh i noticed that i haven't shifted
to android platform
and you know when uh
after half of the things are done
multiple modules will be there multiple
assets will be there in your unity
and when you will shift that now it
would take a hell of time so remember
whenever starting with unity if you are
going to change platform do it do it at
the first then only import any asset
module or anything you want alright
because it would reload all the script
things it would recompile it would uh
make the assets compatible for android
and all those things background
processors going on so always remember
to do that right and now it's our fair
time all right to import the sdk so how
we do that two steps means two methods
are there that is first of all simply
open that whole folder all right open
this folder and simply
drag and drop all right simply simply
drag and drop it in
here all right one way is this another
way uh
is to basically
right click import package custom
package
then import it all right it's uh simple
as that
well so now
uh as uh as that whole processing thing
is done now we have got an another
window all right basically this is the
package window all right
don't worry about anything here and just
click on import all right and it would
import your uh view for your module and
into unity all right and give it its
time so that it can do so all right
and also when it says something like
this
what you have to do is click on update
all right and it would again start
means resume with the importing uh
stuffs
so guys
now our view fourier engine has been
imported all right and one of the uh
very good things all right actually uh
there's a problem with sometimes uh it
occurs or what happens is that uh
sometimes when you import uh euphoria
right uh unity fails to compile it or
something like that some sort of like
that happens all right and your uh view
for a engine doesn't get imported
successfully so how would you check that
your v4 engine has been imported
successfully
right so what you can do is click on the
hierarchy panel right click
and out of all these uh
default options you will get a new set
of option that is view fourier engine
and that's when you know that we you
have successfully imported v4 engine and
if not all right maybe
due to some problem you ha you wasn't
you weren't able to import it
successfully what you can do is reimport
it as simple as that and i'm sure that
that would fix your problem
right
another thing all right uh
uh do you remember when we uh create our
created our marker database in the
target manager in developer.veforia.com
we downloaded another unity package all
right so what that what is that unity
package
that unity package contains the markers
all right and we have to import that
unity package all right so
again uh previously i showed you uh the
drag and drop method now i'm going to
show you the right click method so click
on the project panel
right click all right all right simply
simply just right click
click on import package
custom package
all right and then
get that marker package the uh the my
marker packages name is fast ar app so
i'm going to
import it
all right
so again the same steps you will get a
window like this and click on import and
your files
will be imported
so now as we have imported our
asset all right uh so now as we have
imported our marker database and also
the view fourier engine sdk now it's
time it's our very time to develop our
own ar application right
so how do we do that the very first
thing all right the very first thing our
viewforia developer
does
delete the main camera we don't need
that main camera all right
because that main camera is meant for uh
virtual rendering all right it is only
for virtual rendering not real plus
virtual
what euphoria does is viewforia is
really good and he provides us
an ar camera built into it so just right
click in the hierarchy click on view
fourier engine
and then click on ar camera
and here we go
you got an ar camera now this camera is
going to work
for augmented reality that is it is
going to capture the real world and put
the digital object in the real world
all right and that's what we wanted now
remember we copied our license
previously uh
during the web part all right when we're
covering covering the web part
we are going to need that license
so just click on ar camera in the
inspector menu yeah you are going to get
this open viewforia engine configuration
all right in the view for your vf script
click on that
you are going to get something like this
all right and click on uh in this app
license key section right this is the
main section so what i'm going to do is
don't click this button it would
redirect you to that website and you
have to create another license but we
have already created our license right
so i'm going to just
paste that license
right and voila
viewforia got the license
right so yeah that's cool now as we have
done the very basic setups all right see
uh in this in this one i'm not go not
going to uh
tell you how to create advanced v4 app
this is just a setup video and
this is a video of how we set up our
viewforia and also uh
we'll be creating our very first
ar application with euphoria all right
so unity is doing its processes so
let it do it it's taking some time but
don't worry yeah it's done now what we
have to do is we have to right click
again go to view fourier engine and now
see in marker based uh as i already told
that we need markers so how would we add
those markers in unity so right click
view fourier engine then there's
something known as image target click on
that all right and you will get
another game object known as
image target
right
now i know you might not uh
see if i if i zoom it to you you will be
seeing it totally white
now believe me uh
uh this one uh
we have a fix for this right see by
default unity uses
image type that we have to uh specify
from unity only this that is image
uploaded in unity but as we already have
a database all right we already remember
we made a database we made a target
manager database so we are going to use
that so click on the image target all
right go to this inspector menu and you
will find something called image target
behavior all right don't look into
another other options we are going to
explore these options in our next
like in project videos or next videos so
what we are going to do is
click on this type
uh
selection menu all right and from here
you would find multiple things cloud
record basically cloud record what it
does it it fetches the data from cloud
that is the images from cloud and here
is from database that we uploaded in our
unity all right and now uh we have
selected our database now we have to
select which database alright maybe we
have multiple database in our ar
application so we can we have to select
it that is our first erf and voila it
will automatically get you the
first marker
the very first marker available in the
database so we have this marker
available in the database right
so as simple as that
nothing too complicated
now
what we have to do is
all right now what we have to do
we have to right click again all right
see i'm not going to include any 3d
models right now all right yeah we'll be
doing that in our future videos but as
of now this is only a setup video so
just
add a 3d object all right add your
favorite 3d object
there's no favorite one of mine so i'm
just going to add a cube
yeah
and
voila a cube got added now reset it
transform alright reset its transform so
it's back to zero all right
and put it up a bit
right put it up a bit and
voila you got your cube
now
if you play this all right if you play
this scene
the cube will be there right the marker
won't perform its functions why
because uh you haven't put this cube
inside of this image target so that's
what we have to do we have to make the
3d model that we are using the child of
the image target all right so now we are
good to go
all right
that's cool right
one of the good things of unity uh and
euphoria is that you can test viewfordia
on your pc only so how would we do that
uh just click on play button alright and
it would
start the camera
all right
nothing to complicate it so let's do
that
so now if i put the camera all right i
mean
if i if i basically put the marker right
in front of the camera right uh it would
start tracking the cube it would uh
start showing the cube all right just
see it in here
right uh you can you can see it clearly
right now if i remove it all right you
can see that the cube is staying here
all right now this is a feature that
called extended tracking of uni uh for
euphoria only but uh it is useful also
but not in this case so i'm gonna remove
it how would you remove that
all right just get out of the play mode
all right uh so i got out of the play
mode uh click on image target
then here is a in the the default
observer event handler only here you are
seeing multiple or an option that is
tracked or extended tracked so what i
want you is to select only tracked all
right and what would do uh what it would
do is it would set uh like it won't uh
now it won't have the feature all right
now it won't have the feature of
extended tracking all right let me
show you by entering the play mode all
right
now if i uh if i show you all right just
just check it out in here
see the cube is here right i the cube is
here now as soon as i remove it
all right as soon as i remove it
the
cube goes away right
see the cube goes away so this works
much better if you try it on android all
right
so i would recommend you to build that
application i would also show you how to
do that all right
i would recommend you to build that uh
android application and then
try to try it out on your android phone
so and
i guess you all are happy all right you
created your first ar application i know
that this is a cube but the project will
be doing
is going to be really interesting all
right it is going to be really really
really interesting
so
now to build our viewforia application
what you have to do see i i already told
you in the very first video of
installing
unity you have to have the android
module open jdk all right ndk and all
those things so that you can make the
things work right you can build your
application that if you don't have that
then it would be a problem all right and
now what you have to do is
go to asset all right now the scene all
right uh the scene we are on is known as
sample scene all right we are using the
sample scene and in here
in in this particular
section you have to add that scene all
right you can just click on add open
scenes like it would add the scenes that
are currently open my sample scene is
open i can
simply click uh add open scenes you can
even add uh it by drag and drop
right it's as simple as that but uh as
uh now we have added alright remember
without adding the scene
if you build that application it
won't work out right so it's really
important to include the scene you are
working on
then click on build
all right
then
just click on build
and then
name your application i want to name it
test
all right and then click on save
it would start building building your
application
in this particular section of the video
i'm going to tell you about some of the
free resources that you can use uh in
your development all right see as a
exact developer
i need 3d models animations all the time
all right and these resources are a life
saver believe me like when i started or
see i am not a 3d modeler all right when
i started i didn't knew about these
things but i got to knew over time and
believe me these resources have helped
me a lot and one of the resource
is
sketchfab see sketchfab is a really good
place to find your 3d model alright see
if you if you want a 3d model of a car
you can just search for it you will get
multiple 3d models for free all right
there will be paid 3d models free 3d
models too you can get your own
all right
so sketchfab is a really great place if
you want some other options all right if
you want some other options also there
is uh another that is cg cg trader i
guess its name is cg trader then there
is turbo squid all right boost code is
there there some some sort of free 3d
models are available also there are also
available in there
but what i prefer the prefer most is
sketchfab sketchfab has a lot of 3d
models available for free so i'd suggest
whenever you're looking for a 3d model
go to sketchfab this is from where i get
my 3d models all right
so here's another resource that is known
as turbo squid i already told about it
to you but let me show you see this is
another website from where you can get
multiple 3d models for free and also for
paid all right you can get it from here
it has multiple 3d models of 3ds like it
you can get blender 3d models cinema 4d
models maya models 3dx
models obj models all right similarly
you can get cars models of multiple cars
you can get models of multiple
characters you can get models of animals
then there is of vehicles you can search
for any model you want all right so this
is another very useful resource that you
should have a note on
this is another resource that you can
make use of this is known as ready
player dot me see if you want avatars
all right if you want avatars for your
uh games let's say you want your own
avatar you can go to this website uh go
to this website and make your own avatar
based on you all right you can make your
own play playable characters with this
ready player dot me all right this is a
really good avatar creation engine even
if you want to
um
build your own uh like if you want to
implement all right if you want to
implement this ready player dot me
avatar engine they also have a unity
plugin for it so you can check that out
too
all right
the thing that you are currently seeing
is a is a output all right uh there is a
3d model
that i customized all right that i
customized so there's a 3d model that i
customized and even you can make your
own
avatar
so here comes another website all right
from where you can get a lot of free 3d
models all right there's a really great
website i prefer this one too all right
my next uh
means after sketchfab my next choice is
alwaysfree3d.com you can uh
don't worry if if you are
if you want these links all right i will
provide a link down below all right i
will provide all the links of the
website that i am using down in the
description or description box and also
i would also create a
pdf of it and
upload it on my course website all right
so you can check the links from there
also
so free 3d is also a really great
website from where you can get a lot of
free 3d models so this is also one of my
choice
here is another website alright known as
nasa 3d
here you can get all the free resources
from nasa all right the i guess all the
models in here are totally for free you
can get all the models uh free uh models
related to space all right related to
nasa at this place all right i would
provide the link down below so this is
another great platform where you can get
the 3d models it also provides you
textures all right so this is a really
great place
so this is another website known as
render hub from here also you can get a
lot of 3d models both paid and
free so you can search any model you
want all right and i'm pretty sure that
you might get
those models
in here all right even sketchfab is also
there i already showed you turbo squid
is there then there is free 3d now comes
render hub 2.
all right
so this is another resource all right
this is known as 3d leashes
so it can if you want any sort of low
poly household items you can get all the
things from this website uh this
particular 3d website so this is a
really great platform also so you can
simply go into this website and download
your 3d mode
here's another resource known as
opengamer.org
this is a really great website if you
want to have
free assets all right free ui assets for
your application you can go to this
website all right if you want uh if you
are making any game this website is also
going to be really helpful for you for
getting the ui assets for free all right
so it contains both paid and free assets
this is another website known as
archive3d.net
all right from this website you can get
any 3d model totally for free all right
now none of these models available in
here are paid so there are free models
means
the models that are available in this
website are totally for free so you can
also visit this website and search for
your models
here comes another free resource known
as mixamo this free resource is provided
by
uh adobe you can add animations to your
humanoid 3d models and there's a really
great website that you should look for
yeah this website lags a bit all right
but there's a really great website from
where i get animations for my 3d models
all right
so here's another resource all right
this is going to be the last resource of
the video that i'm showing alright but
there are plenty of more resources
available over the internet all right
i would include all the additional
resources that you might need also in
the
i would also add them in the
pdf alright that i'm going to share with
you all right and to get the pdf you can
simply uh
search for like search for it in the
description below in the uh video and
also
you can get that from the course website
all right so this is this is another
website that says smithsonian
digitization all right this is also a
really good uh website for getting 3d
models as you can see here there are
many models available like of like
skeleton of triceratops then skeleton of
mammoths then there is orbiter space
shuttle model is also available so you
can there's also a really great resource
all right so this much for this video
in this lecture we are going to look
into multiple tracking all right so this
is basically a feature of euphoria where
you can track multiple markers at the
same time all right it's it's a this one
is really useful whenever you are making
uh an ar book all right
whenever you are making games so these
this feature uh helps a lot all right
like for example if you are going to
make an ar pokemon game right so
with within one mobile there will be one
there will be two cards and you would be
scanning those card and make and two
pokemons would appear and you would make
those two pokemons fight each other all
right so
multiple uh market tracking helps a lot
in many ways all right and in today's
today's lecture only i'm going to show
you all right so
first of all uh i want you to set up
your euphoria account your sd case all
right you already know how to do that i
have shown you in my previous video so
if you are confused
you can watch it watch that particular
portion again and uh if you have any
doubt you can comment it down in the
comment section all right so without any
further delay let's get started the very
first thing you have to do is click on
this main camera and delete it all right
because of course we don't want the main
camera and uh one more thing i would
like to do is to stack up
stack this game window or to the side
all right to the side of my scene window
so that i can uh see whatever
thing is happening all right so
yeah
so
just wait a few seconds all right cool
here you can see that it has been
written no camera is rendering that's
because we don't have any camera so now
we do what you have to do is click on
hierarchy uh go click on view fourier
engine and select ar camera all right uh
so you can keep it like this or you can
stack it up uh on top of directional
light i prefer stacking up on uh
directional light it feels better
actually looks good actually so that's
why it's just a personal preference
alright and now what you have to do is
uh click on i means right click then
again uh click on image target all right
select a marker right from here click
in the image started behavior click on
from database and select the database my
day for for my uh case the database is
first ar app all right and
the marker i'll be using for this is m1
and let's name the image target as m1
all right because i'm using uh the m1
marker all right so
yeah so here we got our very first
marker all right i would be placing the
3d models later on first let's set up
our second marker so again right click
click on view fourier engine click on
image target all right then again name
it m2 all right
so then again
in the inspector window only you will
get a
type selected from database then select
the database that is first arf in my
case and uh
take this uh
m2
marker that i have all right so you can
uh you will get the marker what you have
named after all right so
make sure you do that now we have two
markers in in place now the problem with
that is if we if we try to
show one marker all right if we try to
show one marker at a time then uh means
let's let's uh say for an example all
right uh i'm using this app alright and
now i want to show uh that
total how many means i i'm trying to uh
means track both the markers at the same
time all right
so i'm trying to do that and uh of
course that wouldn't work all right so
to figure out uh this problem
we have a solutions all right so
currently the problem we are facing is
uh it will only track one marker at a
time all right but we want to track both
the markers at a time all right so we
are going we are going to go to that
feature but first of all let's uh set up
our 3d models all right
so
right click or not right click uh i
already have the 3d models all right i
have the uh i have one dinosaur 3d model
so i'm just going to import it right in
here all right uh let me reset its uh
transform all right so here we actually
got
the dinosaur i know it doesn't looks
that good i just
uh choose one random from
sketchfab these are objs and
believe me i don't uh want you to like
use obj files all right i want you to
use
uh
gltf files because they have better
quality
better texture quality and all those
things all right
that's that's the major reason
but for the sake of this tutorial and to
make things work first fast so i go
got to go for uh this obj model all
right now there are some materials all
right so i will create the materials
it's uh it's pretty simple here you can
see there are multiple materials in here
albedo so what you can do is uh right
click in the
texture section and create a dinosaur
material
so here i create a darkness of material
now if i try to find where is uh
exactly the
means this is the normal map right this
is uh
the albedo one already so i found albedo
one drag and drop it in uh here all
right and
drag this on top of this now this this
one looks uh looks pretty good all right
so now
i need i also need to add the
normal map so that it uh gives a better
look all right so
yeah it's it's uh looking
really really great so i uh currently
have click on fix now because it is not
being marked as a normal map so what uh
the what this fixing process would do is
it will uh fix that uh
texture to a normal map all right so
just just wait for a few seconds and uh
this process would be done all right now
let's let's see
we have ambient occlusion we have
metallic texture so uh let's apply the
metallic texture first all right so here
we got the metallic texture but uh
actually let's remove the smoothness
all right then
here we have the roughness all right uh
so
and uh then
where is it
yeah there's another albedo one this is
uh maybe for the eye so i'm not going to
go into that much so uh for now this
this thing looks good all right so just
uh
as our model is ready so what you have
to do is uh put this model
under the hood of
m1 that is make it a game object of m1
marker all right so for now our this
this model is set up now
again we have another uh
model that is of a cake
i uh like i was thinking to take another
dinosaur model but then i thought let's
let's take a cake how many dinosaurs
would be there
right uh so
now i need to bring the scale up all
right so i'm going to make it 50
50 sorry
and here goes another 50. all right so
this this seems uh pretty big um
so i would scale it down a bit so uh
don't worry
okay yeah this this uh this thing looks
good all right
okay cool
now i wanted to save this all right uh
save this and uh simply drag and drop
this inside the m2 all right so
yeah
so now uh
here uh one thing we would be seeing is
all right one problem we will be seeing
is that
whenever all right whenever we are going
to like play uh the scene
what would happen is uh we only one
marker will be detected alright if we
give if we feed it two markers all right
then it will only detect one of it
because uh we haven't set up the
settings that is needed right so that's
what we have to do or click on ar camera
all right then click on open view for
your configuration
all right
so here you can see here multiple
options and
the one that would be uh our preference
is that this one maximum size
simultaneous tracked images all right so
and there's another one maximum a
simultaneous tracked object so basically
the first of all let me tell you what
the this
two does basically the uh currently you
can see
uh one is written there alright and that
means only one marker or only one object
would be detected all right at a time so
what we have to do is uh we have to
increase it to how many uh like to harm
to as many as
as many numbers as we want all right
like let's say if we want our app to
detect four markers at a single time
right so we can uh write it four in
there all right or if we want it to
track four objects at one time then we
can write uh four in the object section
but for for for this course we are only
uh like we aren't exploring the tracked
objects portion all right so we are
going to explore those maximum
simultaneous tracked images so what you
can do is currently it is one just
simply change it to two all right so
that's how it's uh it's going to work
all right
so it's pretty simple as that there's
nothing
much to like exactly scare about all
right but yeah this is uh
this is it right see uh the thing that i
would like to say is
whenever all right uh
generally generally uh whenever we
actually like
create ar books we
don't usually uh keep making
means we don't usually track two to
three images at one time we just track
one images at a time all right and
that's what i would recommend you to
track one images at a time because then
that would make it more efficient all
right or else uh the the ui might get
cluttery if you if you don't manage it
in that way all right and that gets a
bit more complicated so i always
recommend people to
uh like for ar books all right for
specifically ar books try to use only
one marker uh means
set the maximum sample antennas tracked
images to one because at that point uh
you guys will want or to exactly use
already to exactly use
one marker at a time all right so
let me show you all right let me show
you
um just just see this now all right so
we have uh
we are able to just
oh yeah we got it so we are able to see
that uh at at a single time all right we
are able to detect two markers all right
so that is what how it works all right
so i
i would recommend you to try uh play
with this this features feature more all
right so that uh you explore more new
things all right um
so yeah that that's it
so that's it for today's lecture all
right so see you in the next lecture
thank you
in this particular section of the video
we are going to look into
virtual buttons
so virtual buttons are another way all
right are another way to add buttons in
your
view for your application all right you
there are two types of buttons that you
can add first of all ui buttons all
right like uh using simple canvas and
those buttons in world space all right
you can do that
another
another way is that is to use virtual
buttons all right
so in this tutorial we are going to look
into the virtual buttons
uh and before starting all right before
starting with virtual buttons there are
some rules to be followed all right some
suggestions some rules that are needed
to be followed
the very first thing all right the very
first thing that should be kept in mind
that the size of the button alright the
size of the button should be equal or
greater than 10
all right
of the overall target area
always remember that
the size of the button should be
equal or at least all right at least 10
percent
of the overall target area all right
now if the like
if the area is 100
then the 10 uh the button should be at
least the size of 10 percent of that
area all right that's it
another thing all right another thing
that is
always all right always try to place the
button all right always try to place the
button
where the place is reach with feature
points all right
see in the introduction video i already
uh showed you how to check for feature
points and
open the viewfor your website and look
for where the feature point is much
greater all right where the quantity of
feature points is much greater and
always place the button there all right
another thing is that
uh insert
insert the buttons all right
what does that means
that means uh is that don't
make the buttons all right don't make
the buttons touch the image target
borders all right the borders of the
image target so
always
uh
give some padding in the button from the
outer side all right so sorry from a
margin in the button from the outside
all right so always remember that so
always insert the button so that they
don't touch the borders of the image
target
another and the last point is
don't stack the buttons upon each other
all right what does that mean see when
you are viewing all right when you are
viewing
uh
from some point all right when you are
viewing
the image target from
a particular point
you would see all right
you would see
that
if you place those buttons on top of
each other all right you won't be able
to reach
the uh second button it would be really
like it would be really hard to get uh
to the second button so don't ever stack
the buttons upon each other all right so
that's it
so
let's start the development of our
virtual button let's implement it
see
uh i would like to mention is that i'm
using the same project all right the
same previous project that i used to
uh
develop the what like show you the very
initial steps of euphoria
all right
so i'm using the same project so i i
haven't had changed my license key and
my database although if you want you can
do so all right it's totally upon you if
you want you can do so you can even
create a new project for implementing
virtual buttons
i am doing this because i want to keep
all the
source code
at one place and provide provided to you
all right so it won't be cluttered up
so
yeah let's get started the very first
thing alright the very first thing is
you have to delete the main camera
and then add a ar camera
select view fourier engine and click on
ar camera so
let me uh place it on top of the
directional light
don't worry it won't have any sort of
effect so it is totally upon me now i
have placed my ar camera
another thing is to add the image target
now the image target would be same as
the previous one because i haven't
changed my image target
but you can do so if you want all right
now if i click on image target
here i get my image target now
let me uh
select the database
so i'm going to select from database and
now i'm going to select the database
that is first ar
here is the marker that is selected all
right now what i want
what i want is to create a 3d cube all
right i would show you why just wait for
a second let me reset the transform of
it
so as i've reseted the transform i'm
going to uh
place it
at the back all right i'm going to place
it at the back
so
see i'm using shortcut keys q w e all
right q for uh the this hand tool uh w
for this uh
anchor tool and e for the rotational
tool and r for the scale tool all right
so these are some shortcuts
so uh i'm using those shortcuts all
right if you think how am i getting this
then yeah that's how i'm getting it
now
uh this cube looks a bit dull right like
it doesn't have any sort of colors it's
totally white and i don't like it
so let's create a material for it all
right now
uh
in this i'm also going to show you how
to add textures to your material all
right and i have already imported a
texture i have downloaded downloaded
from 3d textures dot me
all right the links are given in the
ar resources file you can check them out
all right it is available on my website
now let me show you the textures
here are the textures all right and i'm
going to tell you how to implement it
now this is not a texture this is just
an overview file so you can check how
this how the cube will look but
i'm
directly going to implement it all right
so first of all delete this uh
delete this particular material we don't
need it
all right
so
and another thing all right another
thing is that
first of all create
a material all right create a material
let's name it textured
textured
box or let's say
cube
all right this is what i will name it
after that
what i want you is to
go to the inspector panel all right go
to the inspector panel and
select the textures you want
so what i will simply do is i will click
on albedo
it would pop up a panel now i have to
find all right i have to find a texture
i want
now
i'll find a texture
that that has been named as baseline all
right
so it's not showing the full name just
wait
let me lock it
cool now from here i can find
what textures i want so for the very
first thing uh in here i have to get
a base color texture all right this one
this is i'm going to put this in the
albedo section
all right
now you might not see uh the
effects in here
all right you might not see that because
we haven't applied the materials
so just drag and drop the material in
here and see it has been applied in the
cube i know
it has
the texture has been applied but it
doesn't looks good but
you won't say this after
watching the whole
material uh applying thing
all right now
and here's there is another section that
is metallic now let's
find
a
metallic texture so here i got a
metallic texture all right
so see uh it's not like i'm identifying
these textures it is just written in the
end of the names
now i would adjust the settings a bit
all right
i would adjust the settings a bit
uh see you won't uh like you won't like
it as of now the reason is i haven't
applied other materials that that's why
it's not looking realistic or good so
i'm going to apply those now here i have
to add a normal map
this is a normal map
so i'm going to apply the normal map and
here you can see that uh
the bids all right here you can see the
bits in here are
coming to show up all right they are
putting the 3d
aspect in here you can see it right
now we have to add another thing that is
a height map all right so let me find
the height map
okay yeah
now
i have applied the height map and this
uh this height map will help me to
adjust the height of the
like height of these uh
particular things right you can uh let
me show you from like
from uh from nearly all right
so here you can see that it is moving
right it is moving right
so that
that is what height map does
now another thing all right another
thing is that we have to add an
occlusion now this is the ambient
occlusion all right this is the ambient
occlusion mask
so
now you can see that we have also added
the occlusion mask
now if you want to increase the
smoothness you can do so but i am not
liking the smoothness that much so it
should be something like this
all right now
let's see if anything is left
um roughness
no um
all right let's see
okay
as of now all right for us it's uh we
are good with this cube alright this
looks realistic too
now you can get all the textures all
right there are really great textures
available at 3d textures dot me so i
would really suggest to go in there and
check out the textures alright and take
the texture that you
like
as simple as that
all right
now another thing all right
is another thing is we have to
put this cube all right we have to make
this cube a child of
image target all right we have to make
image target
now click on image target all right and
another thing that you may you might see
that the inspector panel is not changing
that's not any sort of bugs it is
basically i have locked the inspector
panel now i have unlocked it so i have
got all the things
all right
now
in the image target uh
in the image target behavior script
uh under the
add target button you would find
something a drop down
that is advanced all right you need not
to look into these um
properties
but for us the very important thing is
this particular button add virtual
button so click on it
right and you can see that it has added
a virtual button now if you click on it
the
virtual button will be visible to you
all right
now remember the rules all right
remember the rules
and try to resize it all right now i'm
not sure all right and i i haven't seen
where uh where are the feature points
but i'm what i'm doing is
i'm putting at a particular place and
i'm trying to follow all the
instructions
all right
so i would suggest you to follow the
instructions too
all right so we created our virtual
button
now
now what
see
when you click your virtual button in
the inspector panel you would get some
options all right you will get some
options now
the very the very important thing that
we have to see is the virtual button
behavior script all right
in here here's an option sensitivity
setting that is a drop down all right
so in the drop menu you would find high
medium low now these are the sensitivity
settings what this tells
what this tells us is that
how often or you can say um
how exactly are we going to uh
like when we uh place
uh place our hand
upon or sorry over the particular mark
over the particular virtual button all
right so
how what will be the sensitivity all
right or what will be uh the rate all
right when it will
like
detect all right it would detect and
start doing the function so that's what
sensitivity means it tells that how
sensitive the particular button is
all right if if it is low then it might
like it might take some sort of
hard work to get the button to work but
if it is high then it won't take that
much hard work to make the button work
all right
so yeah
now
now as we have created our virtual
button all right we also have to add
some functionalities to it right
now
i'm going to uh create a script all
right let me tell you first which script
i'm going to create on it i'm going to
create a script that is that will simply
uh
when you hover all right when you hover
over the virtual button all right
whenever you hover over the virtual
button
what it will do is
it will simply
disable the cube or let's say uh hide
the cube all right
as simple as that
nothing too complicated
all right
so yeah
let's start coding now see as you can
see i have created of multiple folders
in here and i i would suggest uh you
should also create because that would
help you to structure your projects
now i would create another folder in
here that is
uh watch virtual
button
scripts all right
now i would uh
create different types of folders for
different types of tutorials all right
now in here
create a c-sharp script and i'm going to
name it
virtual
button
all right
or let's say virtual button
or
let's say button
behavior something like this behavior
so it would take some amount of time to
create the script
so now we have created our
virtual
button behavior script right now it's
our time to code it all right and you
already know that what we are going to
code
all right
so
the very first thing the very first
thing is we have to somehow
target the cube and all right and before
that all right and before that we also
have to
uh use a namespace
all right we also have to use a
namespace called euphoria all right it's
very important to make the
virtual button script virtual button
functions to work all right
so
yeah so i remove the comments and make
sure that the void start function is
there alright and if you have forgot
what this void start function does don't
worry i'm going to re-explain it
all right the very first thing all right
was
to
include the namespace euphoria now
uh
to like edit the cube all right or do
something with the cube we somehow have
to
uh grab or
let's say get the reference to the cube
right we have to somehow store that cube
somewhere to be edited right so how do
we do that it's fairly simple
we have to create a variable that is
public
game object all right as it is a game
object so the data type i am keeping is
game object all right and then cube now
one thing you should note all right if
you if you don't give public or give
private what will happen is this
particular field won't be showed all
right it won't be showed in the
inspector if i had to show you just wait
all right
let me show you i have created this
particular game object all right and
let me show you in uh let let the script
compile all right let the script compile
and i will show you that what will
happen if you don't give public all
right
now see there there are two ways to
reference a variable all right i will be
showing you
two ways
both the ways actually
like uh the simple drag and drop
reference referencing way and another
that is
using the script to reference
all right
so yeah
now let's attach the cube to our image
target all right you can create another
empty game object and attach it in there
but
the thing is that the process will be
following up is
it requires us to
add the
script in the image target only in the
image target game object only there's a
reason behind it i would show you why
all right it depends on our scripting
procedure and i'll be scripting it in a
in that way that
the script should be in the image target
game object only all right so you can
see that we aren't able to see any sort
of
uh variable but we did create one so
let's give public let's see
by default alright by default whenever
you create a game object all right or
any variable it is public it is private
all right those variables are private by
default
so
make sure if you want to make them
public if you want to make those
variables public
then
you should remember
that to add public keyword in front of
them
so now
let's see if our cube like if our
variable has appeared all right so click
on the image target and then
go uh at the last and check in the scale
in your script that you created that the
cube is coming or not all right so in
here our
cube variable is coming now what you
have to do is select the cube all right
select the cube and drag and drop it
in this particular area alright in this
particular
place it uh it is currently taking
all the uh game objects that are
of type game objects all right it is
taking all the objects available in the
scene that are type of game object all
right
so anything that is game object it will
take it in here it can be stored in this
variable
all right
now another thing is that we have to
create a private variable all right
because i don't any uh want anyone to
edit it externally so
we have to
give a data type that is virtual button
behavior
and let's name it
button
or let's say v button that is virtual
all right
this uh you already know uh if you don't
give public in front of any sort of
variable what will happen
all right now as we have created all
right as we have created a virtual
button
we have to reference it also right we
also have to refer
so how should we do that
right it's very simple all right there
are some uh functions that is get um
get component gate component in children
we would be using get component in
children because we are targeting
the
like we are targeting the
means
let me show you
all right
see
you can see in the unity editor all
right that this is the image target all
right this is the main uh game object
all right and the virtual button and the
cube all right the virtual button and
the cube
are a children all right are children of
this main game object right so we are
attaching the script in this
game object all right and we will be
trying all right we will be trying to
access
all it will be trying to access
the particular uh virtual button
behavior all right virtual button
behavior script all right we'll be
trying to
access virtual button behavior script
from the virtual button game object all
right so we'll be doing this
so very the very first thing alright see
as i told you that
in normal state all right in normal
state
the cube should be hidden right and when
we hover all right when we hovered over
the particular virtual button
all right the cube should be visible all
right that's what i told you right now
the very first thing is we have to
make the cube invisible all right so
cube dot
set active
and put false in here so what will
happen with this is what will happen
with this is
uh
whenever you start on it whenever the
game is starting all the app is starting
at first all right at first instance
this uh
cube will be deactivated all right or in
simpler terms it will be hidden all
right and you know that what void start
is void start runs
only once
whenever the application is starting all
right so that's why
that's why whenever the app will start
we will
run this particular function cube dot
set active false so that the cube
gets hidden all right another thing is
that you can simply hide it from
the
means hide it from
the particular uh hierarchy panel from
the scene only but of course that isn't
a good idea so let's do it by script
now
you have to
uh instantiate all right you have to uh
like contain the virtual button behavior
script all right so i'm
going to name it
uh sorry
i have already name it that is we have v
button oh sorry v button
so yeah now let's
let's sort uh what can i say let's um
add all right let's
uh reference
that particular
virtual uh button behavior script all
right so you have to uh type this get
component
and
children
all right
and inside of this
inside of this particular greater than
and lesser than arrows
you have to write the script name all
right that is virtual button behavior
all right now
we have targeted the
virtual button behavior script now
all right now let's create two functions
all right let's create two another two
function that will help us to activate
and deactivate the script so
void
on
button pressed
we have to
take a virtual button behavior as a
parameter sorry
vb
all right
and then
what we have to do is
whenever all right whenever the button
is pressed or you can say button is
hovered
we have to
set the state of the cube to true so
that it is visible all right
and whenever
but a button is released all right
released
whenever the button is a
button is
released what we are going to do is
we are going to simply deactivate
the
cube all right
so it is as simple as that
but
all right but
we haven't uh like see whenever
to make any sort of function work right
any sort of method work we have to
call it right we have to call that
particular function
but
in our case we haven't called it can you
see where we have called it
see
now all right like when you create
normal buttons ui buttons alright in
unity there are uh some sort of on click
on click functions right and
in the button parameters there are on
click functions
in here all right in here there there is
no on kick on click function available
so we have to uh
like create our own on click all right
or you can say register these functions
in our button so how do we do so it's it
is fairly simple all right it is fairly
simple
so
select the button all right and then
we
v button
dot
register
on
button
pressed all right and inside the
parenthesis
pass the function on button pressed
because whenever the button is pressed
we have to run this particular on button
press function
now
v button
dot again we have to do another thing
that is on button released
all right
so
on
button
released
all right so
yeah this is it
all right this is it now let me
recapitulate the whole code to you all
right so that you won't get confused the
very first thing we did
is to uh include the namespace using
euphoria
then what we did
we created a game object public game
object that is a cube and referenced the
cube to it then we created a virtual
button behavior named v button then uh
in in the start already in the void
start what we did
we
uh
like
in the void start we specified that
whenever the application starts
deactivate the cube all right the cube
should be hidden then after doing so
what we we created two functions all
right having uh virtual button behavior
vb as a parameter so
the first
function that we created is on button
pressed what it will do whenever uh the
when we whenever we are hovering over
the button or you can say
whenever we put our hand over the button
that means
that we have pressed the button so
that's why it is written on button
pressed
so basically you are hovering over it so
uh this is what happens
now whenever on button pressed function
will be called the
cube will be like will be restored it
won't be hidden anymore but whenever the
hand is released from the button all
right whenever the button is released
again the cube will be hidden after that
what we did is we referenced that we
referenced our virtual button behavior
script in our v button
uh component and then
we uh
used functions
to call our
own functions right like v button dot
register on on button pressed what it
will do is it these two works like uh
on click all right whenever uh whenever
you are pressing the button it will do
some function and we have passed the
function that is whenever we will press
the button
this particular on button pressed
function should
run
and
another is that v button dot register
on button released all right
what will what will it do whenever the
hand
is released from the button
it will run the function on button
released all right so let's save the
script right let's save the script and
try it out in
real time
let's
try it our
basically let's write our application
that we created the very first thing i
would suggest you to do is to change the
sensitivity setting to high alright
and then click on play mode all right
so as you can see it right in here
all right here is my marker
you can see that whenever i am hovering
over my hand you can see that the
cube is appearing and whenever i am
releasing my hand the cube is going all
right so this is how it basically
works all right
as simple as that
so
congratulations you learn to create how
your how like how to create
virtual buttons but
if you uh if you ask me what do i
suggest virtual buttons or
ui buttons believe me ui buttons are far
better than these virtual buttons
all right so i would always recommend
you to use uh ui buttons yeah if there
is a need to use virtual button then
only use it all right because
those watch
these virtual buttons sometimes even
doesn't tracks the hand like it's really
hard to get them track the hand maybe
it's because of my laptop's camera but
it is really problematic and uh
creates a lot of problem and also breaks
the user experience so that's why i
always recommend
ui button all right so yeah
in this lecture we are going to learn
how to use video playback feature all
right in our viewforia
project
so this in this video we are going to uh
implement our own video player you in
augmented reality using euphoria and
unity after this video you would learn
how to
use your videos
in your games all right in your v4d
applications now in this video i'm going
to show you there are actually two ways
to uh
means add the video playback
functionalities such as
play pause and stop all right but
there's another way that is the
non-coding way all right i'm going to
show you the non-coding way that is to
use the
uh given on click functions means
ready-made on click functions
give a given in unity all right even i'm
going to show you how how to play the
video whenever
marker is found and stop it whenever
marker is lost all right this video is
going to be the
real is going to be really simple video
so follow along all right now first of
all delete the main camera after
deleting it go to view fourier engines
uh add ar camera then again right click
euphoria engine and then add image
target all right in the image target
select uh from database then select the
database
and
the image target all right this is the
basic process that
we follow along all right and i'm using
the previous project only so i need i
haven't created any sort of new license
or
any sort of new database so i'm using
the same marker and all those things but
in different scenes
all right
now uh here you can see here is a script
default observer event handler in here
there you can see dragged or extended
track click on track all right
then what you have to do is
click on image target
add a plane all right go to 3d object
add up plane all right here you can see
a plane is added now we have to
reposition it
uh
move it upwards a bit that is in the y
axis then resize it all right
so that it can fit the marker
all right
you can even create your
ar video playback like ar video
application or you can say ar video
player after watching this video all
right you can like get all the videos
from the
file explorer and then show it in here
all right you can create your own
application with it but in augmented
reality all right now let's name the
plane to video playback or let's say
player
all right now in here
after that go to uh in the inspector
panel only search for video all right
click on add component then search for
video and you will get a com here you
will get a component called video player
all right now i have already i already
have a video imported all right i
already have a video imported
in my uh assets so i'm simply what you
have to do is you already know how to
import it right because you just simply
have to download the video and just
import it it is as simple as that
now you have to drag and drop the video
inside of the video clip parameter all
right and voila
this is
the thing you have to do all right
now
another thing is that whenever you play
all right whenever you play this
all right the video will be
inverted all right now let me show you
what are the problems that we'll be
facing now
so as you can see in here all right as
you can see in here
the problem with the video is
all right
it is currently playing all right it is
currently
playing
just wait
the video is currently playing and it is
inverted also all right you might not be
able to hear the audio but the audio is
also playing in the background all right
so this is the problem we are facing
currently let's let's fix it all right
let's fix it
see the very first thing all right the
very first thing you have to do is to
invert this all right invert means
rotate this in the y axis
rotate this whole plane in the y axis so
that we get the video straight
all right now after this will be getting
the video state another thing all right
another thing is that
click on the plane all right in here the
video option there is an option called
play on awake
what does this mean this means whenever
you are
like whenever the application is
starting it will start playing the video
all right this is what it means now
uncheck it all right uncheck it
now uh
all the problems that we we were facing
uh is fixed now
so let's implement
the features that i told now here you
can see here are two option
on target found and on target lost right
what we have to do is an air uh click on
on target found
click in it all right and then here you
can see this is the video right this is
the video
now drag and drop it in here all right
drag and drop this video in here now uh
i fall i guess i forgot change the name
so name it video
player
all right name it video player
now
what i did
let me show you the process again all
right
click on image target here are two
options on target found on target loss
these are called events all right
these events call some sort of function
all right these type of events are also
available in ui buttons also i'm also
going to show you how to create play
pause button in ui all right so don't
worry
now
what you have to do is click on this
plus icon in on target found
then
drag and drop your video player
inside this particular field then here
you can see here's another here the drop
down that
no function written in here all right in
here what we have to do go to the last
and you would find an option
called video player all right
now in here what you have to do here are
multiple options available from these
options you have to click on
means call the play function all right
what will happen whenever all right
whenever you try to
play the video all right sorry whenever
you uh whenever the marker is found all
right whenever the marker is found it
will start playing the video
all right another thing all right
another thing is that
i want also to integrate whenever all
right whenever the marker is lost the
video should pause or stop all right so
for my case i would like to stop it so
again uh
in here's an another event parameter
that is on target lost
again do the same thing
drag and drop the video in here
call a particular function inside the
video player i will be calling
stop function all right
so
yeah this is how we basically
create our own video playback features
all right now this is the basically uh
this is basically uh if you want only to
use euphoria to control the video
playbacks all right like whenever the
marker is found
you want you want to start the video and
whenever the marker is lost you want to
stop the video all right so let's try
so as you can see in here all right
here
uh the marker is found and the video is
playing all right
i'm not sure you are able to hear the
audio or not but you can see the video
is playing now if i remove it all right
now if i remove it all right uh the
video has stopped right you are not able
to see anything now if i again all right
if i again uh put the market you can say
the video is starting all over right
from uh from the start the video is
starting from the start all right
so yeah
we successfully created our
video playback features all right we
successfully created our video playback
in viewforia now it is our time to do
the same thing using buttons all right
that is to implement the play pause and
stop functionality using buttons so it
is pretty simple all right it is not
that complicated
what you have to do is
see i'm not going to remove these two
functions because i think these are good
all right because whenever uh i want key
whenever the marker is found it the
video should automatically start and
whenever the marker is locked the video
should automatically stop all right or
you can what you can do is uh you can uh
like
make it pause all right
just make it pause let me change it to
pause on it so whenever the marker is
locked the video will pause and whenever
the marker is again found after being
paused
the video will play from the point where
it has been paused all right so
it is it
so that's how we implement
uh video playbacks in euphoria if you
want to do the same thing with
markers like marker lost or marker found
all right
now we'll be doing the same thing using
uh ui canvas in viewforia all right
so now as
we have successfully created our video
playback now it is our high time to
implement
some particular buttons for it all right
so how do we do that the very first
thing click on image target um sorry
yeah click on image target then go to ui
alright and click on canvas
all right
so click on canvas then in the canvas
here you can see canvas scaler here it
is written constant pixel size changed
into scale with screen size it will help
help the ui to be more responsive all
right
so yeah let me make it first let me go
to the 2d mode for designing the ui all
right
now as i'm 2d mode as i'm in 2d mode now
i have to implement the buttons it is
fairly simple just click on ui then i
would like to implement
text text mesh pro buttons all right so
i would click on button text mesh pro
and it has been imported all right the
very first button that i have to create
is the play button all right this is the
play button that i want to create now i
have to anchor this button also all
right so how would i do so
so simply click in here all right
you can see this direct transform option
click in here and press alt key
after that
click on the this last
this last one all right click on this
last one
now
i also have to
change the text inside it all right so
that it uh resembles play button
all right now let's make it bold
now i i see
i would be duplicating this button all
right so that it becomes more easier for
me
now yeah
now let me change it to
pause
all right now
let's change the text of it to that is
to
pause
all right
now again the same thing
duplicate it
let's name it
stop
let's
change the name to
stop
and also make it bold oh all right i i
have already made it bold
now
again go to rick transform alt then the
right side
see our button is
anchored all right in a great way now
what we have to do is we have to
implement the functionalities so the
very first functionality i am going to
implement is the play button
functionality so click on the play
button
go to a go below alright go below
like in in the last and here you will
find an option called button option or
you can say button component in here
all right in here there's an option
called on click all right so simply
click on the plus button it's it's it's
similar to the image target on target
found alright it is similar to that now
again drag and drop the video player
object inside alright drag and drop the
video player object
inside
the play button then
select video player
and then click on play all right
again do the same thing all right do the
same thing with
the other button but
choose
different set of functions based on the
function functionality you want all
right so this is the pause button so i'm
going to use the pause function and
there's the stop button so i'm going to
use
the
stop function
all right
cool now
let's
let's test it out by playing it all
right
so guys
just see what is happening in here all
right
so
whenever i you can see the video has
started playing all right you might
heard uh some sort of sound maybe i'm
not sure all right now let's let's pause
the video all right see the video is
pause now the video is pause now let's
play it again
the video is
playing all right now let's pause it the
video is pause now if you want to stop
it
the video has stopped now if we want to
play it
the video has started
playing
so
all the functionalities that we
implemented is working perfectly fine
all right
this lecture we are going to create our
own car customizer so
this the basic logic or idea behind this
car customizer is would uh would be
providing the user three to four
different colors all right and based on
those colors
the player would be able to like select
uh a particular color and paint the car
all right or with that color so this is
the basic idea behind today's project
and
if you want alright if you want you can
like customize this app further like you
can add detachable doors you can uh add
numerous numbers of tires that a person
could
change right so uh you could you could
do those things also to make this app
more uh like
more big and later on you can launch it
on play store already when you can add
uh ads into this application all right
so the uh let me tell you so
first of all i already
have a 3d model all right inside of
my unity engine all right this is the 3d
model actually i downloaded it from uh
sketchfab uh actually uh let me show you
this is uh the actual model that was
there i edited it later on the this is
the actual model that was on sketchfab
uh so i'll edit it later on basically
this uh this kind of color came just
because of uh it's a fbx is uh it
doesn't
already have the properties that i want
so i created a new material and
me
applied those materials into the car all
right so that's what i have done
so uh the the better option would be for
you to is uh
download
the gltf models all right that is
download the models in glta format
because they are they comes in much
better quality and they have the texture
already embedded in it right so it would
be much better to work with those all
right so let me first reset its
transform all right so uh
so yeah i've reset it it's transform and
uh
i'm like
just a bit moving it uh in the z-axis
just a bit all right and now what you
have to do is uh
go to your browser all right first of
all we have to create a license for our
ar application right and one more thing
i have already imported the viewforia
engine all right and you already know
how to do that and you also know that
how to check whether it is imported
successfully or not so make sure uh you
import
the
view fourier sdk
and before importing all right always
make sure before importing change the
uh build platform alright because if you
change the build platform later on that
is after importing the model the sdk
then it's gonna take a lot of time so
what i did is uh after creating the
project i first
shifted uh the
build uh platform to android all right
and then uh what i did is
i go i got to the player settings all
right
after going to the player settings what
you have to do is uh go to resolution
and presentation all right not sorry not
in the resolution presentation just wait
okay
yeah i was actually in the desktop tab
that's why i wasn't getting all the
options so now as i'm on the android tab
uh go to the resolution and presentation
you will be getting a
default orientation change it to
landscape left alright it's totally
based on the camera you can choose any
uh any
mode you want alright but uh we'll be
creating our application in landscape
mode only so make sure either to select
a landscape right or landscape left i
chose landscape left because of the
position of my camera
all right and uh
now go to other settings all right here
you would find uh android build settings
right so what you have to do is uh
select uh
android version all right that is the
lowest standard version you want to
support so for me it's a api level 23
that is android 6.0 you can choose a
kitkat you can choose uh lollipop and
anyone
it means any target api level it sorry
minimum api level you want all right and
leave the target api level to automatic
highest installed all right so yeah
that's what you have to do
uh so after this what you have to do is
you
got to go to the uh license manager all
right
uh click on get basic and create a new
license all right
so
give this license a new name that is i'm
going to give it ar car all right and uh
click click on the check box and
click confirm
all right
after that open this
ar car license and what you have to do
is you have to copy this license all
right you have to copy this license and
go to a unity editor then
one more thing delete this uh main
camera all right in the united uh delete
this main camera because we won't be
needing it
uh now right click view fourier engine
ar camera all right and one thing i
prefer the most is to put the ar camera
on top of everything
so after you have done uh setting up the
ar camera what you have to do is uh in
the in the inspector tab only you will
get the properties of ar camera and in
the ar camera you'll be finding open
view 40 engine configuration right and
in here you'll be finding app license
key so click on this blank box and uh
just pay paste the license
all right just paste the license and you
would be good to go right
so uh
our basic
project is set up right now we have to
create a database
so click on target manager
all right click on add database give the
database a name so i'm going to give it
ar
car
db
all right
uh
make sure that the type is device and
then click on create
so after it has created a database open
it
now what you have to do is you have to
add uh the target marker i already have
the marker all right so you can select
any marker you want so i'm going to
select the marker
now
let me
find the marker
okay got it now give it a give it a
width
i'm going to give it a weight of 6 all
right and i will keep the name marker on
right
so
just let it upload uh
upload that marker and after that or
what you have to do is you have to
download the marker
so that uh we can
upload it on our
unit engine and one more thing always
check that
what is the rating that is the
augmentable rating of your marker and
make sure it has four
minimum four all right it should be at
least four to five
not less than that all right now click
on download database and uh select the
unity data and click on download
all right so
it would start downloading the database
now save this database uh
somewhere in your
desktop and uh
import it all right
so right click
you can either drag and drop it in here
or you can right click import package
custom package or that you can do that
so i'm going to
follow the
second one now click on ar card db all
right ar card db your uh unity package
this is the database i downloaded and
click on open and it's going to take
some time to process and
it did the processing and click on
import
all right so it's going to take some
time to import uh the assets and wow
cool so our asset is also
imported right now what as we already
have imported our uh
car model what i want you to do is right
click view for engine image target
all right and in the image target you
will be finding uh like in the inspector
menu you will be finding image target
behavior from the type select from
database all right and in there select
the database and uh your marker will be
automatically selected if you have more
than or two mark one marker that is two
or three markers then you you can select
it from there right now this is the
database i'm going to like
reset the transform again so that i get
it in the center of the
card now i'm going to increase the size
of the car all right
so that i could uh
match the ratio all right
now uh what i have to do is i have to
put this car uh means make this car a
child of the image target right and uh
now
we are good to go our markerless
sorry marker based ar app is set up all
right now what we have to do is we have
to uh
code
all right we have to code our
means we basically have to code what are
the functions we want in the app so for
now we only want to change the color
of the car alright that is the material
color of the car so first of all i want
you to create the ui so how are are we
going to do that it's pretty simple
right click
ui
um then canvas
all right as uh this app is in landscape
what i'm going to do is i'm going to
choose the medium resolution so that we
could uh like easily
make our app responsive all right and
put it right in here now
after i've created a canvas
you can see that there are multiple
options in here you can say canvas
scaler option is there in there in the
ui scale mode section you have to choose
choose
scale with screen size
all right and
leave it
there only all right because that would
actually help us to make the
ui more responsible right now what you
have to do is
uh add some buttons all right
uh click on button text mesh pro all
right so
it would
like prompt importer you can import it
but currently i don't want it so i would
be going with the normal buttons only
all right
i would like to go with the normal
buttons only actually we won't be
needing the text so that's why i'm going
with the normal buttons but what i would
suggest you is to or if you are going
for text based buttons or something like
that all right even buttons in general i
would suggest you or to always go for
text mesh pro because they are
1000 times better than you know
these other buttons so give it a width
of 200 all right out let's not give 200
so it's too big let's give 100 only
all right uh yeah
now
what you have to do is in the right
transform only in here you'll be seeing
a small box click on it click uh alt
all right
just wait
okay
now what you have to do is
click alt in here
or
just do it
all right
now what you have to do is
after you have done that
give it a give it a name all right let's
give it name i want to name it red
all right and
let's give it a red color all right and
make sure you are in 2d mode because we
are going to edit this ui
all right
and uh duplicate this button all right
duplicate this button and uh
move it right in
in here
now give it another color that is let's
say i wa i want black right
uh let's give it another color that is
black
uh
it might not be that visible so i'm
going to make it a bit like
this kind of black so that it becomes
visible all right
now here give another color
all right
let's let's give it uh
blue
all right
let's make the color blue
okay now let's give another color that
is uh
yellow
all right
okay cool
all right so we have our ui prepared
that we got our ui prepared we have uh
we have prepared our buttons now what we
have to do is we have to code right the
very first thing or the very first thing
i would like to do is i would be coding
a script to rotate our car all right so
that it rotates continuously and to do
that
uh first of all what i have to do is i
have to
just
create a folder scripts folder all right
and then click on create
then again c sharp script and let's give
it a name that is rotate
all right so i want my card to rotate
actually
now it's compiling the application all
right
okay so give it a few seconds
okay
so
all right it's taking a bit time so
let's give it its time so that it is
able to do the processing it needs to do
all right so our script is uh perfectly
compiled now i'm going to open the
script in my visual studio editor
all right
now
okay
here we got our editor all right
i don't want it to be in full screen
mode
as of now so uh
remove the
whole start function and comments all
right we need the update one so first
thing is you have to create a vector3
variable all right
vector3
uh let's name it rot
all right and what in the update
function only what you have to do is
transform
dot
rotate all right and pass this rot
variable in there and multiply it with
time
dot
delta time
all right
now
save the script and
[Music]
let it compile in your unity editor
all right
so
after it is uh compiled what you have
what we have to do is we have to put it
in uh means inside our
car model all right that is we have to
attach it as a script in our car model
all right so that we could uh
use it
right
and uh
all right
now
go to the image target all right and uh
first of all unpack this whole prefab
all right
after unpacking what you have to do is
drag and drop this rotate script in here
and in in the rot value uh give it a
value of 30 alright it would be like
moving at rotating at the speed of
30 all right now what you have to do is
play this all right uh play this
particular scene and let's see
how all things work
right
so just give it a few seconds
so
just a few seconds and we'll be good to
go
all right okay
cool
let
let me uh
maximize it
okay cool now
see our car is rotating all right
and that's pretty good all right oh one
more thing
extended tracking feature is on and of
course we don't want that
uh go to ar camera all right
sorry not ar camera or click on image
target
all right in here
uh select track all right and we'll be
good to go
right
so now as
our
basically our car means we have created
our car model
right as we have created our car model
now what we have to do is
uh click on create she sharp script all
right and let's
give it
change color all right so that we could
change color of our
car after clicking some particular
button all right
so
just wait it's compiling the script
all right
just wait a few seconds
let's open the script in our editor okay
cool
now
what i want you to do is uh create an
array all right
that is a line renderer sorry not like
line random just wait public
just give me a second
all right so
what we have to do is we have to create
a array all right
of first of all uh create an array of
colors all right
so that we can store the colors in here
now
again create another array of renderer
that is it will
help us to
get the renderer of
our car material there's a reason why we
are
there's a reason why we are actually
creating a renderer all right uh there's
a huge reason means not exactly a
renderer why we are creating an array of
renderer and
you know
just wait
let's name it uh
mats all right now there's a reason why
we are doing that because see a car
might have multiple materials in it all
right that is multi car might have
multiple sections in it where
there will be different different
materials will be up uh like
applied right so that's why we are
creating a array so that we could
include all those
uh sections in our
you know in our
model only that is in our script only
right now
let me show you what you have to do is
record public void
all right and write a method or function
all right called red
now make it public so that we can get it
on our uh inspector menu right now
we have to run a loop all right that is
for nti equals 0 i less than
max
dot length
all right it would be running from 0 to
that is 1 minus the actual length of the
material
all right and uh
yeah
now
you can you can either open the brackets
or you can simply write it like this let
me show you
all right
because if it's if it's a one-liner all
right you don't need bracket and uh
currently it's a one-liner only now what
you have to do is mat
mat of like i we have to give it take
each and every like
each particular material and apply color
to it so max of i
ah dot material dot color
equals
so you can
what you uh what you can do is
just wait
colors yeah we got the variable and give
it the first that is the first value of
all the
colors all right now copy and paste all
right copy and paste it so that we can
uh basically replicate it all right
now
blue
all right
and
or let's say which was our second color
in here okay it was black right let's
give it black
and uh
let's give it one all right then in here
let's give it blue because it was our
third and give it two
and
yellow
and do you know why we are uh giving
like
first
index value as zero then one then to the
second we are giving one then to the
third we are giving two that's because
indexing starts from zero all right so
we have our script written
and i hope you understood uh understood
the script now
there's nothing else to do we just have
to apply the script and the functions
all right we have to apply
to the variables
right
so
[Music]
yeah
so now what you have to do is
create a empty game object alright you
can do that and
reset its transform name it
color changer
all right and attach the script or to
the color changer now what you have to
do is you have to give uh
you know
four colors to it
give the array size four and
uh let's see how many materials we have
to give in here all right so basically
the body is there all right
now
all right
not this one
this one this one
all right this roof sweet not sweepers
for window front not this one all right
so uh
okay
all right i understood
so
go to the color change script alright
and let's give it two as of now all
right
now what you have to do is
get the body material in here all right
the body is for the whole body right
and uh
let's
get the sweepers that has no sorry uh
the roof one all right
let's get the
where is the roof okay yeah we got it
so
yeah here we got the hood
all right
actually there are multiple
layers in it so that's why that's why i
told you to
add
like
create an array of those materials right
now let's get the hood in here
okay so we got the hood
now
okay the body is uh done the doors right
oh yeah the doors
so go to the color changer add another
section all right and uh
let's give it the dose right
take the doors all right
okay just do it
okay
okay here we go another one
that is door fr
all right
now
let's see what are the things we have to
give
okay
trunk a door
right
let's give it the trunk dough
all right i hope not nothing else is
left
okay
no i guess everything seems good right
yeah everything seems seems good now
let's let's see let's uh
now let's give those colors the first
element should be red
all right it should be red
okay the
next that is which the next one should
be uh you know black
all right now the second one should be
you know blue
let's give it a move a bit sky color all
right it would look good and the next
one would should be yellow right now
what we have to do is
click on canvas all right
click on buttons all right first of all
uh select every button
add a plus sign in there and
add the color changer script in here
right what you have to do is uh
go to a red button click on change color
click on red go to the black button
again or choose from the change color
then select black then from the blue
color
click
uh change color then blue then from the
yellow one
go in here click on change color
and
click on yellow
where is it
okay cool
now let's try our app so that uh let's
try our app and let's see uh how it
performs all right
let's see
so give a few seconds and
we'll be good to go
okay cool
so let me maximize the window
okay
all right cool so we are able to see the
car right now let's try the color wow
see
it looks good right
cool isn't it
yeah so
our first project is done actually all
right uh congratulations you have
created your first full-fledged
application
with
euphoria all right you can let me give
you some idea what you can do further
you can let's say you can add varieties
of tires in here all right you can add
numerous varieties of tyres you can add
more colors all right you can uh like
create your own own car model or you can
even like
take the door of it all right and like
rotate it somehow or to get like the
opening door animation sort of thing
right you can create your own animations
like that and add it in there so that
the person can actually um you know
the person can actually view the
inner parts of the car right you can add
more customization customizations to it
you can add more cards to it right now
the next process for you is to go to
build settings all right and
add click on add open scenes all right
that is for our the scene is main or you
can simply drag and drop the scene
and simply click click on build and it
would start building our application
all right so if you have any doubt
regarding this lecture you can write it
down in the comment section
all right
in this lecture we are going to create
our second project all right that is ar
business card all right how this uh
project would help you is let's say you
are going to some client alright and you
want to or give them your business card
alright you can share the apk already if
uh like of course
yeah you can do this right so
would be creating a ar business card
today all right and in this project you
are going to learn to
like implement your own avatar all right
and uh
you you would also learn to apply
animations
right so
let's do it
so what you have to do is right now let
me show you
first of all you have to set up your
project all right it's very simple
create a new project go to file
build settings
all right in the build setting first of
all switch your platform to android all
right
i have already done that and make sure
whenever you are opening a new project
when it's blank all right that's totally
new
uh switch the platform first all right
because if you do that later on after
multiple things are done in your
platform means uh in your project
then switching the platform would be
very tedious because then it is going to
take a lot of time if your system is
slow all right after you have uh
switched the platform i also add uh also
click on add open scenes it will add the
a primary scene i am using on right now
all right and uh go to player settings
in the player settings give it a company
name alright give it a product product
name
all right and uh
go to resolution and presentation in the
default orientation select whichever you
prefer all right i am i prefer landscape
left because
of my camera position all right then in
the other settings uh
select the lowest android version you
want to keep all right for me it's
marshmallow all right and
leave the target api level to automatic
highest install all right and after that
we are done setting up the
uh like project all right now what you
have to do is import view for your
engine and you already know how to do
that right and uh another you have to
import another sdk that is the ready
player me sdk all right uh it it will
enable us to create uh 3d avatars all
right i have already i already have five
avatars in my
dashboard all right so you can also
create yours and upload it in unity all
right and to upload them you you have to
use this
unity avatar sdk all right
so
click on this download the latest
version and download your sdk right and
then import it the importing process is
totally similar already there isn't much
any difference so yeah all the things
are there are totally similar all right
i have already imported both euphoria
and ready player me all right now what
you have to do is
we have to set up our view for your
engine now all right so
first of all to do that go to click on
this main camera then delete this main
camera all right then again go right
click view fourier engine ar camera all
right you have this ar camera now put it
on top alright put it on top
okay now
after this is done we have to create a
license key alright so go to open view
for engine configuration and we have to
add a license key in here so to do that
go to your view for your developer
portal click on get basic
all right
and then you have to get a new license
all right give the
license name that is
business
card
all right and uh
check
check this box and click on confirm all
right and you'd be having your
business card right in here all alright
that is the license of your business
card
so now what you have to do is
uh
click on this particular means copy this
code all right and paste this code in
your view for your configuration that is
in the app license key all right and we
are good to go
now what you have to do is
open this and we also have to add a
target manager all right that is we have
to add our own market database so how do
we do that uh click on add database all
right then
let's uh
business
card
marker
all right
card
wait okay
marker all right db
so
i create this database all right and
after you create this database you are
going to find uh open this database and
add the marker already
add the
marker that you have created in there
all right i have my own business card
marker all right so i i will simply add
that in here
and then
download it all right
so
just wait let me find my
business card marker
oh yeah i got
now import it all right after you do
that uh give it a uh give it a size
alright i'm going to keep it to six all
right and you can
i am going to keep this name already you
can give any name you want and then
click on add target all right and it
would upload the target in your database
now what you have to do is after all all
these after all these things are done
download the database all right click uh
that is click on download database and
then select unity editor and click on
download
all right and this would actually start
downloading your
database all right
and then what you have to do is you have
to import this database in your unity
as simple as that
all right so now
open your unity all right open your uh
unity drag and drop alright drag and
drop this uh sdk
all right drag and drop this sdk into
sorry not sdk the database into
unity and click on import all right
so after
after all this all right it would import
your sdk and
sorry not sdk your database and we are
good to go
all right now what you have to do is
right click in here click on view for
your engine image target
all right so it would create a image
target uh game object in here and in the
inspector menu you would be finding
image target behavior
in there click
from database
select the database and
voila you got the marker
right so here you can see we i have the
business business card
right now
what we will be doing right now is we
have the avatar right i already have
imported the assets all right first of
all let me convert the asset so
select all these assets all right
uh all all of them are png's all right
so
set the asset and
in the texture type
go to sprite 2d and ui
and click on apply
all right so it's going to take some
time it's going to convert
all the textures
to a certain type all right that is this
sprite 2d and ui all right and
after it is converted right i'll be back
so our assets are converted all right
and now we are good to go
all right so now what you have to do is
uh you have to import the 3d model all
right so how do you do that first of all
uh click on this ready player me
button in here all right that is in the
head and click on
avatar loader all right in here
what you can do is
uh
create a new avatar for yourself all
right i i already have them uh create a
new avatar all right it's very simple to
create one and create avatar and then
what you have to do is
click on that avatar in the three dots
all right and
copy dot glb url all right
copy this glb url and
go to unity editor
here you can see avatar url or shortcode
you have to paste
that link you copied all right
okay so now
have a few options all right first of
all uncheck this model caching why see
this model caching feature is a feature
by uh
ready player me only what happens now it
will cache your model in unity now if
you don't alright let's say if you if
you uncheck this model caching what will
happen if you make some changes all
right if you make some changes on the
ready player me web that those changes
of the avatar will automatically
get reflected in
your unity editor all right so for now i
don't want uh model caching to be there
but if you want that if you want model
caching to be there you can do that all
right but currently i don't want uh my
model to be cached all right and or if
if use i animations is not checked
click on this use i animations all right
and
after that click on load avatar
all right so it would start loading the
avatar
all right so first first of all it will
download then
simply import your avatar
okay so our avatar
is now
loaded as you can see right in here
all right so first of all let let me uh
keep this avatar in a different place
all right and
let me add another plane all right that
is go to 3d object
uh in the 3d
object click uh plane
all right this plane is of course a
big first of all let me reset the
transform all right
and let me you know put it down a bit
and let me go to the top view so that i
can i could adjust all right i could
adjust this particular plane
okay
cool
all right
okay
so
we have adjusted our you know
okay we have adjusted our plane all
right now you can simply put it upwards
all right
cool
now uh what i want you to do is attach a
material in or to it all right so how do
you do that click
right click on the project panel create
a folder all right
create a folder called you know material
all right
right click create folder
material
click in here uh go to again material
and give it a
card material all right card mat all
right so that we can add the material in
here and in this albedo click on this
option alright and select the card
material in here
okay and then drag and drop it in
here
all right now rotate it all right rotate
it
so that we get the perfect alignment
all right
so now we are good to go now let's uh
edit this material a bit
right
okay
of course metallic doesn't look good
all right yeah
let's let's experiment with this
material a bit all right
wait
so now as you can see we have a menu
right in here all right uh click on
legacy shaders
and click on
diffuse
okay now it does looks good all right
so
let me show you how how i did it in the
material section
click on the shader option all right
then go to legacy shaders then diffuse
all right so that's how you do it
all right so yeah i hope it's clear
now
what you can do is uh drag and drop this
plane all right inside this image target
and you get this avatar right reset the
transform of this avatar all right reset
the transform of this avatar scale it
all right scale it a bit
scale this avatar a bit all right
first of all you remove this directional
light alright i don't want this means
remove the shadows not the directional
light of course after removing the
shadows all right rotate
rotate this particular avatar all right
let me rotate it okay cool
now
put it right in here all right on top of
this blank area
all right
okay let's
make this like this all right cool
so now you get a avatar
all right you can add a rotation script
all right so let's let's go to
uh create another folder all right
let's
create a folder called scripts
in the scripts folder
create a shop script all right and name
it rotate
okay i'm going to hit reload in my
visual studio editor all right
so it's currently compiling and it also
reloading my visual studio editor so
just wait a few seconds
so now uh our script is compiled all
right now let's open this in our visual
studio editor all right
and
let's write uh some script in it first
of all remove this start and all those
comments all right
simply create a public vector3 all right
vector
3 and give it rot
all right and then click on transform
transform dot
rotate
then pass this rod value and uh
on the rotate function and multiply it
with time dot
delta time
all right
and then uh save the script and uh
compile it all right after compiling it
we we have to attach the script on the
avatar all right to make
it work
so it's currently comparing the script
so just wait for a few seconds and
you know it would be done
right
so um yeah
sure
so our script is compiled now what we
have to do is click on this avatar all
right add the script right in here all
right and give it a rotational value of
let's say um
10 all right
and also drag and drop this
a particular avatar
inside the image target or make it a
child of the image target all right so
now as we uh did a lot of things right
in here all right let's uh let's see if
everything is working perfectly or not
all right so
let me open my uh marker
and
then
hit the play button all right hit the
play button all right so that's what you
have to do right now
so click on this play button
so now as you can see our
camera is open now let's uh
cool
see uh all the features that we
implemented as of now is perfectly
working but here you can see the uh
character animation is being played
right the character animation is being
played but the problem is that it is uh
sometimes it's also walking all right
it's also showing the walk animation and
i of course i don't want the work
animation all right and here comes
another problem that this extended
tracking so we'll be fixing these
problems alright before moving forward
so how to do that first of all uh let's
fix the about or let's let's fix the
image target problem all right click on
this image target
uh change it to tracked all right then
in the avatar what you have to do is and
you can see in the controller option
click on mail full ball with body that
is the controller name and double click
on this and it would open animator
window here you can see that uh
there there's two pathways that is first
it is going from idle to walk then again
it is going to walk to idle all right so
simply delete this all right simply
delete this particular
uh animation and we will be good to go
all right now also i want to increase
the size of this avatar a bit all right
so
yeah
now let's see how everything works
right
let's see how how perfectly uh things
are working and if it needs any more
changes or not
right so
yeah
just give it a few seconds
okay cool
okay
yeah it looks good
it does looks good right now all right
so yeah and also this uh tracking thing
is fixed
right and currently you can see the
blink speed all right
the blink uh you can increase the blink
speed all right that is i can make it to
like
0.3 maybe all right i'm going to
increase it to 0.3 it's the ideal value
i i find
all right now as our avatar is set up
all right now also set up our
you know our ui
all right now how to do that
this thing is fairly simple go to image
target click on ui
then uh select the canvas right in here
all right select a canvas and currently
this is a 2d canvas and of course we
none of us want 2d canvas
uh what you can do is go to
click on click on this render mode
alright and select world space
select the uh here you can see here's an
option for
event camera
uh drag and drop this ar camera into
this event camera all right and here you
can see our canvas is now transformed to
3d mode all right
now
let's
edit this canvas all right
let's scale it down alright and let's
reset uh not reset let's reset its
position
all right
here you can see we also we need to
scale it down more
okay
now
rotate this into y-axis not y or
x-axis to 90 degree
all right
and make sure it it is like this
all right give it a bit bit space to it
so that you can you know add our ui into
this
right now what you have to do is
you have to add
ui to it right what you can do is click
on this uh canvas
all right then go for uh first of all i
want to add an image so click on this
image
all right and uh let's drag and drop it
in here
all right so this would be my profile
image all right and i already have the
profile image so i'm going to just
select it and you can see
first of all let me do actually uh i
guess
the rotation of the canvas is uh
different let me let me check
yeah the rotation of canvas is wrong
just wait let me fix the rotation
okay
all right
now
let's get this particular image in its
right place
okay cool so now we got our image right
in here
all right so you can if you want you can
like
increase the size of the image all right
and let's add our name text
on the side of the image
so what you how do you do that click on
ui then click on text mesh pro
all right import the text mesh pro all
right because this is
the bet best alright there's the best
for button and text
both all right and it would start
importing the assets so it's gonna take
some time
so give it some time all right
so i have imported the text mesh pro all
right and also i have also imported the
text mesh for examples and extras all
right because it already provides some
really good fonts so i'm going to use
them all right now
as you see we have you know the text in
here now
write your name in here so
priyanshu but touch rgb
all right so what i'm going to do is i'm
going to like in the wrapping i'm going
to disable the wrapping all right
because i don't need it
now uh
let's see uh let's
let's choose a font from the given set
all right let's see which one would be
good
okay now this one
of course not this one no
let's see
yeah this will uh let's check the anton
one
okay
so roboto looks good all right this
roboto one looks pretty good
now
what you can do is you can
adjust it all right i just used more i
think
this
this is good this looks uh just to it
okay
yeah
no just wait
let me adjust it a bit all right yeah
this this this is pretty good
this this looks fine and uh
all right
so now we have set up uh this particular
profile thingy right now
what uh i want you to create an empty
prefab alright right in here all right
create an empty the game object and
let's name it a left container all right
because as we are going to add
animations to it all right so position
it in
you know in the center of these two
assets that is the
image and
the text
put it in the left container
all right and
let's uh you know sort of
add a bio in here
okay
so this would be a short bio so
i am
let me write let me uh complete the bio
all right then i would again
resume the video
so i wrote the bio all right now i have
to adjust let's adjust this bio right in
here all right so that like you know
uh this of course doesn't looks good
and uh
just give a moment
all right
okay
so
let's give it a height of 400
not 400 let's give it 200
okay yeah this this looks good now
let's reduce the size all right let's
make the size 25 maybe
or
20.
yeah i guess
i guess it's fine
let's make it
all right
yeah i guess uh this is fine this this
this looks fine now align it a bit
alright align this thing a bit
and uh
actually let's remove this
intro thing all right let's add two
buttons in here all right let's add two
buttons in here
go to ui
click on button text mesh pro
all right
go in here
you know uh
increase the size of the button alright
increase the size of the button
put it in the middle maybe all right and
i have wait i have the logos right in
here
go to assets okay
let's let's make two button for our
social media that is you know
uh
this instagram and uh linkedin all right
so
i'm not going to remove this particular
text i'm going to make it bold and let's
name it linked
in
all red
so and let's reduce the size that is
make it 20 all right
and in the button only click on ui then
again add an image
all right reduce the size
uh
in the image add the linkedin you know
link this
linkedin image in here all right and
drag and drop it to the side right
put it in the side
uh
make the text a bit centered
right
okay
let's make it uh
side all right let's
just give me a second
let me reduce the size of the text again
that is let's make it 17 maybe okay
sorry 20 buy mistake i got 27
all right cool now
i would also like like to or just wait
okay so i would also like to uh reduce
the size of the button so just simply
remove these text from there all right
now just wait
let me reduce the size of the button
um
okay good now again uh
make those text and
images the child of the button right
so let's adjust it a bit again
um
right yeah this this looks good
okay and also go to gizmos all right and
go to gizmos and you can see this 3d 3d
icon slider just
make it
small all right so small that you can't
again see those
things
all right and
okay now yeah this looks cool so then
name it linkedin
all right then again you know
duplicate this button all
right put it in here
all right and let's uh
name it uh
instagram
all right
so
give the text instagram
all right
so
let me reduce the size a bit for this
one
okay
15 okay all right
here we go and change the image
to the instagram image
all right and
yeah so we got our buttons in here
so now you what you can do is you can
simply you know
take these two buttons all right take
these two buttons and
simply
put it right in here
all right
or
let's try some let's try making this
button a bit you know
larger
in size
okay
now
just give a moment and
yeah
these looks good
right
so we got our
left container all right that is the
left left panel all right it would be
like coming like this in the animation
and let's create our another container
all right let's
create an empty container let's give it
a bottom all right that is it would be
in the
bottom container all right
so bottom container
now in the bottom container again
place that uh add an you know uh ui that
is an image
all right add an image in here
uh give this uh image a new you know
component that has button component
all right because we'll be using them as
buttons
all right now get this container and
drag and drop it in here
all right
so
uh as if you don't get that container
all right now what you have to do is
take this image and put it in the side
and add the discord icon in here
all right and let's uh give it a name
discord
okay
this cord
all right then again now
duplicate this and again place it in
a bit you know change the position and
place it in
[Music]
the side of it and again drag and drop
the github
you know github
logo and again
duplicate it all right
and now it's the time for you know
youtube
so now
rename it to youtube
all right
now what you can do is
okay so yeah
so we got our three button containers
all right and make sure to place it in
the center all right
um
let me reposition this you know the
button of
just wait let me reposition this
all right
just give me a second let me make all
the things in center
just give me just just a moment
all right
okay yeah
now i guess everything's fine right
so now
we have the buttons in here all right we
have all the things that we would be
needing let's uh
again
let's reduce the size of this one too
let's make it 14 maybe
all right
okay
now let's
go for 15.
all right this looks good
so now
as our buttons are created
right
now what you have to do is we have to
create a script all right because of
course the these buttons have to do
something right these buttons have to do
something so what uh this buttons will
be used to open the links all right so
how to do that click on
create a new she shop script all right
and
name it link manager
all right because we would be adding the
links in here all right and after it
gets compiled open the
open the link all right
so
[Music]
so we have to write some you know some
functions
all right to open the links the
the script is pretty easy
so now as our script is opened all right
uh everything's pretty simple just
remove all this
comments and start an update function we
have to write our own function that is
public all right
void
i'll say open
linkedin all right give give the
function name anything you want all
right and now uh within that function we
have to write a particular line that is
application dot
open url all right and in that uh pass
your linkedin profiles url
all right so here i have the
linkedin profiles url and now i'm going
to
paste it right in here all right
similarly write some other function that
is public
void open
instagram
then again application dot
open url
then you know add
the instagram url
copy link address
okay there's some problem with the link
all right let's remove this yeah we got
our linkedin uh that is instagram pro
profile all right now
again uh let's
create another function that is open
github
all right so um
application dot open url
and let's
put our github profile in there
copy link address
all right
so we got our get get a profile too
right
all right so now let's add
our
you know uh
which one is left now let's see
discord yeah
so open
discord
so this is uh the discord server of
android so you can join that so
application dot open
url
and uh
all right just wait let me copy the
url copy link address all right so here
we got
the url
all right now another uh was youtube
right public
void
open
youtube
all right
so application
dot open url
now again uh
put youtube in there this is the put the
link of the youtube in there all right
so i'm just going to copy the link
all right and you know
just paste it in here and
let's compile the script
so uh so our script is compiled all
right now you what you have to do is
create uh empty game object alright
reset its transform
all right just just do it ah yeah so
reset its transform and add this uh also
rename it to link manager alright
because we'll be attaching our
link manager script to it all right
and attach this link manager script in
here
now what you have to do is
uh go to the first of all uh this is the
these are the button all right so first
of all go to this linkedin button all
right in here you can see on click
click and uh click on add then add the
link manager
then click on link manager and find open
linkedin all right so and we got the
open linkedin function now again go to
instagram on click
link manager
open instagram
okay and in the bottom container click
on discord
on click
link manager
and then
open discord and again github save do
the same thing for github
all right
so add the github one
then click on
open github
there again
youtube
add the link manager
link then again open
youtube where is youtube yeah we gotta
so
that's how you do it all right now let's
test if everything is is working
fine or not
right
so
just give a few second and let me show
you
so here you can see that
our business card is created all right
and uh click on any button all right
let's say that's this discord button so
what will happen it would uh start
opening the url in my browser all right
so here you can see it has opened the
url in my browser and
so you can do similar things with that
you can add more features all right and
now it is our time to add the animations
to it
all right
so how would we do that see uh adding
the animations are very simple
what you have to do is
click on this left container all right
then go to your window
uh go to uh sorry in here go to this
animation section and click on animation
and a window like this would appear so
uh create all right click on create
then what you have to do is uh create a
new folder in here let's uh name it anim
solid because we'll be storing all our
animations in there
all right and uh
in the adams folder give it uh give it a
name called left container
left container anim already done save
the animation
all right now what you have to do is
here you can see first of all see here
in the record button click on this
record button all right and you know
put this
inside alright put this inside of in
here
all right
now
uh let's give it a let's say 50 second
gap all right
and again pull it back in here
all right
now
let's see
okay if if you want you can make things
more slower by dragging it to like
uh one
all right so now our left controller
animal is done
right so let's make it up to full
all right and now in the
bottom
container
what we have to do is again
click on create all right and
let's name it
bottom container
and
all right and uh save it
then again click on this
red icon all right this record button
drag drag it in in here all right drag
it in here and then again go to one
then again bring it up in here
all right
so that's how we do it right so that's
how everything works right
so now our animation is recorded you can
play the animation and see it's working
all right now here's a bit of a problem
all right this animation all right this
animation would be looping all right
when when the animation works right so
to fix that click on go to the anime
folder all right and uh
you can see these triangle icons right
so click on them and
uncheck the loop time option alright and
again in the left container also uncheck
the loop time option all right now
let's see if the animation is working or
not right let's uh let's check that all
right let's check that
so
let's see
oh our animation didn't work but can you
tell why because uh see when the scene
started now it already played the
animation all right
means uh let me show you again all right
let me show you again
let me uh you know
bring it up in here all right and let me
show you what is happening in the
background
okay so just give me a second and here
you would see that when the scene start
it would already
play the animation
now we all we do have a fix for that and
i will show you what is the fix it's a
very simple fix only all right
i will also make you understand the
concept of that all right so just give
me a second and uh would be good to go
right
so
here you can see the animation is
actually not playing because it has
already been
played right so this is the problem so
how to fix this let's let's see how to
fix this all right so the very simple
way is to go to the image target all
right and here you can see uh there's on
target found and on target lost right
and uh currently our
work is with this on target found
right so what we will do is click uh
click on this
get the left container in here go in
here go in animator all right
and
click on you know
play
right
and
if on target is lost all right
away uh
okay if on target is lost what you have
to do is
go to the left container
all right and
uh just wait
click on stop playback
all right
now let's see if if it's working or not
all right so
our camera is active all right let me uh
maximize the scene all right let me
maximize this
game view all right and let's see
see our animation is perfectly working
all right and let's remove it and then
again
bring it
see our animation is working so we have
to do the same thing all right we have
to do the same thing for the bottom
container too and
you know what will happen our
first business card will be created
all right
okay
so drag and drop the bottom container
then again click on play
all right and then in the on target lost
again drag and drop this bottom
container
and then
uh
click stop playback
all right
and
let's see
so now let let me show you all right
see the animations are perfectly working
right
isn't this uh great
so like this you can create your own
avatar like see
uh this uh means your own business card
see here you can see this there is avada
and it is also blinking
can you see that see it is also blinking
so our business card is perfectly
created all right so now what you have
to do is
uh you have to build this application
and to do that you simply have to go to
file build settings and click on build
the application and give it a name and
save it alright so that's it so this is
how we create a business card all right
so hey guys
in this lecture we are going to create
our last project that is of euphoria
that is we are going to create our last
augmented reality application in these
series
all right after these after this uh
module we are going to start with spark
ar so it's also going to be really
exciting to work with sparky so
yeah without any further ado let's get
started
so the very first thing all right i want
you to uh is set up your unity engine
already is to set up your view fourier
engine you already know how to do that
it's fairly simple first the very first
step is go
create your unity like unity project all
right after that uh go to your build
settings
in the build settings all right you
would be finding
android option all right if you don't
have android option means if if it is
showing something like this uh no
android module loaded install it install
with unity that means you haven't
installed your android module so do that
after that what you have to do is click
on build so in not build i'm really
sorry you have to uh an
app an option would be coming called
switch platform all right like uh like
this switch platform so
as i'm already switched to android it's
showing me build
but uh in your case it will be showing
switch platform so click on switch
platform and after you are done done
switching your platform go to the player
settings
all right go to the player settings and
here add the company name at the product
name all right then go to resolution and
presentation
in here you'll be uh getting an option
of default orientation i uh for in my
case all right in my case i want it to
be landscape lift uh
i'm adjusting this just because for the
camera position of my device
all right and in the other settings
we have to set up our
android build version so currently it is
getting all the api levels all right uh
the one i all i means i always go for is
android 6.0 all right you can even go
for android 4.4 alright it's totally
upon you
uh so i'm again going to go with android
6.0 all right
so here here i have
selected android 6.0 there are multiple
api levels i have i have up to api level
30 that is android 11. you can choose
any one from these and i suggest you not
to go above android 6.0 all right
because nowadays most like
most of the device starts
from 6.0 like
four to five year old mobile phones have
android 6.0 in them so
uh
means take the api level as high as 6.0
all right
don't go above it
as of now
now you can even select android 4.4
kitkat all right it's totally upon you
and leave the
target api level to automatic highest
install all right just like it is and uh
yeah
we uh our setup is done
all right
now what i want you is to uh import
the viewforia engine you already know
how to do that and i have already
imported view 4d engine just cause
because it's going to take a lot of time
to import in my system all right if your
system is fast it's it's not going to
take so much time but in my case it took
a lot of time so i've already imported
it and you already know how to import it
all right so
now
let's uh
first create our user interface all
right that is the main menu
after that we are going to set up our
viewfore engine
all right and uh
you see
i'm pretty sure that you already know
how to use the ar camera how to use the
image target right how to use
uh
means how to use the dashboard means the
website for getting the license for
adding the image targets all right i'm
pretty sure you know that and
i i want you to try this ar encyclopedia
yourself first all right try this one
first by yourself all right
and then watch the video all right
because that would be a really good
practice for you
so you can do that or even watch the
video and develop along with it all
right
now let uh i i already have a scene this
is the sample scene all right i just
want to rename it because the uh in here
i am going to create the ui
so
hit a rename and
let's name it main menu
all right it's asking to reload okay
cool so we have
basically
renamed our main menu all right now what
we have to do is we have to uh provide a
canvas to it right uh because uh the
main menu is going to be our ui all
right and uh one more thing i would like
to tell you that this
this ar encyclopedia project is based on
dinosaurs all right currently uh i have
included three dinosaurs all right you
can add as many as you want the three
are triceratops uh t-rex and the
spinosaurus
all right so you can add as many as you
want and even launch uh
this product after developing it all
right and i have al also created the ui
assets already all right
i'm also going to show you how to play
pause and stop an audio in this tutorial
so
hang tight there and for the tutorial
so first of all right click in here and
go to ui and
click on canvas
all right and in here in the top you
would be finding a 2d option click on
that 2d option and then
double click on the canvas option and it
would be focused
all right so and the thing go to the
game window all right and
choose a resolution
see for uh developing a responsive ui
what i generally do is i have three
resolution all right one one is of
iphone 6 that is the medium resolution
one is
of uh
not exactly the medium all right but i
have iphone 6 that is the lowest
resolution i have oneplus 7 that has the
highest resolution and redmi note 5
that has
the
medium resolution all right so what i
want you to do is uh you also follow
these uh three
means these three presets
you can create your own by like uh
in the game window here you'll be
finding a drop down go in here and click
on this add button give it a name uh
give it and width and height all right
so and click on ok it would help you
create
a
means
a basically a resolution of any phone
you want all right so currently i want
to go with iphone 6 all right this looks
good
now what i want is uh
in this canvas i'm going to create a you
know panel all right for attaching my
background image in here so i just want
to stretch this you know stretch this
panel out a bit because let me show you
why
uh go to a game window if i'm not sure
if it's visible to you or not but uh
just wait
if if you can see uh here are some edge
edge spots like uh the panel isn't
covering the whole uh you know whole
canvas so that's creating a problem so
that's why i'm going to you know stretch
it out a bit
okay
and uh now what i want to do is i want
to uh click on the panel all right then
in the color image here is an option of
alpha
i want to increase it all right so that
it doesn't uh means
it is not transparent all right and in
the background here you can see source
image i am clicking this button to
select the image all right
and
in here let me see yeah i got the
background image in here all right so
this is the background image i'm going
to use let's see how it looks yeah it
looks good
all right
and now
what i want to do is i want to give it a
heading right so i have also created an
asset folder so click on this image all
right click on this image and let's
let's give it a name that is
heading all right after you give it a
name of heading what you have to do is
you have to choose the title all right
that this is i have kept the title as
dynapedia all right
so i'm going to adjust this particular
asset a bit all right so that you know
it uh
it fits good to the ui
and
you have to do one thing all right
go to this particular transform alt and
you know
then
anchor it on the top all right
now uh adjust it a bit all right
and let's see how it looks yeah it looks
good let's stretch it out a bit no
let's uh let's stretch it out a bit okay
yeah
all right now it looks good now
let's drop it down a bit all right let's
drop it down a bit
okay
cool
now
i have to add a button in here that is a
start button all right so i'm again
there are two ways you can do that all
right i'm i'm going for the image one
but let me show you first of all go to
uh ui you can simply select uh button
you know uh simply select a button and
then from that uh button delete the text
all right but uh
i don't want to do that i'm going to do
a very simple thing that is go to ui
select an image
all right and
you know
select the start button asset all right
and then again uh you know stretch it
out a bit all right
so that it looks you know looks good all
right now now that it looks good
what i'm going to do is uh also anchor
it all right and cut it maybe
actually let's anchor it in the center
only let's
keep it at the center click on start
button
all right oh i guess one thing i forgot
yeah see
i always forget to make this change all
right whenever i'm created creating a ui
and
i just it just comes to my mind after
many things are done and
i again forgot to do that all right i'm
really sorry about that actually in the
canvas all right click on this canvas
here you'll be finding
an option
or means a component in the inspector
called canvas scaler in there you will
be finding ui scale mode
what you have to do is uh you have to
change it to scale with screen sets and
see
this is why uh
i like i really hate it when i forget
about you know setting up all the things
in the ui
so it happens with me a lot all right so
yeah
forget uh forgive me about this but uh
yeah now as everything's working fine
all right
we are good
right
so yeah
let's you know uh let's make this button
a bit more shorter just wait
all right
where is the button here gotcha
yeah it looks looks good
now in the start button all right as it
is an image we won't be able to click
this image or of course we won't be
because it is not a button right now to
make this image a button what you have
to do is you have to click on add
component
in here all right you have to search for
uh something called button all right and
here you would be getting a
option for button all right and now this
image is a button all right this image
is transformed into a button
right now i want you to create another
image all right go to the ui
um
then you know let's let's give it a size
of let's say
60 60.
yeah i guess that's that's really cool
then again select another ui that is the
quit you you quit button all right of
course you want to give a quiz button
right
so so that people can quit from the
application right
now what you have to do is again click
uh
click on this rec transform click alt
and
yeah here you go we have our button
aligned
right on the bottom
left
all right now let's see
here it looks good now
let's just do one thing
let's you know
shift it
on a bit or change the position of it
all right and let's make the size 50 50.
yeah now now again let's change it to 40
40. yeah this looks this looks really
good
right
so we have created our
main menu all right
now as we have created our main menu now
what you have to do is uh we have to
create
our arc
all right so
let's see how to do that
first of all as you have created a main
menu
congratulations and what i want you to
do is
go to file click on build settings
and add this main menu on the top all
right and always remember whenever
there's
let's say there are multiple scenes
alright three to four scenes
always remember to put the main menu all
right to put the main menu on top of
every scene all right because uh this
would
mean the scene in the top all right the
scene in the talk will be the main scene
all right would be the means in in the
sense that it would uh means after
building the application
the application would start with the
scene that is on the top all right so
always remember to keep the main menu on
the top all right
so yeah as our you know our main menu is
done now what we can do is we can create
another scene uh that would be our
ar scene right so right click click on
scene and let's name it arc
all right and let's open it now i want
to enable the directional light so let's
do it
i'm going to select the common lighting
settings i have all right and yeah we
are good to go
now what you have to do is
let me show you first of all uh first of
all the very first thing is i want you
to create a basic ui
the the ui would be containing back
button
all right so what you have to do is go
to canvas
in the canvas
what you have to do is
uh change the constant pixel size to
scale with screen size all right and
then in there
click on ui
then add an image
all right then select the back button
um change the width to 50 50
all right
and uh let's
you know
anchor it to the top right side top left
right now
let's change the position of it let's
say 50
and minus 50 all right so let's see how
it looks
now it's uh it's a bit too much so go
for 40 and you know minus 40.
yeah this looks good
all right so this is one of our ui and
also add a button component to it okay
so i i somehow added another component
this is virtual but
button behavior and of course i don't
want that
just to wait let me remove this whole
thing
okay yeah
just uh
let me again reconfigure the button okay
cool now go go in here and add a button
component all right and
yeah our button is created and rename
this button to
back
button
all right now for uh further all right
for further development we have to set
up our view for your engine all right so
it's fairly simple
delete the main camera all right delete
the main camera
then
add a v40 engine ar camera
all right and you know drag it and drag
it to the top
all right now as we have the ar camera
we have to you know create a license so
what you have to do is click on get
basic
and in here give
a license name or as i want as my app's
name is dynapedia i'm going to
give it a dynapedia license name all
right and
simply just
you know copy the license key
great
so now that we have our license key
go to ar camera click on open view for
your configuration
all right and paste it
okay so now our license key also set up
now one thing uh just give me some time
alright i'm going to prepare the markers
all right and then i'm going to come
back and show you how to also add the
markers all right and how to use it in
your project
all right
so now we have
downloaded all the markers we needed all
right now what you have to do is go to
your target manager
click on add database
then give it give it give the database a
name let's say dynopedia
db all right so then click on create
and it's going to create a database for
you
so
now what you have to do is
after opening the database you have to
add the targets all right so
click on single image all right choose
the
image file all right
so
this is not the one just yeah here i got
it
now this is the marker one all right so
let the name be marker one and give it a
width of let's say six
all right and uh wait it for wait for it
to add the target
and
let's add another target all right
okay
let's again give it a weight of
6 and
add it
all right let's add another target all
right see all these markers are taken
from google all right so you can find
them on google only
then
click on add
okay cool so we have our markers all
right and all of them are four star
markers and that's totally fine anything
uh between three to five is okay but
less than that
don't even like give uh don't even work
out with those markers all right and
even i would suggest not to go for three
star markers also because their tracking
is also not up to mark all right so
always have markers having four to five
stars not less than that now we have to
download the database all right uh i'm
going to download the database
so it's going to take a few minutes and
then it would uh start downloading
all right
so
let me save the dynapedia you know
package in here
and
after it's downloaded
let's
import it
all right
so
here got a window pop-up and uh click on
import
so now it has started importing our
assets
means our markers all right and we are
good to go now
as
everything in here alright is is working
pretty fine
our air can uh ar camera is set up all
right now we have to set up our
marker so how we how do we do that first
of all go out of 2d mode all right
go out of 2d mode and uh
click on uh there's right click view
fourier engine image target all right in
the image target
click on from database
select the database
and get one marker all right and i'm
going to get
the first marker for the first marker of
course
all right here is our first marker
now
what i want you to do is click on the
image target in here you will be finding
an option tracked or extended track
click on track
all right and let's give it a name
marker
one or let's uh keep the marker one for
the t-rex all right or let's name it
t-rex marker
all right let's add you know another
another marker
and uh again
let's select from the let's get the
marker too all right let's shift it uh
in the side a bit all right
now
name it spinosaurus
marker all right
now again view fourier engine
another image target
now
name it triceratops
all right now select from the database
get the database and you know there is
our marker
all right so we also got about so we
have our three markers right in here
all right okay uh let me uh shift it to
tracked only all right oh all right so
let's check if everything
is set up correctly or not yeah
everything is set up perfectly
fine
now i have the models imported in here
alright it is of spinosaurus t-rex and
triceratops
now what i want you to want to do is
i am simply going to
add first of all i'm going to add the
t-rex model in here all right
right in here all right
and you know it's uh it's
really really big
and i'm going to scale it down a bit all
right and
make it like this
all right
okay
cool
so here we go
we
let's you know let's make him settle
down a bit
all right
okay
cool so here our first
you know
first model for the marker is ready i'm
just going to drag and drop it uh
instead of the tdx marker
all right
so our first one is ready uh let's you
know let's get the second one that is of
the spinosaurus
all right ah very cool
great one actually
let's set up this one too
all right
if you want you can add rotations but uh
for the dinosaurs one i'm going to i'm
not going to add the rotation all right
i'm not going to add rotations in here
all right
i was actually trying to get uh animated
3d models for uh for dinosaurs but uh
actually didn't uh got any
like not in the asset store not on
sketchfab
even i got some of the animated but the
animations weren't working
so
you know
that's why i had to get these
now let's again add this one oh
this says triceratops
all right let's add this buddy in here
okay
cool
so now we also have our triceratops
right in here all right okay
very cool so now uh let's uh again make
it a child of our tri set of marker
all right so now
our 3d models are set up now you might
be thinking oh this is it our third
project is done no it's not because i'm
going to show you something more
what see this is an encyclopedia right
there is an er encyclopedia
how can we call
something an encyclopedia if it doesn't
have any information about that
particular
thing that it is in there
right
so of course i'm going to add some more
things to it all right as there's an ar
book this is an ar encyclopedia i'm
going to add information too so how
would we do that
fairly simple you need not to
worry first of all go to the tx marker
create a canvas
yeah right create a canvas
so create a canvas all right
remove the remove the constant pixel
size and change it to scale with screen
size all right in here you'll be finding
sort order
give the sort order all right sort order
means it would be
means it would keep this particular
dinosaur layer means this particular tdx
canvas on top of
the main canvas in here all right so
that's why i give
it
a sort sort order of one
all right so that it doesn't overlaps or
something
right now uh go to your 2d mode all
right
go to your 2d mode select the canvas
first of all i want to disable this you
know this
main canvas so that i get the full
trx canvas in here now what i want you
to do is right click
ui
image
give it a width of you know 60
all right give it a weight of
anchor it down to the you know bottom
left
and you know change the position to 40
and 40
all maybe
50 and uh
50 actually let's check if it's aligning
with you know this particular canvas
let's check this one
all right and uh you know select this i
button all right this is going to be our
information button and i'm i want it's
size of this button means i want
size of this button to be like this all
right so width and height is 50 and 50
let's give it
50 and 50
all right and let's make it
and 40.
all right very cool all right so yeah
one of our canvas is ready
now what i want you to do is you have to
add uh you know another image that is go
to ui
image
all right
in here i have a panel right in here all
right
and i want let's say let's just scale it
up a bit all right
and uh
let's anchor it down in here and let's
reposition it
okay
all right let's see if any spaces are
left or not i don't want any spaces to
be left
or
all
right
okay cool so now let's see in our canvas
all right let's you know
let's let's increase the size of of the
panel a bit all right
now it looks you know
good right isn't it let's let's check
okay
so yeah this this ui works with
you know all
the basic resolutions we have
right
now
first of all this
it's i is a button so i'm going to name
it information
button all right and uh
you know what i'm going to do add a
button component to it
this image is you know a panel so i'm
going to name it
panel
and all the information alright would be
all right all the information would be
under this
panel so what i'm going to do is right
click
make sure now all the things i'll be
creating all right
will be this uh
panels child already the text and all
that stuff so i'd be creating will be
this panel style all right
so what you have to do is ui
image
all right we have an image
select the heading that is information
heading
right
now
let's resize this thing a bit
mm-hmm
all right
okay
cool now
again rec transform alt anchor it in
here
uh reduce you know scale it down a bit
okay
cool we are good to go now also one more
thing we have to add in text in here
before adding a text all right first of
all let's name the change the name of it
i'm going i was going to say name the
change of it
now we have to add some more button that
is play pause and stop button
again go to you know image
and
let's anchor it down as of now all right
and let's
let's get the button uh size that is the
player this will be the play button
all right
let's you know
drag and you know
let's change the size of
it okay
cool so now
just wait
all right
okay let me let me start it from again
so again go to you know ui
image
you know bef
let's do all the thing before anchoring
it all right
let's get the width to be 20 maybe
okay cool
now
anchor it down
all right
now
reposition it
so you know it looks
good
duplicate it all right
again duplicate it
okay
so now it does look good
all right
make it to the center alright so that it
looks okay okay that's that's pretty
good
change the name to play button
change this one's name to pause button
all right
[Music]
just give a moment all right and change
this one's name to
stop button actually uh i i have the
audios all right this would be playing
the audios in there
so also select all the three buttons uh
add uh you know button component in here
and
we are good to go now oh yeah also i
have to change you know the picture of
it right so i'm going to do that
okay so
pause button got the pause icon stop
button is going to get the stopper now
oh yeah you got it
all right
it looks good right now let's add a text
in here all right so click on ui always
use text mesh pro all right
use nothing except xmas pro
now first of all let's change the text
color to black all right
and
let's
resize it all right let's resize it
um
change the text size to 20
and uh
first of all we have to create a font
asset because we have a different type
of font and
let me show you one thing this uh
text mesh for only except sdf type fonts
alright
so
currently the font i already have a font
called comic new
all right
so this is uh comic new bold so
this is a font already but we won't be
able to apply it uh let me show you see
we are not able to apply it so to apply
any font
for into text mesh pro it's very simple
click on window
all right click uh here we'll be finding
uh text mesh pro
click on font asset creator
uh window will be popping up
drag and drop this font asset in here
all right click on generate font alias
all right so it's going to take a few
seconds and uh it would be like you know
creative create the font asset for you
within no time
all right and uh click on save
so here we got our font asset right in
here all right and now what you have to
do is click go to the text all right
just wait go to the text and uh drag and
drop this font asset right in here and
see we got
our description panel which is
description text now i have some text
already written in here all right so i'm
just going to copy it in here
and
simply paste it in the panel
all right
cool
now
these looks pretty good
all right
doesn't they
and
center them all right like this
okay cool
now as we have got
our information panel we have to also
code all right code is code means uh
i want to click this button all right
and enable and disable this particular
panel and creating the script is fairly
simple what you have to do is go to
asset uh create a folder of called
scripts
all right okay the folder didn't got
created alright
okay
scripts
all right after you create this folder
scripts all right you have to create a
shisha script
so now
our script is created i'm simply going
to open it all right on my visual studio
so let's
get this thing going in here
all right
great
so first of all
let's start coding it
see first of all understand the
mechanics all right
you there are two ways you can do that
all right first of all uh let me tell
you one way that is the
first way would be a very simple way
actually both the ways are simple all
right
so the first way would be uh adding a
set active function to it all right
set active means uh
when you will click this button
this panel will be deactivated from the
first so set active function would
actually activate that and
with that all right also
disable this button and add another
button all right that is activate
another button that would be like
looking similar like this but would be
having a different function that is it
would be
setting uh it to false alright setting
the set active to false and that would
make this
particular information panel disappear
right
another way all right
this way is uh i prefer to do it this
way so what you have to do is first of
all create a variable
so basically in this winner you would be
using the single button only to
uh switch on and off
the panel all right
so this is a little
this is
less hectic so first of all uh
create a boolean variable
and uh
set it to false all right
let me uh increase the size of this
editor a bit now
create a serialized field all right that
is
i will tell you what is it so
game object
in for uh mission
panel basically see uh this serialize
field uh parameter basically first of
all uh understand that this is a private
all right this is a private variable and
the serialized field helps us to
serialize this that is
show this private variable in the
inspector all right so that's what the
serialized field does it it serializes
this particular
variable even though it's private in the
inspector menu all right
now
click on uh create a function that is
public void
on toggle
or
button
click
or let's say
toggle
panel
all right now
this this uh thing is fairly simple
click on means write if
if this
panel is on
what you have to do is
you have to set
active it to false all right you have to
disable it and set the
is on
to false
now in the else block
just copy this
let this two lines
and paste it in here and
change them to
you know true
all right
okay
very great
so now
let the script compile all right
so our script is compiled what you have
to do is go to uh go to this you know go
to this canvas all right
add the script in here all right add the
script in here drag and drop this you
know information panel in here and
you have the information button right so
uh in the on click parameter click on
the plus button
drag and drop this canvas in here and
you'll be finding an option called panel
toggler and click on toggle panel
all right now to test
the if to see if this is working all
right disable this uh panel
and uh
let's see
if you know if this whole thing is
working or not
all right so let's see
if everything's working fine or not
okay so
nope this is not the one
which one was it
just give me a second
all right yeah
here we go we got our information panel
button
right we also got our
model now click on this
okay
just wait let me
disable the battery saver
okay
so now it won't
turn off by itself all right
okay cool so now
see our information button is working
pretty fine all right and let's see if
our main canvas is also work
okay so our main canvas is uh the button
of main cameras is also being clicked so
everything's working fine
all right so
now
now what we have to do is we have to add
the audio functionality
right
now to do that
go to your tdx marker create an empty
object
name the empty object as
t-rex
audio all right of course this is not
the audio of you know a t-rex it is the
explanation
of
who he is right and now in the t-rex
audio game object add an audio
source
all right in the audio source uh what
you have to do is go to assets all right
uh where have i saved audio here yeah i
got it so now in the t-rex audio add
this t-rex description audio in here
all right and remove this play on awake
now as we have our tx audio in here now
what i want you to do is
go in here
uh select the
three buttons
click in here means the plus icon drag
and drop this
no drag and drop this particular audio
game object and in the audio source
select the play option all right now all
the three buttons
have the play option now we have to
change one by one all right i do this
because it
it is more faster than the usual like
just selecting one button and adding
them one by one it's much faster now in
the pause button
uh go to audio source and select the
pause
and the stop button
go to audio source
and
select the stop
all right
now let's play play it again
and let's see
if everything is working fine or not
all right
just give it a few seconds and
would be good to go
all right
so
let's see
okay
so
all right let's see tyrannosaurus is it
genius
see the pause is also working right
dinosaur
all right
so the pause play and stop is working
see
this is working pretty fine so our first
marker is totally ready now we have to
do the same thing for
every marker so i'm just going to you
know duplicate uh these two game object
right and drag and drop it under the
spinosaurus all right i'm gonna get
going to name it s audio all right it's
too much to write its whole name and uh
this this canvas let's put it up in
there
in the canvas all right
here's the panel drag and drop it in
here
and
in the buttons all right
we already have the s audio all right
means the this audio source so we don't
have to do anything else
also enable this particular button you
know and uh
in the panel all right in the panel in
the text we have to change the text all
right in the text
i have got one text just
let me bring it up in here
and
let's see let's enable this particular
panel and let's see how it looks oh it
looks really good
right
doesn't it and again
duplicate it
all right and drag and drop in the
all right and
not uh sorry triceratops not
terrance or slicks
uh and
in the canvas select the panel all right
and
inside of the panel let's see if the
buttons has the right audio or not yeah
they do now in the text all right enable
the panel
and we are going to get
the actual
all right
where is the text here
got it
now
simply go in there and
put it in here
right
okay
cool
now
all right just give a few seconds
all right
now
disable this particular panel right in
here
all right
so now in the t audio change uh the
audio to triceratops audio all right and
in the
spinosaurus rex audio
change uh into
spinosaurus x
sorry spinosaurus not tricks not tricks
already i'm really sorry
dinosaurs and dinosaur enthusiasts are
going to kill me i guess
so
yeah
let's
try this out
and let's see if everything's working
or not
all right
so give it a few seconds to run
so
let's see
so there's our first one all right this
is our special dinosaur that is t-rex
all right my favorite
so let's see if audio or the sword is
supported
all right so audio and everything is
tyrannosaurus is a genus of perfectly
stop it all right and if you let's say
uh
let's say let's do one thing
let's say if uh if if you want to stop
the audio all right if you want to stop
or pause the audio after the marker is
you know removed you can simply do that
so go to trx marker uh in the on target
lost click on add icon
um
get this audio
all right audio source and uh
i let's say i want to you know
stop the audio all right let's stop the
audio all right and again in the
spinosaurus marker do the same thing
all right
do the same thing and uh
you can do whatever you want already
when you can pause the audio and even if
you want you can start playing the audio
when the marker is tracked you know it's
totally up to you but this is what i'm
doing now
yeah
we are
good to go
right
all righty let's see
all right
okay
so let's check if everything's playing
tyrannosaurus is it
uh tyrannosaurus
so it's working now let's
let's select this one
all right
okay
triceratops is an extinct genus of
herbivorous genes
all right so clay is also working stop
is also triceratops is an extinct genus
of triceratops isn't it
all right good
now let's triceratops is an extinct
genus of herbivorous chat
all right so this one's also working
perfectly fine and let's test
this one our tries at the top so sorry
not the triceratops yeah spinosaurus
all right let's
all right so
our dinosaurs dinosaur encyclopedia is
working perfectly fine now the thing
that is left is
to code the back button
right means
the scene changing script all right so
what i'm going to do is go to script
all right
uh first of all oh yeah before going to
the script
go to fi uh build settings all right and
add this ar scene in here so currently
i'm on this ar scene so i'm just going
to click on add open scenes and always
remember
to keep the main menu on top of every
other scene you are putting in the build
settings all right
so make sure you do that now
in the in the scripts
create another script called c script
called
scene
controller
all right
now
all right so
let's code our scene controller all
right that uh that that is it will be
controlling our scene all right
that means we'll be we have to navigate
through the scenes right so we need that
so what we are going to do is
using
unity engine we have to include that
particular library
scene management
all right
so here you go
right
now
what we have to do is we have to create
three functions first of all the
function would be
public void
we are going to call it main menu this
function would be
loading the main menu all right that is
scene manager
dot
load scene and gif
give you know give this scene a name
that is main menu all right so after you
give this scene a name you have to
create another function all right public
void alright in the public void function
you have to create another sorry
so now all right
we have to create another function
alright that would be for loading
our ar scene right so public void
let's name it ar
scene right and again same
write the same line in here that is
scene manager dot load scene all right
and now in here you have to provide the
ar scene name
see these are the names all right these
are the names of the scenes we have all
right
these are the names of the scenes we
have that is the main menu and the ar
scene all right so
make sure to put uh this c name right in
here all right so make sure to do that
and another is to quit all right public
void
quit app
all right
now scene
[Music]
manager
dot
load scene
and so not loads in what i'm doing i'm
very sorry okay just tweet oh yeah
application
dot
quit
all right so that would help our
application
to quit all right and
let's compile the script
so now our script is compiled what you
have to do is create an empty game
object reset its position all right and
name this empty game object as scene
controller
all right because
this empty we'll be attaching our scene
controller script to this empty game
object now what you have to do is go to
canvas click on the back button in the
back button click on on click click on
the plus icon in the scene put the scene
controller down there and click on scene
controller and
after clicking the back scene you should
load the main menu all right now we have
to do the same thing with our main menu
all right and in the meantime we also
have to check if everything is
responsive or not right so let's check
it all right really really great
yeah everything's
totally fine
right
now
again in here create an empty home
object called scene
controller
reset its transform
uh add the
you know scene controller script in here
in here you will be finding uh
okay this i forgot to rename this button
let's rename it squared button
all right now in the start button
alright we have an on click function
simply add it in there
scene controller
and click on this arc because it would
be loading about ar scene and again i
also forgot to add
a button component
to this
quit button
click on the plus sign
scene controller
scene controller then again
quit app
all right so now
everything's done now let's play this
scene and let's see if everything's
working fine or not all right and if
everything works fine we are done with
our application right and
you can actually launch this application
on play store if you want all right
so
and
actually before launching i would
suggest you to add some more information
all right now let me tell you one thing
this uh this quit button is working all
right the squid button is perfectly
working fine but uh you can see nothing
is happening because currently we are
not on our phones so when you you will
be in your phone and pressing the squid
button
it will be working perfectly fine all
right and i'm not sure why there's uh
here is one button i have to check all
right so
everything's uh first of all let me
check if the function is right right
yeah quit uh the function is right so
quit button will work perfectly fine now
click on the start button all right and
let's let's see it load all right
cool
now
let's try out our markers just let me
open the markers all right
all right
okay cool
so now
everything's you know working perfectly
fine asaurus is a genus
okay cool so just like this every other
marker will work and let's click on the
back button yeah cool so we are able to
navigate through our scenes right so
this is working perfectly fine and uh
which button is this one all right also
it's uh
not inside the canvas so it's not
necessary so delete it i guess i have
added it by mistake
so
we are done with this project and
hopefully you have learned
how to create your own ar books all
right how to create your own ar
encyclopedias and if you want you can
launch this application
after developing on play store
all right and also add
ads to earn money
so
yeah
for this lecture this is it and
best of luck for
and also create more projects like this
all right and in the next module of this
course we are going to explore spark
here
all right so
yeah
stay tuned
in this lecture we are going to learn
about sparky studio will be getting an
overview of the interface we'll be
learning about the spark air ecosystem
all right and we'll be doing a lot more
things all right but before using sparky
studio you need to download it so
this is the link all right sparky dot
facebook.com
studio slash download all right so you
just need to click on the download the
installer would be uh downloaded on your
system and the process is pretty simple
you just need to install it all right
it's like any other installation process
all right so
from this this website you have to
download it all right now
here is the interface all right this is
a dashboard all right now
with this dashboard we actually manage
our projects within uh sparky all right
so first of all this is the basic
interface
here are the templates all right this is
the first uh
area that you you are going to see after
installing and opening the sparky studio
here here are three uh weld mints
three
blank templates all right that is oh one
is totally blank that is blank project
and there is sharing experience and
video calling experience
all right and other other than tho these
three
here are uh
some more all right so these are the
basically uh templates made by the
sparky our team and other creators all
right so here you can see there are
multiple uh multiple multiple
templates that you can get this there is
a face decoration there is face mask
then there is body tracking
then there is neck decoration then there
is head tracking all right so
these are the templates that you can
explore all right there here here is a
real scale world object tool that is
that it means
real world like real world scanning
market scanning so
you you can
like
try to explore all these templates
alright it would give you a humorous
like huge amount of knowledge all right
so
these are the templates that you can
work with now
let's say uh after this course you want
to explore uh more of spark here all
right so spark here has their own
platform where they are there are two to
three courses on sparky that is
fundamentals of spakia then there is uh
like a totally free means
those are totally free all right then
there is advanced sparkier all right so
you can
find it on
on the internet uh it's by facebook only
it's totally free you can
watch there all right and if you want to
learn more advanced ar development all
right then i'm also going to launch
one course all right uh it's an ex it's
called exa01 augmented reality for
everyone all right so it's an augmented
reality mastery course you can get that
course it would be a very low cost
course and it would be
launching very soon uh at my at my
startup uh and turned all right so
make sure to
subscribe my channel to get the updates
about it all right so
here are the tutorials that you can get
here you can see there are multiple
tutorials available about the coding all
right about
means about creating a glow effect about
face tracking alright so you can learn
it from that and here are the recent
projects alright here are the recent
projects that you can uh
like if you if you create some projects
all right inside of sparky you will get
those listed down in here all right and
here is uh open option all right so if
you if you have a project file then you
can open
that project file from there all right
and here is the creator community option
then fordham option and what's new
option all right
so this is it all right now
to create a new project you have to
click on blank project all right so we
would be choosing the blank project and
it would start creating the blank
project for us all right
so here you can see that our blank
project has opened up all right so let's
uh get a bit comfortable with the
interface all right
so the very first thing all right the
very first thing you are going to see is
there is a person all right here you can
see this there is a person who is like
rotating its head all right and here is
a very small mobile like window all
right here is a very small mobile like
window that you can uh
see seen here so here here is a
simulation happening all right this is
the person so basically now these are
test persons so whenever we create any
sort of marker all right whenever we are
going to create any sort of marker
these uh these are the test persons that
would be working with all right so um
we'll be testing our markers on these
test process all right so this is kind
of a small phone you could say alright
this kind of a small phone or you can
also say
this is a testing window just like uh in
unity uh you can even dock and undock it
all right like click on this unlock
option then it would be undocked or
simply when it is docking you can drag
it drag it down all right and you can
keep it anywhere you want all right but
i i prefer this
one to be on the top
all right so that that's where i'm going
to keep it now
let me let me shorten this window all
right let me make the
size small now here you can see that we
are able to uh see
here's a total
new scene where uh a camera actually is
there means there's this triangle thing
is there and here's a film going on all
right has a video uh going on so let me
tell you what are these so first of all
uh in unity all right i introduced you
to the scene window right in that scene
window we used to add objects we can we
could manipulate those objects in there
right similarly in spark here
there is
viewport window all right so basically
this viewport window what it does is we
can add objects from uh in the in the
scene panel and uh manipulate those
objects from here all right so that is
it and here you can see there's a some
kind of like phone like structure this
one this one uh this this thing have a
phone like structure this is basically a
phone all right there's a simulated
phone there this it is showing that the
phone camera is actually like projecting
the
filter on top of it all right so this is
basically the camera all right
so i hope you understand right now this
is basically as i told you this is the
scene window all right and this one is
kind of like the game window in uh
unity all right uh so this
game window
in sparky are two all right so this
this is you we use this one for
simulating
all right now
as we uh learned about hierarchy in
unity right similarly in sparky also
there's another panel this is called
scene panel all right so what exactly it
does is it contains all the objects that
are present in the scene right you can
add add new objects in it you can
manipulate those objects right from here
all right like uh here you can see here
is the camera object right in here all
right here is the camera object
right so this is the hierarchy window
from unity all right so try to
understand it like this
now
let's see uh
the inspector window off you know
sparkier actually in sparky it is called
properties window alright but if you
want you can even call it call it
inspector window all right but it is
actually known as properties window so
this uh this is also like the unity
inspector window all right it also
contains all the editable uh properties
of a particular object right like here
you can see that we can see
oh if we click the camera we can see its
properties right in here here uh
there are multiple options in there
these are not editable of course but uh
let's say uh let's let's try out this
directional light so here you can see
that uh this directional light is
editable we can decrease and increase
the uh
means intensity we can change the
positions uh we can change the rotations
right so we can edit those all right
this is kind this is property window
just like the inspector window from
unity all right now in unity there was
also something called uh
project window right similarly here goes
and uh here is also one project window
called assets window all right so this
is uh like it is two uh it is under
it is basically under the scene panel so
you can see it right in here and you can
actually
drag and drop or import the assets right
in here all right
now
this is for the basic interface all
right now let me show you some more
things all right like let's say i want
to for for for testing my uh
filter better like for adjusting the
filter what i can do i want to pause
this character right so
right
or in your left alright like in the in
the left of
the interface you would see a pause
button if you click on that pause button
the the video the video playback would
be paused right
now if you again play then it would
start playing right now let's say oh i
don't want that character all right i
want to uh test with
many other characters there is all right
because uh his face like the shape of
his face is different than others right
so i want i also want to adjust the 3d
model uh to others like to other phase
shape right so what i can do is i can
simply
get another one in here right uh then
there's another one then there's another
one
then
there are many presets available all
right and if you if you want to try it
on yourself then
there are like the currently i'm on my
laptop so this is the camera i have
already called easy camera so i can i
can click on that and get the camera
view on here right but currently i don't
want the camera view so i'm going to
keep this person right now all right so
this is basically
the
things that you would be needing as of
now i like to create the projects and
i'd also be telling you many other
things as far as we move right and uh
let me let me
show you all right how you can get uh
free 3d models free 3d means free
patches and all those things from in
spark are only all right so just uh what
you have to do is in in the assets panel
you have to click on this ar library all
right and a window will appear something
like this all right so let me pause this
character for a minute all right let me
plot pause it alright and
let's get this this window all right so
here you can see that
there are multiple uh multiple options
in here there already there are multiple
templates available first of all let's
say i want a 3d object right i can click
on 3d objects or search for any 3d
objects i want all right so and pick it
from there all right these these 3d
models are free to use all right and uh
let's say i want uh in any sort of music
or sound i can i can get that right i
can get that from sparky only then there
are patch assets patch are basically
there's there's two ways to uh code in
sparky one is a visual scripting that is
the patch editor where you have to move
blocks here and there and connect a one
block to another to code and there is
that we can code it through scripting
all right so
there are presets available you can use
those presets all right let's say if we
want textures we can get those textures
from here also if you want
uh
blocks all right we can also go get
those blocks from here if you want the
script packages all right we can also
get these script packages from here if
you want if we want color luts we can
even get these from here all right so
spark here has a pretty good ecosystem
for its creators all right and if you
talk about
how to launch our own filters all right
so to launch our own filters
what you or what you would be needing is
a facebook account all right and an
instagram account
to launch your uh
ar filters on instagram
all right so make sure you have a
facebook account at least all right and
uh
of course uh to upload it on instagram
you also need a instagram account right
so yeah cool great
so this is it for uh this lecture all
right see you in the next lecture
thank you
in this lecture we are going to learn
about face tracking
face mesh
all right and ah and we will also be
creating our first filter based on face
mesh all right so make sure to watch
this video till the end
so
we are talking about face tracking right
what is face tracking all right what
exactly it is it all right see face
tracking is a concept all right face
tracking is an algorithm that actually
helps us to track our face right like
for example you can see this person
right in here all right he is moving his
head left and right
up and down right if we attach an
face tracking algorithm or module what
will happen it would it would track this
person's face like
for example see this person is moving
his head upward then also the face
tracker will also
point upward all right
so that's how a face tracker would work
it would track the person's face
right
it would it will it will take all right
it would actually
take the person's head rotation
and
movement from the real world and
put those values inside of the
editor all right so that it can perform
other tasks
that's
that is what a face tracker is all right
now adding a face tracker is very simple
all right what you have to do is you
have to go to the your scene panel in
the scene panel there you would be
finding a
plus button you have to click on the
plus button all right and in here in the
first option
will be there
face tracker right now if you are not
able to find the face tracker you can
simply search it in here that is face
tracker
and after
you do that
uh click on the face tracker and click
on insert
all right
so
here you can see
here you can see the anchors right you
are able to see the anchors right
the you can see that with the face all
right
with the rotation and movement of the
face the anchors are also moving right
so that's how face tracking works all
right that is what face tracker does
right
now
as you have learned about phase trackers
and spark are now there's left face mesh
right to make your see face mesh now is
a sort of a layer on your face all right
it's it's kind of another another object
on your face all right you can
understand the face meshes that's like
this all right
now to add a face mesh click on this
face tracker all right then click on add
and uh
right
face mesh and you would find the face
mesh all right and click on insert
so here you can see
that
we added our face mesh right it looks
like checkers board right so not
checkers board but a chess board
right
so one more thing you have to remember
all right that whenever if you want to
make like if you are attaching the
objects which can totally work with your
face tracker all right that is uh use
face tracker for tracking the face then
make sure all the objects that you are
putting in your scene all right
to make it a child of the face tracker
object all right why
because uh
here you can see that uh as the person
is moving its head this particular face
mesh is also moving all right moving and
rotating
that's how it is working right so that's
why i told you to make the objects of
like a child of the face tracker only if
you want
uh to like you know uh make it rotate
and move on the
player's head movement and rotation
right
so
that's how it all works right now as we
have added a face mesh
we can also add a material to it all
right so what you can do is click on
face mesh in here in the properties
panel you'll be finding a material
section and here you find finding an
plus button so click on this plus icon
and here you'll be
a material would be created in your
assets panel and
see a material is also added
right
now
if you want you can uh like you know
change the color color of the material
all right so simply select the material
go to its properties and uh
change the color all right change the
color to whatever you want all right you
can keep it red you can keep it you know
green you can keep it yellow
uh you can keep it blue anything you
want all right but for for now i want to
keep it uh you know
white
right
so now as we have learned to create our
own face tracker and our own face mesh
right now what we have we what we can do
is we can add textures to it all right
now this is a bit tricky part all right
if you're familiar with photoshop
uh then this would be a bit helpful to
you like you helpful means easy to you
all right
so
let me show you
go to your browser first all right
download these face reference assets all
right because these these face reference
assets are going to be really really
useful to us
all right so just uh go to this
particular website you can you can
simply write on the internet uh sparky
or face reference assets all right you
would get get them in there now what you
can do is you can click on this face
reference assets and it would start
downloading downloading a zip file after
you extract it all right go to the
textures folder and you'll be finding
two textures all right
one is phase feminine and one is face
masculine these are basically face
reference assets all right to create the
textures for our face
okay so
uh i'm for this for this example i have
used means for this tutorial i have used
face masculine you can even use face
feminine if you want all right now what
you have to do is
uh open photo p or if you have photoshop
in your system you can open that all
right i have used photo pages it's like
photoshop button online
so now what you can do is
uh first of all import this face
masculine in here all right import this
face masculine in here and
import your line face texture uh for me
it's a line face picture you can use any
texture if you want all right now what i
did is i pressed ctrl in my
you know i pressed control in my
keyboard and uh
mapped it like this just wait
okay here you can see that i uh
mapped it
to the proportions of
the face
all right
to the proportions of the face of the
this particular reference picture all
right and here you can see you can like
you just have to press ctrl right you
just have to press control and
edit the transforms alright and you
would be good to go and always make sure
that these eye holes all right are in
place of
this reference assets eyes all right so
make sure you do that
okay and this is it and then what you
can do is you can simply like you know
uh turn off this background layer and
add another transparent layer and you
can simply
go to file or export as png and
your you know your
texture would be exported right i have
already done that now what you can do is
simply drag and drop it uh inside your
asset all right that is inside your
editor so i'm just going to drag and
drop it in here
all right
so yeah
now is it is uh you know uploaded on
within
the it is uploaded within our
spark studio
all right now what you can do is
sometimes what happens now your uh it
would uh start actually not sometimes
every time it happens that it would
start uh compressing it all right and
mine is already compressed it's it was
so fast so what you can do is all right
it makes uh makes the editor slow
alright it makes spark ar slow if for
the moment alright for the moment you
can uh select it to uh means
uh in the ios section make it to none
then in the android and older or android
also make it to none so it would
stop the compression for a moment and
when when you whenever you will be
publishing a filter that is
exporting it and then publishing it
it would start the compression it will
compress your filter and then you can
upload it now always remember to
compress your filter before uploading it
to sparky sorry uh to instagram or
facebook all right so make sure you do
that now as we have learned to create
our face tracker our face mesh
let's add a texture to the face mesh all
right this is also very simple we
already have our line face which is
mapped to the reference image
select the material
in here you'll be finding a texture
section uh click on this image thing and
select the texture all right and
here you go you got the texture in your
spark right so that's how we work with
face meshes
all right
um you can also like uh add uh you know
occlusion effect in this phase mesh in
the next lecture only we would be
learning about occlusion uh because we
are we will be implementing our own 3d
model in sparky
all right but for this lecture this is
it and we learned about face tracker we
learned about phase meshes and also
created our first uh phase filter
right
so yeah
so as you are already aware of
spar kr all right and you already know
how to create 2d filters with spark air
right
now it is a very high time to learn how
to create 3d filters already that is
used 3d models with and with the number
of filters all right so
the first thing all right what you uh
what i want you to do is or click on go
to settings
that is project properties
uh click on change project properties
all right
here you will see a tab experiences so
click on add experience
and
select this sharing experience and click
on
insert
all right
so after you have done that we are good
to go with the project
now what you have to do is
uh add a 3d model the first of all add a
3d model of it
all right click on ar library
and find for a 3d model you want all
right
so let's say uh
let's get a cap all right let's get a
cap
it's uh let's get actually a 3d cap
right now
let's get this pokemon's masters cap
right
click on import
it will start downloading the model all
right
so it has completed downloading the
model now close this window and
cool
so we are good to go now
click on this focal distance or camera
alright
then
click on add that is this plus sign and
add a face tracker all right select the
face tracker and insert it
all right
now here you can see that our
face tracker is in place the gizmos are
working
perfectly fine
now
what i want you to do is click on this
default texture environment so not not
this one just wait
yeah this one material all these
textures all right what i want you to is
remove the compression all right because
that would
slow the
that would basically
slow spark ar
for me and i currently don't want that
yeah of course when whenever you are
publishing all that you will
uh when you will publish your
filter
make sure that uh you compress them all
right
because uh compressing the filters are
really necessary in case of
publishing it uh on
instagram or facebook all right now what
you have to do is uh get this pokemon
masters cap
that is this 3d model and drag it inside
the pokemon face tracker right now you
can see it so it's a
really really really big
now
let's scale it down that is give it a
0.2 scale
just wait
okay cool uh still it big uh let's give
it 0.00 let's say 8 point zero eight
point zero zero eight all right that's
that's too small
okay point zero
actually zero it i i think by mistake i
give 0.8 okay 0.00 sorry 0 8.08
okay
all right it's it's uh now the size look
good but here you can see all right one
more thing let's uh
remove its uh
rotation actually
okay not not this one let's give it a
rotation like this
okay
it does
have some rotational problems
just
wait
okay
minus 90.
actually let's
uh first of all let's pause the
play all right and
yeah this this is better now here you
can see we can't adjust
this cap on the person right like it's
it's not being adjusted
like it it is not fitting it's just on
top of his
head and of course we don't want that
right we don't want to just just see it
can't even go on its own face
so
now
here comes the concept of occlusion
all right see occlusion is basically now
like in real world when you put uh
let's say uh see you have two hands
right you have two hands
like uh put
one hand on top of the other hand right
would you be able to see your other hand
that is let's say if i
take one of my hand all right let's say
i take the right hand and put the left
hand on top of it so after putting it
would i be able to see uh the portion
that i covered up with uh
my left hand
we won't all right that's uh
that is what i can say is a occlusion
occlusion basically gives a more
immersive experience on it to
make it easier for you all right let's
search for ar occlusion
let me uh
get some image to make you understand
all right
okay
so
all right yeah here we go we got one
really good
image
just give a few seconds
so here you can see in this image that
first of all uh the first that that is
the left side of the image is non occlu
doesn't have any occlusion all right and
you can see that the pikachu is
like
on top of uh his
legs right and that is not giving us a
sense of emotion or also it is not
feeling realistic all right
but if we look at the second image
you would see all right that the pikachu
is behind his leg all right it's it's
not like overlapping the leg it's behind
the leg and that is what occlusion is
the person or the car
in this in the first case all right this
portion doesn't have any occlusion but
in the
second case the person the person has
an occluder all right on on his legs so
that's why he's able to hide this
particular pikachu all right so
i guess uh
occlusion the concept of occlusion is
clear all right
and if you're still confused about that
that's totally fine uh you can ask it in
the comment section and if even if you
want i can make a separate video on
explaining occlusion all right
now how do we achieve occlusion in
sparky right so first of all there's uh
there's an object actually called
a head occluder all right so what you
have to do is uh
go to the
ar library and search for occluder
it's but it's given by spark r only
you would see that in the block section
that is this second one head occluder
click on it all right it's by it's given
by spark ar team so click on import free
and it will start downloading it and
import it after its download
cool so we have imported the head
occluder
now what i want you to do is put this
head occluder uh inside
this
head right
means inside this face tracker now you
can see that uh the the means some
portion of the
cap is hidden right and
of course this is good we are able to
see the occlusion all right now uh
we have to adjust the cap
right so how would we do that
um
let's see
okay cool
so
can you see that uh occlusion is
perfectly working
we are getting the
3d effect we wanted
right isn't it
so uh
occlusion is working perfectly fine now
uh
you have to adjust
the 3d model accordingly all right so
that it fits the head
so that it fits
actually it fits the head and
you don't face any uh issues right
so that's what i'm currently doing
it's a bit tedious process actually but
the result you the end result you would
be getting is like
pretty good
just me just let me get this cap
straighten up
okay cool
let's see
this seems fine
but uh as you can see there's a bit gap
already a bit of gap on on the head now
just adjust it all right now uh
this looks good this looks pretty good
then it was previously so you have to
play with all the 3d models all right
all the occlusion effects to
get uh
to the point you want right to get to
the final result you want so it's a bit
tedious process but after you adjust it
a bit the outcomes looks really really
great all right so uh
yeah
hey guys
so this is our last lecture all right in
this lecture we are going to create a
very simple project
after we have learnt uh spark ar all
right with the basic skills we learned
about spark air all right see i i'm
going to admit that i haven't taught
uh sparky in much depth all right
because i'm going to bring out another
series all right
totally on sparky are alright which will
be covering sparky are in depth the
main idea already the main motivation
behind putting sparky are the basics of
sparky in the syllabus
the reason behind it was that i wanted i
wanted you guys to get excited about
augmented reality all right uh and
i know many of you are active active on
instagram all right i know many of you
and
you guys uh enjoy instagram so
why not make
uh one filter for instagram right so
i i i was thinking that uh it's going to
excite you and uh i guess it did so
let's jump into the video and develop
our last project right and uh
i promise you all right one thing i'm
going to promise you that more series
like this all right
more better than this are going to come
in near future all i'm improving myself
every day all right i'm going to bring
out videos on virtual reality i'm going
to bring videos on augmented and mixed
reality all right so make sure to
subscribe this channel all right so make
sure to subscribe this channel so you
don't miss any videos all right and uh
very soon i'm going to launch all right
uh most privately in the month of april
i'm going to launch a course called
exhaust 001 all right it would be a paid
course all right so the course would be
very affordable all right for so that
everyone can
learn from that course and uh
the course will be launching at my
startup that is anton all right so if
you want you can and you guys can enroll
in that course and uh i'm going to
announce that i have announced that uh
course in this video so make sure all
right if you want to learn more in depth
all right i have covered
very very in-depth
concepts of augmented virtual and mixed
reality in that
course all right there are concepts that
no one going to teach you in any of the
course
around
all right no one is going to teach you
those concepts i have included those
concepts because they are very important
all right i have included maths required
for
uh ar and vr all right that is 3d maths
so
make sure all right to
visit that course at least once all
right and if you feel like joining the
course if you want to pursue uh
augmented reality
makes reality as a career then you can
surely join that course we are going to
develop multiple projects we are going
to
get in depth of the sdks all right we
are going to get in-depth knowledge of
those sdks like viewphorias or ar code
that is a foundation
then of course sparky r we are going to
going to go into the
depth of sparky
we'll be exploring how to code in spark
and all those very important things all
right so if you want you can enroll in
that course
so
also one more thing all right
join our discord server right join
anton's discord server there are many
experts in there all right who can help
you i am in there all right so if you
have any doubt a near future you can ask
me in there all right and also you can
connect with me on linkedin alright you
can follow me on instagram so
here all the links will be down below in
the description and all the materials
all right that i have used during the
course all the project assets so
all those things will be available uh on
the website all right that is ar course
dot or netify dot app all right it would
be available in
the website so you can get all the
assets from there all right and the
spark air assets you can get from the
air library only all right
so
yeah without any further ado
let's get going
right so the very first thing is uh
click on this project properties click
on change project properties
all right make sure you do that and in
that click on add experience all right
and
uh insert the sharing experience all
right that would actually help us share
these assets on our mobile and all those
like on our instagram
uh
and all those portions right
so now the very first thing is i want
you to add a head tracker or sorry face
tracker all right so
click on this plus icon all right
and
click on this face track and click on
insert all right so here you can see our
anchor has appeared and that anchor is
moving with the face
now
i want you to add some assets all right
i want you to add some asset the very
first asset is
go to the blocks all right i guess it
was in the blocks on the right i don't
exactly remember
actually let's let's search for it
head occluder
all right oh uh okay yeah
here we got it all right so make sure to
get the hair document that is provided
by the sparky assets only all right and
uh click on import it will down it will
start downloading it
all right and after it's downloaded
click on done and
you know what to do you just
place this head occluder inside of
the face tracker
all right so here we got our head
occluder now we have to add some more
acid that is
plus click on this plus icon then click
on search ar library
all right and here we'll be adding our
glasses that is
search for steam punk
glasses
all right
so
here you will be getting this
particular glass so i'm just going to
import it
all right so it's going to take some
amount of time to download and import
the model uh model till then all right
make sure uh you subscribe the channel
alright make sure you subscribe the
channel for more
up uh
videos all right on augmented virtual
and mixed reality if you want to make a
career in
in this domain and i'm going to i'm sure
you're going to like
how this domain is like
i love this domain for
truly like
this is one of my favorite domain in
computer science
so just wait for a few seconds and it
would be downloaded
so now our
asset is
loaded right now the very first thing i
want you to do is because this thing
will make our you know sparky are slow
all right
so
what i want you to do is go in there all
right select all the assets
right in here
and uh
make sure that the compression is set to
none as of now all right
why see here you can see the size is
really big all right and of course uh
spark uh when you'll be launching this
filter spark kr won't be accepting it so
that's why
you have to compress this filter after
you are done with all the you know
uh done with all the spark means
development of your filter all right uh
i always do this so it like i
compress these all the materials after
the development is done because that
saves a lot of time for me uh like it
doesn't interrupts my development all
right the development of the filters
right now what you have to do is fairly
simple
drag and drop this object all right make
it a child of the face tracker
so here you can see it's you know really
big
right
so
it's time for us to
make it small
oh okay
first of all you know he's moving really
fast so i of course don't want that so
now what i'm going to do is i'm going to
you know
all right okay
big mistake now
all right okay cool
very cool now
uh you have to adjust this you know
adjust
this to his face
right now let's see
uh-huh
yeah this this looks pretty good
yeah this this definitely looks so good
let's uh
all right
okay see we can see his eyes also so now
this
glasses are looking very good and we
actually have you know
set up means perfectly set up written
there
now
what i want you to do is add another
asset that is going to be
you know
a hat
right or a cap maybe
so
add any asset you want all right
let's go for this one
this seems a nice fit for this
head right means for this uh
what can i say this particular glass not
head
so
just wait for it to download all right
and
cool we got it
now simply drag and drop it in here
all right
make it a child of our favorite face
tracker
and
and now you know what to do
scale it down
all right
cool
now move it a bit so that you know it
gets adjusted on
okay
let's see now
yeah this looks good
doesn't it
yeah it definitely looks good
now um
just give me a few seconds i guess
all right so i need to make it a bit
more bigger so that you know it this cap
fits this particular occluder face
all right
so
let's see now
okay this looks this looks very good
right doesn't it
all right now let's see all right
let's see
if
everything's working fine or not
all right
just okay it's compressing
so i'm just going to you know
as of now remove the whole compression
thingy
of course it's this thing is of
6 mb and that is of you know
four or four i guess it was a 4mb right
so
okay it's of 7 mb guaranteed so means
this one is of 7 mb so it's around 10 to
12 mb right so of course sparky isn't
going to accept this particular
you know this
particular model so the to fix that
problem is to compress all right to let
spark here compress
these particular you know
textures and models and after that you
can simply publish it right and let's
try this out and uh on myself all right
let's see
if it's
if it's working or not
all right just let me you know
all right
all right it's i guess because of the
background light it's not able to track
my head perfectly
but that's okay it's uh it's working
all right okay cool cool cool
all right
cool
so now if you want to publish it what
you have to do is you have to click on
this publish button
all right
then
you know click on this publish new
effect all right and currently the text
you can see the textures are being
compressed and after the compression
completes all right
here an option you are finding that is
called export all right you have to
export this particular
file into one file the the extension
view dot ar export after it is exported
all right you have to go to a dashboard
all right let me show you the dashboard
just give me a few seconds let me pause
the simulation
so this is the dashboard you can simply
go in there facebook.com
hub slash dashboard so these are the two
filters i made already uh this one was
like
a long time ago all right i had some
other filters also but i deleted them
uh so they are not here as of now so
these two are there but uh this
javascript for dev doesn't really work
because i haven't uh updated as of now
because i i guess it's been almost one
year this was my very first filter all
right and this
and this this was the one i recently
made this was a very old one like i
haven't updated since i guess it's been
more than one year yeah
so
i had other filters too so i removed
them so i'm going to like i'm currently
working on creating a whole new set of
portfolio
of sparky and
ar applications so yeah that's why i
removed the previous ones
right so now what you have to do is
click on
you know
after you are on the hub you have to
click on publish effect all right and
a new window will appear
alright
so just give it a few moments all right
just give it a few seconds and
it will open the window for you
all right
see
make sure you export the
you know the
filter asset all right because without
that you won't be able to publish your
filter
all right
okay cool see first of all uh
you have to give a name to your filter
all right so you can give any name to a
filter if you are uh
going to upload the filter that i showed
you in the
project what you can do is you can i
would like to name it weird uh
uncle maybe
i'm not sure i'm not really good at
naming all right i'm i might name it uh
weird uncle
all right
i might name it you weird uncle you can
you can name it anything you want right
after that when you uh after exporting
all that you will be getting a file.ar
export file all right simply drag and
drop that file in here and make sure the
file is
less than 40 mb all right the size of
the file is less than 40 mb and i would
suggest you to choose all platforms or
if you just want to like you know upload
the filter only on
instagram you can disable the facebook
or messenger and all the things from
here all right but currently i wanted to
publish it on all platforms the owner is
priyanja mata charity right this is the
publisher that is
the publisher is on my instagram account
here the categories you can select the
categories all right like it
what kind of uh is it it can uh it is of
sci-fi and fantasy of course it looks
like something from fantasy right it can
be of selfies
all right so
and also you can like
select the weird and scary because
weird is in its name only right and
after that you uh
for you know
for enhancing the search you you have to
add some
you should actually add some
keywords in there all right and uh
also one thing
what you have to do is you have to
record all right you have to record the
filter
all right you have to record the filter
on your phone
uh and upload the
uh
means
the video in here all right and up after
that you can use the
video thumbnail all right and
if you if if you have collaborated with
some other people also during the
development of the filter you can add
them as a collaborator in here and
there are two options that is
as soon as possible and as uh as set
time and date so you can do any of this
all right as soon as possible means uh i
generally do as soon as possible the
reason behind it is it gets uh like it
takes around three to four hours or i
think it may be even less than that they
publish that filter instantly so that is
one way and otherwise you can simply set
a particular date and time when you want
your filter to be published alright and
they don't take a lot of time to verify
the filter all right and then click on
submit and
your filter will be out for review and
after it is reviewed
if everything success if everything is
successful
you will be able
to you know
user means distributor filters on all
the platforms right and one more thing
while recording the video make sure the
video of uh
you are recording
the video of yourself only because uh
spark
spark has a policy of not using their
you know their presets means you can't
use these presets all right the presets
like this uncle uh is
you
you can't record this uncle using your
filter right you can
you can't record any of them any of the
filters in here to record it right so
you have to record all the assets by
yourself
right so you have to record the video by
yourself all right so make sure you do
that and
great and also one more thing don't use
face all right your face as uh you know
as the icon of our logo of this
particular filter all right uh make sure
to create a logo or specific for this
filter uh any you know in your
in your photoshop in canva or any
platform you prefer all right so yeah
that's it for this video and also make
sure all right you subscribe this
channel alright join our discord server
that is our antenna community
all right and
yeah
thank you
see you in the next videos